from exclusive items to portion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between KFC in India and the US this is
food Wars
[Music]
here in India we have two types of
chicken sandwiches a crispr and a Zinger
in the U.S we have two chicken sandwich
options the Chicken Little because it's
little and of course the Kentucky Fried
Chicken Chicken Sandwich the classic now
let's weigh them to see how much they
weigh obviously
this thing has not been cleaned
in a very long time all right first up
the chicken crispo our Chicken Little in
the US weighs
next up the chicken zingo
240 grams for the classic chicken
sandwich this thing is a work of arts
all right on to chicken popcorn here in
India we have it in three sizes regular
medium and large we're gonna weigh our
large popcorn to see how much we get
I actually really love chicken popcorn
I have an idea we should weigh one
popcorn chicken and add that back to the
total my bad my bad they should serve
this in movie theaters I don't want
regular popcorn anymore
I love that they sprinkle in a bunch of
sesame seeds and it adds a nice crunch
to it what sesame seeds we don't have
that all right you guys are lucky that
sounds really nice we only have one size
according to the website and the KFC I
went to and that is this
how accurate these measurements need to
be really
oh it's so good
unfortunately here in India we do not
have mashed potatoes but that would be
pretty awesome we do have fries we're
big fans of them and they come in two
sizes medium and large and in the US we
also have two sizes of fries at KFC the
individual for an individual and the
large also for an individual let us know
measure the large to see how much you
get
140 grams
that's never not funny that's the third
time that's happened and it's always
funny look at that block of fries our
largest variety
is more than double their largest fry
here's our individual
our smallest is bigger than their
largest
in KFC India we can get our chicken in
six portion sizes number one the single
piece
two piece
they like to give you one breast piece
and one leg piece
kind four piece leg piece to top it all
off the leg piece on top as they say
like cherry on top no okay now we move
on to buckets we have four sizes the
first one is a five piece bucket that
comes with only leg pieces and also does
not come in a bucket for some reason why
KFC I want a bucket next up we have a
six piece bucket and eight piece bucket
and the largest one of them all a 10
piece leg bucket it's a lot of chicken
in the US our KFC chicken comes in seven
portion sizes one which you can get a la
carte two piece with a combo three piece
for the combo four piece with a combo
then buckets that work okay we have an
eight piece
yeah eight pieces
the 12th piece
[Music]
and our largest bucket the 16 piece
ready Julie
you get the idea next up you're going to
need a drink to wash all that chicken
down here in India we don't serve cups
we just serve cans we have Pepsi 7Up
mirinda which is an orange soda Red Bull
and a Pepsi pet bottle however these
will vary from store to store in some
places they might not serve plastic and
in some places you might not get these
drinks you might get something else they
also serve something called a virgin
mojito Crusher which they don't deliver
unfortunately but here's an image of it
refreshing American drinks come in these
following sizes the regular which is 20
ounces and the large which is 30 ounces
and hey what you don't have there if you
want you can also get half a gallon bag
of your favorite drink of choice look at
this thing
it's convenient
uh
here is everything you'll find on the
menu at KFC India that you won't get in
the US here's everything you can find at
a KFC in the US you won't find in India
take a look India take a good look okay
let's start with chicken in India apart
from the crispy chicken we also get
Smoky Red Chicken woof
wow I believe this is KFC's answer to
tandoori chicken if you guys don't know
what a Tandoor is it's basically a
cylindrical oven that they light up
using wood fire or charcoal and it has a
really Smoky flavor to the meats or
breads that you cook inside of it I
doubt KFC's across the country have an
actual Tandoor but
flavoring definitely smells like that
the marinade looks like that
oh my God that's actually pretty good
you know what KFC
pretty good job you have to remember KFC
is competing with a lot of mughlai
restaurants across every Indian City
and while this doesn't have as much of
that Smoky Char that a lot of Tandoori
kebabs have
it has a lot of flavor and the chicken
is quite juicy
good job it's super spicy though so if
you're somebody who can't handle spice
go a little easy on this one when an
Indian says something spicy it's spicy I
believe you man I believe you that looks
incredible we unfortunately don't really
have anything too spicy on the menu for
the like chicken and the bone options
really the only thing that we have here
that apparently you guys don't have is
something that is like what I associate
Kentucky Fried Chicken with is extra
crispy I don't know exactly what makes
it extra crispy but it is as you can
imagine crispier than the regular
chicken
extra crispy to me is far superior to
the regular way to cook chicken I think
it should be the other way around like
this should be the regular and the other
one should be like half crispy you know
what I mean this is oh this is way
better all right let's move on to
chicken sandwiches here in India we
don't have an American chicken sandwich
but we have a Zinger and a smaller
sandwich called a crisper cute the
crisper looks like it wants to grow up
and be a Zinger someday they also come
in two variants uh spicy crisper and a
Tandoori Zinger let's taste all of them
oh that's pretty young they've used a
different kind of mayonnaise here it has
a bit of sweetness to it and a spicy
cooker then and now for the legendary
Zinger
um back in the day there were only two
fast food chains here in India it was
McDonald's and KFC and while McDonald's
had more affordable Burger options the
KFC Zinger was so delicious it was
always a treat to eat
um
and it still is I love that they use a
whole boneless piece of proper Chicken
in there delicious Mayo it's so
delicious okay now let's try the spicy
variants this is the spicy crisper look
at this sauce it's almost blood red I'm
excited
oh my God
this sauce almost has a Schezwan taste
to it next up the Zinger but Tandoori
I love the fullness of the chicken that
comes in these burgers versus you know
like a minced chicken patty in other
restaurants there's so much bite to it
so juicy tender that all sounds amazing
Steph you're going too fast I have to
say those sandwiches look delicious and
I am jealous one sandwich you can get
here in the U.S can't get in India is
this little guy the Chicken Little looks
to be like a chicken tender
in between these tiny little buns
pickles goodbye
I can't really get like five of those
slightly different from what you have in
in India so I'm gonna use as an excuse
to show it off yet again our crispy
chicken sandwich this thing the original
the bad boy
also with Pickles hang on
get off on my sandwich but it has this
really creamy Mayo sauce on it the bun I
love this
yeah
good chicken
s we got here you ain't got what are you
gonna loopy start over here Nashville
hot tender chicken here this I think is
the spiciest thing you get at the KFC
menu and I'm gonna be straight up like
I've had these before these are pretty
good they're really crispy Julie want to
hear that crisp again
not sure if it's made it over to India
yet it is called a chicken pot pie
that's a pie but instead of there being
you know fruit or any of the sweet stuff
you like they fill a pie with chicken
and what do you think else is in your
corn gravy peas maybe I have no idea I'm
not gonna wear this thing over this
thing
it's got some weight to it this is a
meal right here this is not a side I
don't know where it is in the menu but
oh
this right here the KFC famous bowl and
it is famous let me tell you
uh nikhil if you're wondering what this
is someone at KFC was like how can we
put everything into one bowl and this
thing was born it is mashed potatoes
corn uh the popcorn chicken
cheese and gravy on a convenient bowl
for you to eat while you're driving
It generally does nothing for the flavor
it's exactly what I would think this
would taste like there's just a bunch of
this stuff in one bowl yes in India you
can get wings at the KFC but our KFC in
the U.S you can get your wings Sauced
and we have three different sauces honey
barbecue buffalo Nashville hot
honey barbecue thumbs down this bottle
is a lot more orange than I would call
Buffalo beer I cannot quite place my
finger on why suddenly my stomach is
killing me
do you see inside there
okay
on to the next wing
bring on that food poisoning baby
um yeah all these are bad
all right moving away from chicken
India's KFC actually has vegetarian
alternatives for all our Burgers there
is a vegetarian crisper a vegetarian
spicy crisper and a vegetarian Zinger
now while India has a majority
population of non-vegetarians around 70
percent there is a huge vegetarian
population which is why a lot of fast
food restaurants have to make sure they
have a lot of vegetarian options on
their menu to make it more approachable
and acceptable for all people over here
there's also levels to vegetarianism
over here there are I will eat egg but
not chicken vegetarians there are I will
eat fish but not lamb vegetarians there
are I will eat the curry but not the
pieces vegetarians there are I am
vegetarian only on Tuesdays vegetarians
there are I have made a promise to God
for this one month vegetarians there are
I am vegetarians so you will all be
vegetarian vegetarians they're the weird
ones and we try not to talk about them
which is why KFC in India Brands itself
as just KFC there's no Kentucky Fried
Chicken anywhere here because obviously
I'm not going to go to a place that's
named that if I'm one of these many
types of vegetarians one iconic dish
that you'll find on the KFC India menu
is Biryani and so KFC India has taken a
very bold decision to launch their own
biryanis if you don't know what Biryani
is you are living under a gigantic
Boulder my friend hey guess I live under
Boulder because I unfortunately am not
familiar with Biryani but I would love
to know more about it
hello I am christelle Pereira and I'm a
cook and a baker and you may know me as
a finalist from the Great British Bake
Off this is Biryani now Biryani is a
typical rice dish you find in South Asia
and the way you make it is in layers my
dad is a Biryani Master at home and the
way he makes it is with cooked rice
cooked potatoes some fried onions and a
curry we like to go for a mutton Biryani
but you can get chicken or fish and in
this case vegetarian Biryani we
absolutely love it and we always eat it
as a family unit with a lovely pot of
cooling right around the side which is a
lovely cooling yogurt dish which goes
really well with the spicy Biryani and
it's basically our equivalent of a
Sunday roast because you have it in a
big pot and you all take Scoops and I
actually don't think I've ever eaten
Biryani by myself for one person now we
have to talk about this KFC Biryani
because for me Biryani it's a home dish
you make it in a home kitchen it's
cooked by a family member and it's
cooked with love my first impression at
KFC Biryani those two words just just
don't go together for me just to give
you guys context of what it's like to be
Indian and eat a Biryani at KFC it's
like being Italian and eating a pasta at
Domino's
got it thank you
continue they come in four flavors
number one classic chicken nice and
crispy number two popcorn chicken number
three the spicy red chicken that I
really enjoy and number four the veg
Patty which
it's so tempting to just push that to
the side because veg Biryani is already
just a concept that we not a fan of over
here
but just for
just for now you can you can stay here
okay I'm gonna begin with the popcorn
chicken biryani which is just so
Blasphemous to begin with
um
it's not a Biryani it's
I'm so upset right now this one the
spicy Red Chicken
has a bit of that Tandoori vibe to it
they've really tried to over compensate
with the spices there's a lot of clove
flavor just to convince you you're
eating a Biryani soup
go easy on that Curry
I could eat this like if I was hungry
not a Biryani though that Biryani looks
real depressing I am souring but we do
have these exclusive side dishes which
are mashed potatoes I can't believe you
guys don't have mashed potatoes it feels
like this is like Flagship stuff here
macaroni and cheese biscuits again no
biscuits coleslaw this giant dish of
just gravy and of course sweet corn new
country new sauces y'all know what that
means
first one I mean the KFC sauce why this
isn't at every KFC internationally I
have no idea you gotta love that sauce
right there
and looks like ketchup and mayo but it's
really good uh honey barbecue
I know that tastes like
honey mustard
that's not your thing
honey
and of course you got classic Ranch
not much of a ranch Aficionado it's
but there's just okay
with the hot sauce Julie
at 6 40 PM India does not have too many
exclusive dips in fact we just have a
veg eggless mayonnaise and a Tandoori
Masala mayonnaise it's time to taste
I'm using the same hand because here in
India we don't eat with our left hand
if you're wondering why commenters you
let them know
why don't Indians eat with their left
hand
[Music]
well it's just mayonnaise so good job on
that
mayonnaise again with a little bit of a
sweet but also spicy kick to it I wish
we had more options especially
considering there are so many different
delicious chicken options I'd love to be
able to dip my tenders in more sauces
that is a weird sentence for those of
you with a sweet tooth we have two
exclusive dessert options chocolate chip
cookie
and this
chocolate chip cake good as this look
here in India we have two exclusive
desserts a Choco mud pie and a coffee
mousse cake
oh boy just look at this cross section
my friend
next up coffee mousse cake
yeah
um these are
pretty average as desserts drinks drinks
drinks
maybe my favorite part of the exclusive
section exclusive drinking in the US you
cannot get in India Mountain Dew I'm
back baby
and if you're a Mountain Dew fan such as
me you know KFC has got the exclusive
Mountain Dew sweet lightning so Mountain
Dew sweet lightning is like Peach
Mountain Dew it's really good really
good
I think this is a lemonade the U.S style
lemonade not that weird UK Sprite
lemonade
not so good from there you can also get
Sierra Mist
ugh
and of course
sweetie
whoa that's like really sweet oh that's
really good
exclusive drinks in KFC India we have
mirinda which is an orange soda and Red
Bull let's talk about Melinda uh this is
a drink that really evokes Nostalgia 90s
kids
really know what I'm talking about when
I say
Miranda
which country is getting the better deal
at its KFC let's compare a few menu
items to find out both countries offer
eight piece chicken bucket here in La
one of these goes for
19.99 if you ordered an eight piece
chicken bucket here at KFC India it will
cost you
699.05 rupees very specific which is
currently 9.15 US dollars that makes the
American eight piece bucket 118 percent
more expensive than the one in India is
making Romeo combo help the US price out
at all take this chicken sandwich condom
with fries and a drink it will set you
back in America
9.99 the Indian equivalent is a Zinger
meal where you can get a chicken
sandwich it's a medium fries and a drink
for
319.05 rupees or 4.18 US dollars in fact
the price difference is so great you can
get something called the ultimate
savings bucket for just 599 rupees or
7.88 and this contains
four pieces of hot and crispy chicken
six hot wings four boneless strips three
drinks and three dips yeesh in fact you
can throw in a chocolate mud by his
dessert and still get all of this for
much cheaper than the American combo
meal but is it really that cheap here in
India no because two-thirds of India are
still under the poverty line and for
them this meal is still very
aspirational they earn less than two
dollars a day sorry to be a donor but
this is still a meal that is only
available to the really privileged here
in India
unfortunately KFC does not share a full
list of ingredients with the public it's
actually the same in the US all KFC
shares with the public is a list of
allergens so what do we know about KFC
well the KFC India website has a couple
of Clues we know that all of our chicken
is farmed here and not imported and all
of it is 100 whole muscle chicken
hmm that means it's made from whole
pieces of chicken and not cut together
minced chicken like you find in chicken
nuggets in fact the website says they
have an open kitchen policy and what
that means is anybody can walk into a
KFC and apparently ask for a kitchen
tour and you can go into the kitchen
look at everything and ask as many
questions as you want I've never heard
that in my entire life an open Kitchen
Pass I've worked in several kitchens and
I'll tell you straight up if I was in a
kitchen working and some dude walks in
is like hey gotta tour the kitchen I'd
be like yeah here's your tour there's
the exit definitely can't do that in the
United States don't go into a KFC
chicken and demand a tour the KFC Us
website also gives us some hints about
the ingredients it uses over here for
instance all of our chicken is raised on
U.S Farms to the USDA and fda's
standards so that means there are no
added hormones or steroids in American
KFC chicken in addition to this as of
2019 yum brands the parent company of
KFC stopped purchasing chicken raised
using antibiotics Indian chicken farmers
were previously criticized for overusing
antibiotics as recently as 2018 the
Bureau of investigative journalism found
out that a lot of Indian farmers were
feeding coal esteem to their chickens as
a growth promoter without any medical
supervision Coalition is known as the
antibiotic of The Last Resort holy oh my
God that's so frightening and it's only
given to humans when other antibiotics
have failed so if we give our chickens
Coalition then the humans who consume it
might become resistant to it in fact
they can develop antibiotic resistant
superbug and that's not good usually
this sounds like the plot to a horror
movie what is it talking about that is
terrifying I'm gonna assume we don't do
that here and if we do oh God but when a
report came out talking about the ill
effects of Coalition India ended up
Banning it completely so we're safe from
coaliston at last
we should also point out that the KFC
India website is in major need of an
update there is an FAQ page where people
have asked things like how many calories
does this chicken have or sometimes I
see red deposits in my chicken what is
it
and for almost all of these questions
the answers are just filler text so if
you ask me what those red deposits are I
genuinely don't know that's interesting
let's take a look at this website right
now is KFC providing Health Care to
employees KFC responds standard dummy
tax ever since the 1500s when an unknown
printer took a gallery of type and
scrambled it to make type specimen book
from calorie count to portion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between Starbucks and India and the US
this is food Wars
at a Starbucks in India we get our hot
coffees in four sizes number one
a short
at all
a granny and the big boy a venti
Ally I can't think of a single reason
you would order a coffee of this size
who is putting this much caffeine in
their bodies
let's measure this to see if it has as
much as it should
whoa wait a second Starbucks I am
disappointed it's close it's 18 ounces
ish all right if I'm paying this kind of
money I want a bang for my buck 20
ounces to the tea I think that's 20. I
was about to dunk on Starbucks would
actually give us the 20 they promised
cheers
look into the eyes
of an insane caffeine addict
my vision has just gone blurry India's
iced coffee comes in three sizes
tall
candy
and an even bigger one we got the
trender
I want to mention now that our Fenty ice
size is bigger than our venti hot size
the venti hot was 20 ounces this is 24
ounces
and of course let's measure it
can't believe you've done this it's not
even 16 ounces Starbucks and this has
ice in it which should melt and give you
more liquid is that is that how fluid
dynamics Works maybe not but my
disappointment is is palpable yeah I'm
gonna go 22 ounces I is two ounces
that's fine it's totally not a big deal
that's like two sips I can't speak for
anyone else but already my bladder is
about to burst so maybe I don't need 24
more ounces in my bloodstream if that
wasn't exciting enough
we of course have our biggest ice size
which is the Trenta 30 fluid ounces
the bladder Buster this is for anyone
who wants to spend most of their day in
the bathroom
so you think about 28 again two ounces
off you know what Starbucks four ounces
more won't kill you
oh
Starbucks actually good what the hell
anyone watches food Wars knows we're
using this measuring cup for everything
and I know I don't clean it
I don't think Joe's cleaning it I don't
think Julie's cleaning it so this thing
never been clean yeah
and of course if you're in the mood for
96 fluid ounces of Starbucks coffee
bam get yourself the coffee traveler AKA
what Joe drinks in an afternoon here in
India we don't have a huge coffee
traveler we just have this little guy
it's an India Edition tiny pet coffee
traveler it's got a lot of cool India
iconography on it um it's a batsman
there is a an elephant all sorts of cool
Indian stuff and you can put in 355 ml
of coffee in here which is around 11.83
ounces of coffee roughly a tall so
the perfect size we also have one liter
bottles for ice latte and cold brew word
on the street is they contain one liter
each or 33.8 fluid ounces it is so weird
using the U.S system of measurement I'm
so used to our normal correct metric
system but let's not start an active War
over here sorry Joe yeah I don't care
hot venti latte in India is 289 calories
for comparison a normal serving of Dal
chawal is 200 calories
in the U.S the same venti cafe latte is
250 calories so it looks like the U.S
has 13.5 percent less calories
to the temperature where it's like room
temperature
my brain is Swiss cheese and everything
I say is idiotic a hot venti mocha which
is also what my friends called me is 473
calories and the us our venti mocha is
450 calories so according to my math
once again that's a calorie decrease of
4.9 percent what do you think of that
hot venti boy okay Joe it's not a
competition let's just try something a
little sweeter like this Venti Caramel
Frappuccino which looks uh decadent to
say the least
oh my God that is so sweet
602 calories and I can feel every single
one of them in each sip okay genuinely I
have had spoonfuls of sugar that are
more Savory than this drink how can you
make something sweeter than sugar how
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a lot of calories my man ours is
470 calories which is also 24 ounces now
I should note in the US the calories
listed on starbucks.com are quote based
on standard recipes do not reflect
customizations
get this out of my face I hate this why
is this so and they put like they load
the syrup in here how can a human being
drink one of these I don't understand
and now our most calorific overall drink
that we have here in India a venti
strawberry and cream Frappuccino
963 calories
oh my god I didn't even think it was
possible to experience a sugar rush and
a coffee caffeine high at the same time
at 963 calories this is nearly 50 of
your daily caloric intake so please
drink this at your own risk and I am a
risk taker
I feel transported to
another dimension where everything is
more colorful and I can taste sound
I don't know I feel like we should have
an ambulance ready if I'm going to
finish this drink that's a lot of
calories I have to say I'm very
impressed our most highest calorific
drink is the mocha cookie crumble
frappuccino at the venti size and it's
only
590 calories oh God
this looks so bad
oh man it's it's like so powerful it
gets so sweet that everything from here
after the rest of my life is just gonna
taste like paper
so what about the cost
this venti frappuccino will cost you 390
rupees which at the time of filming this
video is 5.14 US dollars in the US a
Venti Caramel Frappuccino is 5.45 or
about 413 Indian rupees now I want to
point out that this is 24 ounces and not
the India 20 ounce venti so if we break
it down per fluid ounce it's about 11.5
cost per fluid ounce decrease in the US
let me give you some context about
Starbucks in India they are catering to
the rich and the elite because it is
very expensive over here in South India
where I'm from you can get a filter
coffee for less than 40 rupees which is
a fraction of a dollar and it's
delicious Starbucks would cost you
upwards of five dollars and that's
unaffordable for most of India
here is everything that you can find in
a menu at an Indian Starbucks that you
won't get in the US quick clarification
some of the items we have here are
location specific and specific to the
season that we're ordering them it's
currently summer here in Mumbai and some
of these items are store specific so
maybe you won't get them in Hugo order
but let me know and here's everything
you can only find on the menu at a U.S
Starbucks you can't get in India now a
bit of clarification we know Starbucks
will customize drink orders and there
are thousands of variations in special
secret menu items thank you Starbucks so
just to make things not completely
insane these are the official things on
the Starbucks menu at both India and the
US cool and let's go alright let's begin
with all the hot exclusive drinks
starting with salted caramel latte
not bad Stardust mocha boom we have
clarified no sparkles nothing about this
cream Stardust I don't know what you're
talking about Starbucks but
it tastes good chai tea or as we call it
here in India chai can I just say it's a
bit of a pet peeve when you guys call
Chai chai tea it's like calling t t let
me describe a good chai to you all right
it should be warm it should be gingery
it should feel like a hug from your mum
in your childhood and you should poke
your morning up and it should be under
10 Rupees but this is expensive
[Music]
foreign
which is actually my favorite drink
every person has their own recipe for
chai but it's a combination of spices
and black tea and some milk and usually
sweetened with a bit of sugar but for me
at home my recipe cardamom is the most
important spice cinnamon Ginger a pinch
of cloves and my secret spice is a bit
of black pepper just to give that lovely
warming spicy feeling but but it's not
Savory it's just a lovely blend of
spices
flavor is not bad but I wouldn't call
this I wouldn't call this a chai you
know what this is a chai tea because
it's not quite a chai It's not quite a
tea
fair enough Starbucks it's a chai tea
next up in the drink I'm most excited to
have tandai spice now Tanda is consumed
primarily in North India in the state of
uttar Pradesh where it's this drink
that's sweet it contains spices it
contains rose petals saffron and
sometimes optionally you can add bhang
which is marijuana and it's completely
free legal and optional to add it and
people enjoy it during the festivals
like Holi and mahashivratri well I'm
sorry did he say that that drink has
marijuana in it or you can't put wheat
in it I mean this is California so if
there's a drink you can put weed and you
think we would have it right
not bad it's got little pieces of Pista
and badam and other nuts how did you get
thundai right and mess up something as
simple as a chai USA we got a lot of hot
exclusives I'm gonna start all the way
down here with something called the cafe
misto
Bland moving on almond honey flat wiped
this flat white I like because it has
like a nice honey flavor to it but
straight up flat whites I just I don't
get a Cinnamon Dolce Latte
I like it it's not too sweets a white
hot chocolate hot chocolate come on
this is like really good but I don't
know if I could drink a whole one of
those this is the caramel apple spice
no that's steamed apple juice what apple
juice
hot apple juice what are you gonna like
some apple juice right about now I
haven't seen in forever let's meet up
for apple juice cinnamon dolce cream
good steamed milk
vanilla cream when you walk past that
ice cream place on the mall it tastes
the way it smells like strong vanilla I
couldn't imagine having more than two
sips of that already my stomach's
starting to hurt I'm gonna be so sick
and now it's time for the cool
exclusives I'm not having a caffeine
crash at all
the Citrus cold brew
sicknessy out of everything this one has
kind of a nice mild flavor the cocoa
chai almond
oh I just had such a mild one I took a
big Sip and this one is
sweet again Vietnamese caramel cold brew
it should typically have condensed milk
but this has normal milk and it's quite
good Nitro cold brew it's basically cold
brew but if you press a button you drink
it faster
dumb joke
it tastes like any other cold brew I'd
be interested to know what the nitrogen
process is what is what is Nitro cold
brew well they add nitrogen to it and
you know what that does I have no idea
next up chocolate truffle cold brew you
know that sounds like something your
child self and your adult self would
want to combine if they had to
collaborate on a drink let's see if it's
actually good
[Music]
absolutely not oh my God Stardust mocha
again
I still don't know what the hell
Stardust is there are chunks or
something something otherworldly
it's it's like cookies and cream it's an
oreo it's an oreo Thunder spice uh same
flavor but now cold mm-hmm
too much sugar for one young man to
consume I'm losing it I'm seeing the
light
oh no I'm literally seeing the light
there's a light above me you know the
funny thing is Tanda is meant to be
consumed cold so this is the appropriate
temperature and way to drink it but it's
layered with so much whipped cream and
it's so sweet tonight requires a balance
of spices and sweetness and that's what
this is lacking and the final two drinks
are salted caramel and strawberry with
cream but I already tasted those maybe
maybe it got better with time you never
know you want to give everything a
chance
[Music]
I'm never giving anything a chance ever
again and now for the pre-bottle drinks
they've got three of them in one liter
bottles this is the ice shaken hibiscus
lemonade looks quite refreshing
that is very nice it says it serves four
to five cups which if you're in an
Indian family they're gonna make this
last for at least 20 people and it's
very reminiscent of ruavsa which is a
rose flavoring that we add to water and
it's super delicious I think this is a
good substitute white mocha caramel cold
brew
oh my god I've gotten to the stage where
I can smell sugar I can see sugar I can
hear sugar I think I am sugar at this
point
Starbucks signature chocolate normally I
would be very excited about this but I
am so soaked to the brim with sweet
stuff
it's actually good it's like the amount
of chocolate you want to put in your
cocoa but you know it's probably not
good for you
I'm losing my goddamn mind all right
starting down here something you can
only get in the U.S is the mocha cookie
crumble a frappuccino it's looking a
little sad so food Wars tip bring your
own whip
that's another Joe's tips
I'm not getting the cookie part of it it
just tastes like a chocolate milkshake I
don't know if that's really doing much
for the flavor the caramel ribbon crunch
frappuccino
I don't know how anyone could drink a
whole one of these the recommended
serving for this Joe should be like two
sips it's like sip number two
and I'm good for a week oh that high
fructose corn syrup is working overtime
in that one the Cafe vanilla Frappuccino
you know always keep the saying on me
the least objectionable one I guess
actually a little weak to be honest then
again after these two maybe it's
perfectly fine Nitro the official cold
brew of The Fast and Furious franchise
Joseph just pour this on your engine and
off you go oh you and Vin Diesel go it
doesn't require ice has a smoother
flavor right now you want something a
little bit sweeter in your cold brew you
can get yourself a vanilla sweet cream
Nitro cold brew
s with it we got a vanilla oat milk we
got a brown sugar oat milk and we got a
chocolate almond milk here they are
not as strong of a flavors I thought it
would be brown sugar
I'm definitely tasting it yeah not bad I
have reason to believe this was
unshooken I think I could shake it
without
I would recommend this one out of all
three but insist they shake it in front
of you you can get yourself an iced flat
white and an iced honey flat white
skip them iced Cinnamon Dolce Latte and
an iced Starbucks Blonde latte not bad
can confirm a sip is good I don't know
about a whole one of these already I'm
kind of like
Starbucks teas or as my mom calls them I
can make this at home starting off with
Indian spice Majestic wow okay
oh can I just say drinking this after
everything else is such a breath of
fresh air you know it's a simple tea but
it's very flavorful very spicy would
recommend next up matcha espresso Fusion
it's part of the trifecta of three
ingredients that have become very
popular in India matcha Peri Peri and
red velvet
[Music]
I feel like the espresso counters the
sweetness that it has and the matcha
flavor is there again just cut down on
the sweetness and this would actually be
good now the exclusive hot taste you get
here in the US the Royal English
breakfast tea latte London Fog tea latte
honey citrus mint tea a jade citrus mint
brewed tea the mint Majesty
mint matcha green all bad the Trinity of
gross I don't want the peach tranquility
and they spot Tranquility but it should
be tranquilitya I feel like they missed
a trick then okay so those are the two
hotties it's now time for the cold tea
starting with an iced green tea I feel
like when you start drinking green tea
it's a sign of adulthood and there's no
going back
that's actually pretty good and now I
feel old
hibiscus Passion Lemonade so many
ingredients but I know I'm gonna taste
only sugar hey
that's pretty good
it's kind of Flowery fruity I really
like this
espresso Fusion oh this is an iced
matcha oh okay sorry
my bad my bad it's guys it's it's a
Starbucks handwriting honestly sometimes
I think it's just doctors writing
prescriptions on these coffee mugs by
the way let me know in the comments
what's the weirdest way somebody has
spelled your name in Starbucks
hmm I prefer this to the weird hot sweet
one yeah I like the teas way more than
the coffee so I don't know what that
says about Starbucks but
I'm a fan I feel the exact opposite I do
not like tea at all and this is all the
stuff on a Starbucks menu I've never
gotten and would like to never get but
gotta do it it's the job so we will
start at down here at the Starbucks in
the U.S you can get yourself iced black
tea and an ice black tea lemonade moving
on you can get Peach cheese we got an
ice peach green tea and an iced peach
tea lemonade so this tastes good because
it's like Peach and lemonade I don't
taste any tea green iced green tea
lemonade
latte lemonade I'm losing a c i don't I
I stopped drinking caffeine for a second
and I fall apart oh matcha no no not
much huh Grundy matcha lemonade all
right lemonade lemonade is doing all the
heavy lift on all these
I absolutely hate this Royal English
breakfast
mmm
it will help a little caffeine
all right also Starbucks you get
something called Refreshers so what I
can tell they are fruit juices with
fruit in it imagine that I would never
normally get a refresh as one thing to
but now I get to try all of them pink
Drink
oh yeah fruity we've gone we have the
strawberry acai lemonade
I like those similar problem to a lot of
the Frappuccinos One Taste and I'm like
I can get into it but a whole one of
these and I just put my gut kind of
starting to look just the mango dragon
fruit right Dragon drink mango dragon
fruit lemonade
I think this is the best one so far one
second all right don't put that in
moving on we have uh the green drink
Zone star drink swimming star fruit kiwi
star fruit does lemonade kick it up even
another notch this one I like the flavor
the best was a little strong yeah oh
these are pretty good the last refresher
is the strawberry acai they have a
regular lemonade and a blended
strawberry lemonade I mean come on
lemonade everything else says head
lemonade in it I've enjoyed so let's
just go straight to the source
whoa dude Starbucks lemon is really good
what is this even the top 10 things you
would get at Starbucks a lemonade what
now it's like your lemonade a little bit
of strawberry
this is fantastic wow even after all
these this is a standout this is really
good why is this so good
fantastic food we have a lot of Indian
exclusives I'm going to start with the
salads this is a vegetarian grain salad
it's got quinoa it's got some paneer in
it it's got corn kernels that look
Unborn
I'm sure this is super healthy but it's
also very dry now the meat version of it
it's got chicken
I'm not really a fan of cold salads if
you are a health freak you might enjoy
this but if you're a fan of food
you probably won't okay next up I'm
going to try all of their rolls rolls
are a huge staple here in India they're
one of the most famous street foods and
it's great for the working class citizen
this is the murgati roll more means
Chicken in Hindi
oh that's pretty good finally some spice
oh my God
it's a lifesaver I feel like I'm being
brought back to life after all those
drinks this is really good you'll find
this only in India but honestly
Starbucks you should consider selling
this all over because it is tasty next
up is a kakuri kebab roll kakuri Kebab
is basically minced meat typically lamb
and it's served with a Paratha or a roti
I've never seen it in a roll and I've
never seen it in a pink roll
[Music]
the main thing about a kakri kebab is it
should melt in your mouth this has too
much of a bite to it not a fan next up
chatpata paneer roll chatpata means full
of Masala and flavor and it's zingy and
paneer is cottage cheese we love our
cottage cheese here in India and we call
it paneer and you should too next up
cheese chili toast so obviously if you
order this at Starbucks I assume they
actually toast this and the cheese melts
and it's super delicious
I can tell you right now this flavor
profile will go really well with Indians
we love our cheese chili toast monsoon
season mom goes to the kitchen toast the
bread lot of butter some cheese some
chili bite into it your mouth's on fire
but it's rainy and cool so you're all
okay this is not quite there but I feel
like it could be next up Tandoori paneer
sandwich I'm gonna have to say that this
bread is a little hard to say the least
might be a bit of an old sandwich
flavor is good though if I had any of
this food fresh at a Starbucks I might
have a very different opinion so far the
paneer items have been way better than
the meat items I'm starting to Guess
that somebody in the Starbucks R D team
who really likes paneer sandwiches and
protein boxes here we go you can get a
bunch of exclusive sandwiches U.S
Starbucks starting right here with the
crispy grilled cheese and sourdough
again ham and cheese on a baguette damn
it got the turkey pesto with provolone
chicken and bacon and brioche why is it
could get that chicken in the whole
thing here guys a Focaccia tomato
mozzarella at a Starbucks you can get a
chicken caprese on Ciabatta sandwich on
to the protein boxes the chickpea bites
and avocado can you tell what's in there
obviously avocado
chickpea bites egg and cheddar
cheese and fruit peanut butter and jam
grilled chicken and hummus there's your
hummus there's your Pita there's your
grilled chicken you can also get which
was not available at the store today egg
and gouda protein box a cheese Trio
protein box and a cheddar and salami
protein box next up egg white and
chicken multigrain croissant should I
just call it a croissant to upset people
the denizens of the internet
if you are somebody trying to be protein
conscious put on the pounds this might
be good for you next up a masala chicken
quasar
I guess you can't go wrong with Masala
chicken you can't go wrong with a
croissant it's just really good next up
a basil tomato mozzarella sandwich
I can imagine just eating this on a
summer day really um next up creamy
spinach and corn pocket pocket it's
pretty cute as a kid this is the only
way I enjoy eating spinach unless it was
in palak paneer but right now I
appreciate it and I really like it in
this pocket next up chicken Chic pocket
sheet Kebab is basically minced meat and
it's sort of pressed onto your skewer
and then grilled over here they've done
that and then they've chopped them into
little sausage pieces
mint tea it has that pudina flavor a lot
of onions have just been caramelized so
it's like sweet but also spicy I really
like this starting with the breakfast
sandwiches and wraps the bacon gouda egg
scooter somewhere on here a sausage egg
and cheddar the double smoked bacon
cheddar Nick dude
what's up
I didn't
other sandwiches you can get are spinach
feta egg wrap the roasted ham the turkey
bacon cheddar and egg white sandwich and
the impossible breakfast sandwich but
you know they do have bacon and Greer
egg white and roasted red pepper kale
and mushroom look at yourself an avocado
spread for dipping Bagels we got them
I'm gonna assume it's in everything
because it's got everything cinnamon
raisin I can tell because of the raisins
hey
plane for the New Yorker right oatmeal
oatmeal we got regular and they come
with a nut medley browned sugar dry
fruit I bet it's like a puck now it's
been sitting for a while
all right you can also get a blueberry
one it's obviously the same stuff with
blueberries strawberry and overnight
grains next up a double chocolate chip
cookie
I think if I put this in the microwave
for five seconds this is a bang and
banging cookie a tea cake this is a
lemon flavored and finally they have a
banana loaf cake but guys I am
dangerously allergic to banana and so I
wish this cake the best of luck maybe
you guys can try to let me know in the
comments whether it's worth ordering and
the baked goods in the U.S you can
assortment of baked goods as you can see
in front of me I'll just start down here
we got scones oh this is a blueberry
scone petite vanilla bean scone these
can't be the same price cake pops yeah
chocolate which one you think is Earth
or which one you think is birthday I
think this is Gabby birthday glazed
donut hey red velvet cake pumpkin loaf
you can also get a cinnamon coffee cake
yeah brownie chocolate chip cookie
available yet not today pumpkin cream
cheese muffin it is now time for ice
creams did you know Starbucks makes ice
creams I had no idea java chip ice cream
this looks really good check it out son
yum coffee chocolate chips and mocha
that is something else I really like
this next up vanilla ice cream and
chocolate sauce now everybody in India
their childhood has involved amul
vanilla ice cream and Hershey's
Chocolate Syrup let's see if this sort
of evokes that nostalgia
oh the vanilla ice cream is so good next
up vanilla ice cream with strawberry
sauce you either got the Hershey's
chocolate sauce or the Hershey's
strawberry sauce
younger Kinney would not have
appreciated this but olokini I really
enjoying it it's fruity Tangy SAR and it
really complements the yummy vanilla
creamy ice cream next up we have the
same Java Chip but now with more
chocolate chips and chocolate sauce so
this is a bit of an overload
too much are you can you zoom in on my
hand
it's shaking right now caramel macchiato
it's really nice it's not too sweet it's
kind of salty next the affogato which is
uh ice cream in coffee
I love how eating hot bitter coffee and
sweet creamy ice cream mixing them
together and somehow they're not
choosing violence they're choosing to be
friends harmonious in my mouth
avogado again but this is house avogado
so I'm gonna assume Starbucks that this
should be better you're putting your
name on it
tastes the same and finally we have the
caramel macchiato ice cream it's similar
to the small cup of caramel macchiato I
had except this does not have a drizzle
of caramel sauce if you were ordering
ice cream from Starbucks I would
recommend the simple Java Chip and the
simple caramel macchiato no drizzle of
sauces it's not as sweet it's kind of
nice from calorie count to portion sizes
we want to find out all the differences
between McDonald's and India in the US
this is food Wars
McDonald's India come in three sizes
regular medium and large drinks to the
McDonald's in the U.S 4 sizes extra
small small medium and large
time to keep them honest
lost a couple drops 26 27 fluid ounces
fries in India come in three sizes
regular medium and large in America our
fries come in four sizes I think we have
a small kids or
kids small I can't tell the difference
either
medium
and large the medium and large come in
these really cool new packaging where
you can just open it up like that and
it's nice and easy to share it's a
little plate good job McDonald's very
Innovative but now it's time to measure
and see how much we're really getting
first things first the large
175 grams obviously it's different per
Scoops or whatever yeah let's go here
this one
almost exactly 100 grams
80 grams frymath hang on
this is like
yep there you go 20 that's 20 grand
difference right there so you tell me
internet is the kids in the small
different sizes I don't think they are
food Wars is on it baby what about
McNuggets here in India you can order
them in three sizes six pieces nine
pieces and 20 pieces they gave it to us
in two boxes of ten each oh is that it
India cute our McNuggets start at four
then you got 6 10 20 and not to be a
done Booyah 40 McNuggets all the math
heads watching will be quick to point up
that is double India's largest nugget
option the only burger that India shares
with the US is the McChicken The Humble
McChicken not even gonna bother with the
analog scale now
pooped
149 grams ah so frustrating just one
more gram will be perfect with the paper
I mean we'll do this and
shave off an eighth of an ounce our
McChicken weighs 140 grams
[Music]
here it is everything you'll find on the
menu at McDonald's India that you will
not find in the USA and here's all the
McDonald's menu items from the US you
won't find in India here in India we
can't really recreate the iconic
McDonald's Big Mac because it's made
from a beef patty and to keep to the
religious Sentiments of Hindus and even
Muslims we don't serve beef or pork in a
lot of fast food restaurants we have
something called the chicken Maharaja
Mac as you can see it's got three buns
two patties a lot of cheese and
mayonnaise some tomatoes onions lettuce
let us try it now
[Music]
oh my God that is truly a Maharaja Mac
if you're wondering Raja is a king and a
Maharaja is like an emperor so this is
clearly our answer to the Big Mac now
let's taste the veg Maharaja Mac I think
it's actually a very cool challenge that
a lot of fast food restaurants here have
had to adapt to the Indian palette as
well as sensibilities of food we have
come up with such cool iconic fast food
that you won't get anywhere else in the
world like look at this this is
outrageous there's no way to eat this
without being messy just literally
mmm oh my God that's really good yes to
all that looks really good because of
India's lack of beef all the American
beef options are technical exclusives
all right
Big Mac there it is
just brimming with stuff my go-to for
like 20 years I still get it
occasionally the classic McDonald's
hamburger beef patty ketchup and mustard
of course
and get it with cheese hi you can
upgrade to a double cheeseburger or a
McDouble what's the difference you ask
I'm not sure either so let's start with
the double cheeseburger look at that
look how yellow that is beef cheese beef
cheese tapos the McDouble is beef cheese
beef so it's just one slice of cheese in
the middle but not on top what's the
price difference can we get that on
screen
and how much is a slice of cheese
Joe's hack get yourself a McDouble and
bring your own slice of American cheese
Booyah save yourself this amount of
money
I'm with Millennials today the reason
you guys can't buy houses is you're
spending all your money at Starbucks
you're getting your double cheeseburgers
instead of a McDouble and bring in your
own cheese slice I mean you guys are
terrible with money but you're eating
what seven eight McDoubles a day like me
right and that adds up to like at the
end of the year
18 10 000 years later that's a down
payment on a house
what are you guys doing all right next
up is the iconic mikalu Tiki Burger you
take mashed potato and you fry it in
breadcrumbs and you get this really
delicious cutlet here in India they
adapted it into this burger with a very
special sauce some tomato and chopped
onions
um it's just so classic they nailed this
burger next up there is a Mexican
mechalutiki which I assume has some
stereotypical Mexican ingredients and
flavors like jalapeno yes jalapeno
um nice it's way more spicy good twist
next up they have a Mac egg burger my
cake my cake my cake I don't know why I
did that let's see what that looks like
sorry I did not expect pesto next up is
a chicken kebab Burger every time an
Indian fast food chain tries to adapt an
Indian special food into a burger I take
it with a pinch of salt because this is
not what we're used to seeing when we
think of Kebabs but I'm gonna try it and
let's see what happens
it's very very dry Patty has almost like
a cardboardy taste to it I wouldn't put
those flavors together if I was thinking
kebab
that's a bit harsh I'm sorry next up is
the mech veggie which is the vegetarian
counterpart to our McChicken if I had to
eat this versus the Chicken one I would
not be upset at all really good next up
we have two American Burgers the
American cheese Supreme wedge
and the American cheese Supreme chicken
my hunch for what makes them American is
that they will have a nice big square of
cheese and they will not be spicy at all
except they have a lot of jalapenos on
them Joe let me know if this constitutes
American
that's American cheese my man that's
what makes an American I don't know
about those other toppings but yeah it
sounds about right all right so this is
what the McDonald's website says is in
this burger whole wheat bun stores from
Maharashtra Tangy jalapenos from
Karnataka shredded onions grown in local
Indian farms and cheese from amravati
also in India quite quite close to home
this burger currently this would
probably be my favorite order a mixed
spicy chicken and there's the vegetarian
option which is a mixed spicy paneer
which is just leaking lettuce for those
of you who don't know what paneer is
it's basically cottage cheese we love
our paneer we put in curries we eat it
plain we put it in kebabs it is so
delicious let's try this
mmm it has just the right kick and it
goes really well with the paneer fair
warning while this may have a light kick
of spice for us it might be a hard kick
for you so
take everything with a pinch of chili
powder I'm going to move up to something
called the quarter pounder and that's
like their big burger so you can get a
quarter pounder with cheese here it is I
mean this looks it looks fake right like
just kidding it's cake or the the new
one is uh it's actually a candle and
then you can get a quarter of a pound of
cheese deluxe more veggies on it all the
junk that I brush off you can upgrade to
a Double Quarter partner with cheese
let's take a look oh man look how thick
this is and then you can get that same
double with bacon yeah oh man skimping
on the bacon guys what we lack in beef
burgers we make up for in Gourmet
Burgers that's right here in McDonald's
India we have our own collection of Chef
special Gourmet Burgers delicious and I
think this is a rolling menu I think
they introduce new things from time to
time the Buns themselves look a lot more
Gourmet you know this nice riff down the
middle kind of looks like a butt uh but
that's okay we're not going to
concentrate on that
first we have triple cheese American veg
burger and triple cheese American
chicken burger same thing cheese
jalapenos some sauce lettuce simple
chicken patty Gourmet bun does this
cream American to you next up cheese
lava American veg burger and cheese lava
American chicken burger again with
American and again with the with a
Strange Relation of food to volcanoes
and lava
is very spicy this qualifies as a
volcano product for sure congratulations
McDonald's the lava in the title of this
Burger Works the MC spicy chicken
premium though has an egg Patty inside
of it
um
that's pretty good
I just feel so existential right now
imagine sitting here on this table and
just tasting every single burger at
McDonald's menu
[Music]
amazing
but also
we also have some exclusive wrap options
we have big spicy paneer and big spicy
chicken I think this is the same mix
spicy chicken patty and it's wrapped
around a tortilla Which is actually way
closer to an Indian chapati than most of
the fast food restaurants it doesn't
feel as synthetic our McDonald's in the
U.S had wraps for a brief period of time
one day they were gone nobody noticed
yeah you guys got some chicken stuff
that we don't have but we got a few of
our own more recently than you think
they finally introduced their chicken
sandwich to an already crowded chicken
sandwich market and that is of course
their crispy chicken sandwich and this
thing is fantastic it's one of the best
ones they were late to the game and they
kind of took it over in my opinion what
I like about it it's simple look at this
you just got crispy chicken pickles that
suck it's baller tastes great like a
little spicy India
it probably doesn't compare the way you
guys are rocking in India but you know
this one has a little nice heat to it
pickles sauce wanna take it up a notch
gotta go Deluxe the cool crispness of
the vegetables just Clash so well with a
spicy sauce it's good it's good nikhil
say the word and I'm putting one in the
post for you tomorrow so when it arrives
in three weeks you can throw it out
now we're getting into exclusive side
dishes here in India we have these
add-ons number one the veg Pizza mcpuff
this is one of the most delicious things
we have here it's basically a pizza hot
pocket Masala veggies these are potato
wedges with classic Indian Masala flavor
to them oh boy masalas are basically
what we use to Spice in flavor dishes
and they consist primarily of ground up
spices like cardamom cloves red chillies
kashmiri chilies you go to Every Indian
home the mums the grandmoms will have
their own random you know Masala mix
that they use and that's guarded and
treasured in their family forever next
up we have cheesy Masala veggies they're
also serving a classic cup of boiled
corn which is so unique and they give
you a side of amul butter guys amul
butter is part of our culture makhan
makhan the this is probably gonna be the
most delicious bite of the day
I love corn next up chicken strips they
come in packs of two
three or five cheesy nugget veg bites
yeah this is just a vegetated version of
the chicken nuggets and it's got some
corn some tomato
next we have the double cheese McMuffin
and lastly we have Mexican cheesy fries
on the McDonald's India website one
British customer said that these Mexican
cheesy fries are the real deal I have no
idea how a British person can say that
Mexican cheesy fries is a real deal but
anytime a British person says that
another culture is food is the real deal
it puts a little fear in our small
Indian Hearts yes price is like ass
next exclusive side that we have is
apple slices
cut them up put them in a plastic bag
but to Get Saucy that's right ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
thank you
spicy bubble
not a good they got a Tangy barbecue
much better mmm
honey mustard
tastes like salad dressing sour
I would tie it with the Tangy BBQ
because it's so different so we'll keep
these guys
sent here Ranch I don't know America we
love our ranch ranch is just okay that's
what I said ranch is just okay oh and
all Ranch tastes the same yeah and
finally honey
how do you like that
Honey's the best one and all that money
all that energy all that time creating
all these recipes trying to sway the
American pop the American mind and you
got you got beat by a bunch of bees
power to the bees
we have one exclusive spice mix as well
as One exclusive sauce here in India we
have chili sauce which is pretty
straightforward it's chili sauce but let
me tell you about piri piri spice mix so
McDonald's launched this in 2013 here in
India and it was so popular there were
riots when they said they were going to
discontinue it and so now it's a
permanent addition to the menu first you
get this shake bag then you grab your
fries and then you just pour that in
there
oh
boom oh boy can we cut to a before of
the fries you saw how they were now look
at these you can see the little flecks
of spice just adorning each fry
[Music]
hello it's Crystal and I know nikhil has
Peri Peri McDonald's chips but in the UK
it is all about Nando's cheeky Nando's
let's talk about Peri Peri Peri means
pepper and it's a blend of spices so
it's got things like paprika ground
birds like chili a bit of oregano a
pinch of Ginger and cardamom but it's a
Portuguese spice blend it's funny
because obviously nikhil mentioned that
the Peri-Peri fries just flew off in
India and it makes sense because I'm
from Goa which is in the south of India
Goa was colonized by the Portuguese and
so I really think that Indians are
accustomed to that Portuguese taste
palette which is why Peri-Peri fries are
doing so well in India but after the
talking I want to dig into these fries
because they look great
no this is so good Harry get involved
not eating chips without me no sorry
I've already had a head start cheers
God damn if there isn't
like crack for the early risers there's
plenty of exclusive breakfast items at
the U.S McDonald's sausage biscuit with
egg next one
sausage biscuit I'm gonna take the egg
out this is just this of course is bacon
egg and cheese ladies and gentlemen
we've reached the point of the breakfast
where we get into the McGriddles I love
McGriddles what's a McGriddle you ask
India fantastic question McDonald's had
this genius idea to replace the
breakfast sandwiches they already had
with pancakes and they also like inject
syrup into it somehow but it is a
breakfast sandwich with pancakes for
buns and it's the best idea anyone's
ever had anywhere ever
look at this look at this look at this
they're looking like a little m in there
this mini pancake and I'm wearing the
gloves but this one's mine
we have a veg McMuffin and a sausage
McMuffin
the sausage here in India is not made
out of pork like it is in the U.S
instead it's made out of simple chicken
speaking of sausage
you can get breakfast burrito
bro I could put five of these Away music
easy you're like a total drag and you
want oatmeal in the morning we have it
that as inspiring as you would think hot
cakes and sausage of course it comes
with hot syrup this here huh
the big breakfast with hot cakes and
it's big a lot of eggs kind of wimpy
looking bacon got yourself two English
muffins here and of course it comes with
hash brown potatoes who doesn't love
them without hash brown undefeated these
things are so good India exclusive
desserts we have a black forest McFlurry
a vanilla chocolate muffin and a
chocolate chip muffin it's kind of like
a McFlurry soup right now
this would be really good when it was
actually a McFlurry desserts USA we got
them so starting down here very simple
chocolate chip cookies uh this next
thing apple fritter right
this right here is called the glaze pull
apart donut
blueberry muffin if you had one you've
had them all this is a what type of pie
let's see what's inside okay I'm
suddenly more interested yeah guava and
cream
how about we'll call it the cream and
guava pie
nah this sucks huh
standard menu item the McDonald's apple
pie everyone knows about this I don't
want a pizza version of this yeah and
last but not least cinnamon roll too
sticky I don't feel like eating it
update it's not sticky it's actually
exclusive drink starting with we have
something called B Naturals mixed fruit
juice next up we have something that
they call Raw mango fruit splash
oh it's a bit too sweet Berry lemonade
Splash all of these come in these very
unique reusable bottles apparently next
up strawberry Chiller green apple
Chiller and lemon chiller
is this flavored water that's exactly
what it is it's flavored water and I
kind of like it this is a mixed berry
smoothie
it's still quite sweet but quite good
next up American mud pie shake
um
that's pretty yummy drink roulette oh
and the ice melted fantastic Dr Pepper
let's go
Coke non-exclusive let's go sweetie too
sweet
oh yeah unsweetened tea not sweet enough
you guys combine for the kids watching
why are you watching where are your
parents or supervisors you can get
yourself apple juice milk come on milk
the thought of drinking straight milk
like hurts my stomach there's also
chocolate milk on the menu Once Upon a
Time this was an iced french vanilla
latte now it's more of a room
temperature French vanilla latte
it's like real like really sweet
strawberry banana smoothie
yeah I always love Cantonese these are
good so I'm gonna assume they're not
good for me exclusive hot drinks first
off we have strawberry green tea next up
uh English breakfast tea and Moroccan
tea next up a flat white coffee India a
land where we run on chai and McDonald's
does not have a chai option caramel
macchiato
cappuccino
caramel latte a vanilla cappuccino the
thing here with the V does look like a
you McDonald's premium roast coffee
I'm gonna hang on to this one
in India a chicken Maharaja Mac will
cost you 231 rupees for just the
sandwich that's around 3.03 us dollars
we do not have the chicken Maharaja Mac
but we do have the Big Mac and a Big Mac
in the U.S cost 4.89 that is a 61
percent price increase now what if you
turn this into a meal a make saver
Maharaja Mac combo comes with regular
fries and a regular drink and will cost
you 356 rupees that is 4.67 US Dollars
still less than the price of the
American Sandwich on its own but does
the combo meal make a difference in the
U.S a medium Big Mac combo so Big Mac
medium fries medium drink is 8.99 that's
a 92 cost increase even worse than if
you just bought the sandwich on its own
on the Indian McDonald's menu you'll
find a two-person Meal which contains a
chicken Maharaja Mac a veg Maharaja Mac
large fries two Pizza MC Puffs and a
drink all of this will cost you 681
rupees or 8.93 US dollars so basically
you're getting food for two people for
the price of one person's meal in the US
however while it seems a lot cheaper
than the food in the U.S it's still very
expensive and aspirational to people
over here your minimum wage per hour is
equal to our daily minimum wage and so
yeah a lot of people can't really afford
this kind of food the English-speaking
Indians that you see in a lot of YouTube
videos on the internet aren't really a
proper reflection of the majority of
people that live in this country who
still can't afford food like this so I'm
checking my privilege and we should all
make sure we check ours but let's play
Devil's Advocate McDonald's India has
definitely included a lot more
affordable options on their menu and so
they are more approachable to the
average Urban Indian than other fast
food chains
[Music]
let's compare some items to see who has
the least healthy McDonald's food in the
U.S a McChicken contains 400 calories 21
grams of fat 39 grams of carbs five of
those are sugar and 560 milligrams of
sodium how about the Indian McChicken
one of these contains 398 calories 15
grams of total fat 48 grams of carbs 5
grams of which are sugars
787 milligrams of sodium so the Indian
version has slightly fewer calories way
lesser fats but much more carbs and
sodium what if we made that a carnival
meal well a medium fry in the U.S
contains the following 320 calories 15
grams of total fat 43 grams of carbs no
sugar and 216 milligrams of sodium while
a medium fries in India contains 340
calories 17 grams of total fat 41 grams
of carbs 0 grams of sugars and 256
milligrams of sodium and if we add the
medium Coke that is adding 210 calories
no fat 56 grams of carbs 56 of those are
sugar and 55 milligrams of sodium ooh a
nice salty Coke we do the same here in
India one medium Coke will cost you 151
calories 0 grams of fat 38 grams of
carbs 38 grams of which our sugars and
there are 0 grams of sodium but my God
that is a lot of sugar packed in this
cup that leaves the Indian meal at a
grand total of 889 calories 32 grams of
fat 127 grams of carbs out of which 43
grams of sugars and
1043 milligrams of sodium
which means this whole bad boy all
together is 930 calories 36 grams of
total fat 138 grams of carbs 61 of those
grams are sugar
875 milligrams of sodium a little bit
lower sodium than India but we got you
guys beat in calorie fats carbs and
sugar
we win we win
unfortunately for India the combo starts
a little misleading and the Difference
Maker is the coke because the American
meal has a larger portion if you order
the Coke Zero in both countries the
Indian meal will actually have a higher
calorie count
McDonald's India does not share a full
list of their ingredients but there are
some things we do know about their food
like did you know that McDonald's India
actually changed Indian farming
practices just so they could grow the
kind of potato that they wanted when
they first launched in India 1996
McDonald's promised the government that
they would use products grown and
sourced right here in India but people
who had eaten McDonald's abroad realized
that the fries didn't taste quite the
same the reason for this is that Indian
potatoes were too small around had way
too much moisture and sugar content and
so the fries made out of them were not
long enough they didn't get crispy
enough and they didn't have that
distinctive McDonald's oof to them so
McDonald's partnered with making foods
and they spent nine years trying to
perfect their potato they imported
saplings which had the perfect shape and
starch content that they needed they
also chose Gujarat as their farming
location for its climate and they
switched from a flood irrigation to a
sprinkler system to reduce moisture
content and save water the result bigger
and more starchy potatoes that can be
used to make the McDonald's fries that
you know and love McDonald's in the US
mostly uses russet Burbank or shepherdy
shepherdy potatoes potato me
so these are big enough the distinctive
long fry yeah look how long this is WoW
known to be low moisture and low sugar
content this means they can remain
crispy when fried and don't caramelize
too fast so you can get a nice even
Browning McDonald's in the U.S actually
discloses all of its ingredients so we
can figure out a few other differences
in the U.S for instance our mayonnaise
contains egg yolk as does most American
male thanks to the FAQ page on the
McDonald's India website we found out
that the mayonnaise is eggless along
with all of the other sauces except for
the tartar sauce when people describe
things as vegetarian here in India they
typically mean it doesn't contain egg
from calorie count to portion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between dominoes in India and the US
this is food Wars
here in India our Domino's Pizzas come
in three sizes our Domino's Pizza comes
in four sizes the small eight inches
with four slices the small 10 inch which
is six slices the medium 10 inches with
six slices the medium 12 inches which is
eight slices and the large 12 inches
with eight slices the large 14 inch
which is I don't know four eight nine
hundred sixteen slices because I don't
know why they cut it this way I didn't
ask them to so and the extra large 16
inches or six slices
unfortunately our large margarita pizza
only comes in one crust option which is
the hand tossed you don't get it in pan
or in cheese burst or any other kind so
I am going to weigh one slice of large
margarita hand toast Pizza to see how
much it weighs 93 grams and I will weigh
a slice of our hand tossed and our pan
to compare the weight please note that
our mediums are the same size as their
larges
that's pretty insane yeah I'm not
surprised by that at all buddy hand
tossed
one random slice is 79 grams a slice
a pan same surface size we'll say but
obviously a lot thicker like wait I mean
come on
139 grams so that's a little less than
double
it's a large Domino's Margarita Pizza
it's also known as a plain or cheese in
the U.S this is 12 inches long it costs
419 rupees or 5.55 US dollars at current
conversion rates so the total surface
area of this pizza is
729.7 centimeter Square which means it
costs 0.76 cents per square centimeter
of this pizza take our large 14 inch
pizza which is 13.99 or 1056 Indian
rupee with an area of
993.1 squared centimeters just like
these slices are square I totally did
that on purpose that's 1.4 cents per
square centimeter that means the Indian
Pizza is 45 cheaper than the American
version
this is everything you'll get in a menu
at Domino's India that you will not get
in America a little skyscrapers you guys
have actual skyscrapers we have Domino's
Pizza Box skyscrapers here's everything
at the U.S terminals you can't get in
India we have five Stan we have five
different crust options we have pan then
you have Wheat Thin Crust cheese burst
is there supposed to be cheese in here
oh
oh there is cheese in here for sure then
we have hand tossed and we have
something called new hand tossed maybe
somebody else's hands were used to make
this one in the US our Domino's is five
crust options this one right here gluten
free if you can only get that as a small
pizza next over here hand tossed over
here the much thicker pan that's medium
only this guy in the middle here is the
crunchy thin which I just found out five
seconds ago they also cut in squares
didn't know that last and certainly not
least this is the Brooklyn style they're
thin slices but you only get this in the
large and the extra large hell yeah that
looks so good just by looking at them I
can tell that the hand tossed is
slightly thinner
um new hand tossed
there's a little firmer as a crust I
would opt for the regular hand tossed
Pizza finally just for fun the cheese
burst
that is such a guilty pleasure so I
thought this was cheese burst in the
sense that just the outer ring of crust
had cheese the entire peas base is
cheese burst all right here is our range
of vegetarian pizzas here in India to
keep with the religious Sentiments of
both Hindus and Muslims who are a
majority in our country we avoid using
beef and pork in most fast food
restaurants but what that means is that
we get a lot of delicious you know
vegetarian options number one Mexican
Green Wave I will say the colors on the
speeds are definitely look like the
Mexican flag jalapenos some tomatoes
onion cheese next up we have veggie
Paradise wow imagine calling an entire
Pizza a paradise red peppers capsicum
olives corn and cheese you guys in the
comments let me know does this look like
paradise to you I'm not in the comments
but I'll tell you right now it
absolutely does not it's funny they're
veggie Paradise is my pizza hell next up
Deluxe veggie mushrooms paneer corn
capsicum and onion
[Music]
I typically don't like when there's too
much on my pizza but the things you
really complement each other pretty good
but again there's so much going on in
this it's truly a deluxe Pizza next up
we have peppy paneer how fun red peppers
capsicum and paneer if you are wondering
what paneer is it's basically cottage
cheese and we love our paneer okay next
up we have paneer makhani if you're
wondering what makhani means it's a
paneer version of butter chicken if
you're wondering what butter chicken is
friend you need a culinary education
[Music]
maybe not I don't like it next up we
have cheese and corn it's got cheese
it's got corn and finally Indie paneer
Tandoori Pizza Tandoor is basically an
oven we use here it's cylindrical we use
wood fire and coal in it to sort of give
the meat and bread some Char to it and
Indie well this pizza has just not hit
mainstream yet
oh that is
spicy and a half if you can't take heat
avoid this one my favorite so far none
of them I will order non veg Pizza wow
India has a lot more vegetarian options
than we do and good for them I
personally don't want any of that we do
have two of our own exclusive veggie
options this here is the Pacific Veggie
and over here we have the spinach and
feta I don't want to try either of these
do I have to
it's a wasting valuable stomach space
you know like it's only so big all this
awesome Domino's food here you think I
want any of this in my stomach who cares
[Music]
got feta cheese on it this isn't so bad
non-vegetarian Pizzas number one we have
the pepper barbecue it doesn't look like
it has any vegetables just a bunch of
chicken pieces and with a nice Smoky
Barbecue flavor but you can choose a
pepper barbecue chicken with onion
that is a great combination chicken
sausage quite quite sausagey for sure
the next Pizza is what I believe to be
the best pizza you can order from
Domino's India the chicken Golden
Delight what a delightful name this is
one of the oldest pizzas that's been
there on the Domino's India menu it's
got nice sweet corn it's got some
Jalapenos in there and some delicious
delightful chicken
next we have the Dominator which seems
to have every single meat topping option
on the menu
my God
consider me dominated I don't think he
knows what that means
wow we're learning a lot about nikhail
today aren't we
whatever you know my man and next we
have chicken fiesta it's got some
tandoori chicken pieces some capsicum
onion nice simple flavors you can't go
wrong with this one and finally Indie
chicken tikka which is just the chicken
version of that paneer Pizza I had and
that one just burnt my lips so steer
clear of this one if you can't handle
spice but if you do
this is the one you should get actually
some of those look pretty good I'm very
impressed now here in the US every Pizza
that has beef on it is an exclusive and
we also got some chicken ones let's do
this I am starving all the way over here
this is the
Extravaganza which looks to have a bunch
of veggies mushrooms and pepperoni
this is the meatza 2 capital z's I'm
seeing pepperoni ham sausage possibly
hamburger all the meats hell yeah let's
go
thank you
I can maybe do one bite of that we're
not external sweat next we got the
Hawaiian pizza
A Plus on this one I put this one
definitely very good Cali chicken bacon
ranch you see it looks like it has a
sun-dried tomatoes bacon I'm assuming
and chicken white sauce a little flimsy
Guy this is the Brooklyn style so I
don't know why it's California
oh yeah
buffalo chicken pizza I mean they
drizzled it on there right you see
that's just drizzled
surprisingly very good the ultimate
pepperoni not just any pepperoni pizza
the ultimate pepperoni oh yeah well it's
covered in pepperoni who is right
oh yeah put me in a Pepperoni Como oh
yeah oh the deluxe Deluxe is just that a
little bit everything black olives
sausage Peppers ham probably bacon
you put black olives on anything it just
tastes like black olives ooh Memphis
Barbecue I Am pro barbecue sauce on
pizza it looks like a chicken here too
yeah onions
um yeah oh man that barbecue sauce
that's really nice Wisconsin
six cheese there's no way there's six
cheeses here I don't think I can Name
six cheeses we have mozzarella chatter
Asiago is American is that kind of
cheese
next up if all of those non-veg which
pizzas aren't enough for you
for your section called Chicken Lovers
and they have these four pizzas that
look absolutely insane they're more
topping than pizza at this point this
one is called the chicken five Feast so
they have chicken pepperoni chicken
tikka chicken meatballs
there is so much going on over there I
like it but it feels like a drug a pizza
drug next up we have the spicy double
chicken it has two different types of
chicken pepper chicken and tandoori
chicken and I assume it will be spicy
and I'm gonna take Domino's word for it
and then we have chicken Maximus which
sounds like a Roman Emperor who is also
a covered
um they have chicken sausage chicken
tikka this is a lot of chicken this is a
lot of chicken that's that's what this
has like oh my God can I just weigh this
it feels like a small baby I'm holding a
small baby
545 grams for a medium pizza and finally
we have what appears to be the king of
all of these chicken lover pizzas it's
an Indo Fusion Max
sounds like I don't know some sort of
detergent but uh dude you can't even
tell what like what number of
ingredients is on this I can't even see
the pizza at this point
oh my God I feel like a new man you have
to order this once in your life it gives
me deep displeasure to announce that
Dominos India has decided to create
these monstrosities called Pizza burgers
is a burger supposed to make this noise
in Bangalore where I'm from if uh
something bad happens to you your friend
will say you got a bun
and this is the bun they're talking
about they have three flavors classic
veg premium veg and classic non veg
oh man
no it's just veggies inside is that
cheese no no no no no no no
you know what I thought this would be
bad and
it's worse it's much worse it's not a
burger like nothing about this is a
burger except for the bun this might be
the worst thing I've eaten on food Wars
so far
okay we did kind of the same thing only
we call them sandwiches I've never
gotten one of these outside of food Wars
I'm just gonna pick this one right here
it looks like it is a chicken habanero
you wanna everyone wanna get bummed out
no
Philly cheesesteak listen up
Philadelphia Domino's wants to make you
guys proud
Philadelphia why are you not riding
right now at the Domino's headquarters
wherever it is because this is just
insulting oh no remember the
Mediterranean veggie here it is in
Sandwich form also when it's banana
peppers on it oh here we go
chicken bacon ranch love that
combination oh no you look at this look
at this this is just too much
this one I just labeled sandwich I
didn't know which one it was what the
look at this what is this
is this a buffalo chicken no on this one
guys Buffalo let us know in the chat how
insulted you are by this both residents
of Buffalo and Buffalo the animals uh
Italian they didn't skip by the
pepperoni you gotta give him credit for
that one the chicken
parm sandwich
[Music]
surprisingly Bland
they're not terrible but I mean why get
this instead of pizza
continuing the list of exclusive
Abominations we have a string of pastas
but also pasta pizzas which look
um fascinating here in Domino's India we
use fusilli pasta fusilli being the
whole helix DNA strand of passas we have
creamy tomato veg non-veg and we have
Moroccan spice wedge and non-veg and to
accompany these I'm sure delicious
pastas we have pasta pizzas in the same
flavors wow it's just really inventive
stuff going on over here this is the
Moroccan spice vegetarian pasta pizza
here we go they ask you how you are you
just have to say that you're fine when
you're not really fine
[Music]
it sent a shiver down my spine it's so
bad how many different types of carbs
are in this my disappointment is
immeasurable on my day is ruined okay
I'm gonna try one pasta just in case
it's good let's mix it up this one has
some tomato sauce in it
[Music]
this is bad we here in the US have our
pasta options that come in Penny Noodles
these type of noodle guys is that a good
shot of a penny noodle you can get it in
pasta primavera chicken carbonara
chicken alfredo Italian sausage marinara
again I don't know why you're getting
past it a pizza place
I like it just fine
is this the best pasta you can get in
your neighborhood most certainly not now
on to chicken wings we have three
flavors tomato chili sauce Peri Peri and
boneless Peri Peri I'm gonna try the
Peri Peri Wings just to see how they
Stack Up
they're all right this is your standard
run-of-the-mill chicken wings in a
country filled with millions of flavors
I can't believe we're still doing the
same standard flavors like Peri-Peri
barbecue and ranch where is my chicken
65 my chicken Mexican Heroes oh chicken
Heroes dominoes if you do chicken Gyros
wings I think you're gonna get a lot
more people Wings in the U.S we got them
too here's three flavors that we have
here in the U.S honey barbecue sweet
mango habanero and garlic parmesan
Domino's if you're watching you need to
effective immediately stop
doing this I don't know who your
organization said you know what we
should do instead of tossing it in the
sauce you know how everyone expects
their wings to come we'll just put on
here and drizzle look at this look at
this mess toss it toss the wings toss in
the sauce toss it in the sauce that's
how everyone does this how it's supposed
to be done next up exclusive sides
number one cheese pops
tater tots as you call them we have
fries and their crinkle cut that's
unique not a lot of restaurants here in
India do this they have been flavored
with a bunch of stuff though so I think
the views are
um oregano and chili flakes over here
they have here a veg parcel it's like a
little puff with the same you know
paneer pieces over here then they have
what they call uh tacos there's a
vegetarian version with some
simple veg cutlets and they have a non
vegetarian version with a slab of
chicken I do not expect that I am
speechless at the level of quality these
sides have compared to the pizzas then
you have a chicken parcel and finally
they have literal meatballs of chicken
with periperi dust on top of that this
is literally just one of their pizza
toppings that they're selling as a side
yes India has breadsticks and stuffed
cheesy bread but they don't have garlic
ones we got those we also have these
parmesan twists
look at these twisty guys and for
stuffed cheesy bread you can get it as
spinach and feta or bacon and jalapeno
dips this I don't know what they just
were like how could we give people Pizza
without bread behold this it is a dish
of cheese and marinara sauce they're
calling them dips cheesy marinara and
the if jeez come on look at that
look at that oil you see that right
there
exclusive sauce is at the U.S dominoes
you know what that means
tall here you can get these exclusive
sauces in the U.S can't get them in
India we got hot buffalo
sweet mango habanero honey barbecue
Ranch
ooh blue cheese for the wings right and
garlic
yeah it says Ranch they gave us two
ranches instead of a ranch and a garlic
and marinara those are like generous in
the marinara that's a big one we have
two separate dips over here in Domino's
India we have a cheesy dip and we have a
Cheesy jalapeno dip
cheesy dip
oh that tastes good okay cheesy jalapeno
dip really yum something about this
tastes spoiled is this past is expiry
date it tastes like curdled milk go with
the cheesy jalapeno dip for sure it's
time for desserts
dessert we just have one dessert here in
Domino's India but it's a banger this is
a Choco lava cake you heat it up and
boom
gooey lava goodness
oh wow this fixed everything that was
wrong with the menu of Domino's up until
now just eating this is so comforting I
can feel those memories of the pasta and
the burger and the Ridiculousness that
they served slowly disappearing from my
head like like thoughts from
Dumbledore's head when he's near the
pensive
hey India check out these desserts we
got you can't have them uh over here we
have a marbled cookie brownie now go for
brownie right
foreign
oh my God it's cookie dough and brownie
what a great idea
tips I don't know who I don't know who
in your organization said let's do dips
but you need to let that person go it's
like chunky applesauce
and cinnamon twists now it's time for
drinks yet again it's PepsiCo winning
over here we have Pepsi we have seven up
and mirinda unlike a lot of other
restaurants Domino's is yet to switch
from plastic pet bottles to something
like cans or reusable cups drinks again
in the U.S can't get in India I said the
UK Jesus I'm cracking up coke diet coke
Fanta orange the doctor Sprite Dasani
water I'm taking the Dr Pepper
large hand plus Margarita Pizza has
256.4 calories per slice so that means
the full Pizza is
2051.5 calories which is over twice your
daily recommended protein intake and
172.5 your daily sodium intake yeesh
our large cheese pizza is 2 240 calories
that's a 9.19 increase from India's
cheese pizza look I screwed up I needed
a thin crust for the crust section of
this video and I just randomly made it
this large just understand that maybe
Victoria can you do me a favor and take
this pizza here and this like put it
right there like can you just do that in
post please
next up one slice of a large Deluxe
Wedge Pizza is 220.5 calories and so the
entire Pizza is
1764 calories this is our large Pacific
veggie veggie pizza and it is 310
calories per slice which makes the full
Pizza 2 480 calories that's a 40 calorie
increase in the US and oof
get a load of that sodium over 200
percent your daily amount at Domino's
India our highest calorific Pizza is the
chicken dominatrix
chicken Dominator the chicken Dominator
dominating the calories I guess one
slice will cost you 399 calories and the
entire Pizza is a whopping
3192 calories which is
159.6 of your recommended daily intake
please steer clear from eating an entire
chicken Dominator are you estamos pizza
with the most calories is this the Cali
chicken bacon ranch ONE XL Brooklyn
slice of this it's 560 calories then
it's the full pie 3 360 calories that's
168 your daily recommended calorie
amount it's worth it it's delicious go
get a slice tell them Joe from food
we're sent to you
they'll have no idea what you're talking
about
the portion sizes we wanted to find out
all the differences between Subway and
India and the US this is food Wars
Subway sandwiches in India come in two
sizes
six inches
12 inches Subway in the US also has
those two sizes six inch and 12 inch now
the website also says there's a four
inch sub called a Chota sub Chota
meaning small but mysteriously it is
unavailable we called four Outlets
wasn't there and now we shall measure
the 12 inch sub to see if it actually is
12 inches okay when I'm honest right
that's 12 inches
all right Subway I'm getting more than
12 inches here Subway has given me a 13
inch sub
this is why I love Subway fun doesn't
stop there because in the US Subway also
offers catering options first you can
get this a platter which is five foot
long Subs cut into threes making a total
of 15 pieces let's see boom boom the
discrepancies continue here in India the
website says that we too have a platter
option but we called a bunch of stores
no platter option
and on top of that in the US you can get
a three foot long party sub gosh
we didn't get it this time Graphics you
can go ahead and put a three foot party
sub right in front of me thanks guys
okay is my ex-girlfriend running the
subway India website because it full of
lies they not only advertise a three
foot sub but a six foot Giant sub and
surprise surprise we called a couple of
stores no six foot Giant sub in fact
they said there are barely any six foot
humans here in India why would there be
a six foot sub and I was like yeah sorry
I'm the idiot hang up okay I am a short
thing
175 centimeters
this is how much I measure
now this is a six foot sub next to me
why would this be a thing it's taller
than me
well
Joe is six feet tall so
go ahead and
so if Graphics go ahead and make me a
sandwich in three two one
pretty comfortable can we do the rest of
the shoot like this
ugh this is pretty nice here in India
Subway is actually opted out of using a
lot of plastic which is why they only
stock these 330 ml cans which I am going
to measure just to make sure we are not
being fooled by PepsiCo
smells like my teeth decaying
it's about right 330 ml
Subway in the US we're still totally
using plastic cups small medium large
and the large is supposed to be 40
ounces why someone would want to drink
40 ounces of something that's not Malt
Liquor in one sitting is beyond me but
if you want 40 ounces of soda good Lord
Subway has you covered I of course am
curious to see if there actually is 40
ounces in this drink full food Wars
transparency I did have to fill out my
own fountain drink let's be honest could
we agree that if you had to get your own
drink fill it up to go you would
probably get this much now keep in mind
the cap is recessed
everyone roast me in the comments and
not filling up enough like you can only
fill this thing up so much
oh my God not even close you know I'm
even gonna like get the condensation on
the cup in there it just even like help
tip the scales in their favor right 34.
six you guys are
just say it's the 34 ounce cup 35 ounces
we're still gonna get it
still gonna get it shame on you I saw
that John Oliver episode terrible Subway
shame on you before you do the
franchisees and what you're doing
skimping on the sodas
foreign
menu items from India that you won't
find in the US here's all the Subway
menu items from the US you won't find in
India obviously Subway lets you
customize your sandwiches so we're not
talking about every single different
combination we're just going on what is
on the menu now let's begin it's
glorious the speed is like a Subway
buffet and I get to pick whatever I want
first of all the Aloo Patty this is
basically potato which has been cut up
into pieces and then fried with bread
crumbs on top
hmm
this is not bad but I think you can add
all the fancy sauces you want into this
thing nothing will beat a humble Mumbai
what up corn and peas that looks like a
lot of mayo I don't think I shall ever
order this sub this is a local Legend
This is the first thing a vegetarian
will order at an Indian restaurant
because it's this delicious mishmash of
spices vegetables and potato fried
Tangy delicious next up we have a
Mexican Patty I would like to extend an
apology to all my Mexican Brethren
watching that their great culture has
been reduced to a Patty of Aloo and
beans paneer Tikka beautiful pieces of
cottage cheese as you call it is it uh
weird for me to bite a Subway right
through the middle
would that upset you
[Music]
it's nice I wouldn't go with this
particular combination of vegetables and
sauces also I just want to point out
there are literally three pieces of
paneer in here when I used to go to
Subway in college I would make sure that
they put in like a lot of protein
this is Despicable veg Chic Kebab sheet
Kebab typically is minced meat that's
sort of pressed onto your skewer and
then grilled but this is a veg version
it has a lot of different mixed
vegetables and potato
hmm
that's pretty yummy I love the onions
the sauce combination is great and the
sheet Kebab it says not a flavor next up
we have the vegetarian shami Kebab uh as
you can see they're nice rounded balls
shami kebabs are from Lucknow here in
India they have a very crispy exterior
and a delicious melt in your mouth
interior they typically mince meat but
this is a vegetarian version let me try
this
oh
best one so far I'm so full
next up chakpata Chana Subway what a fun
name chakpata means full of Masala zingy
flavor really delicious Chana is lentils
it looks kind of like a dirty diaper but
I assure you this is gonna be absolutely
delicious
oh yeah
that's pretty good now on to the
non-vegetarian sub starting with this
one the Indian chicken tikka it's pretty
good
I just took a mouthful and there was
absolutely no chicken every bite should
have a bit of everything chicken kofta
kofta is basically meatballs and this is
chicken flavored you can see the
meatballs right there
wow that's actually really good whoever
picked the sauces on this one this is
the way barbecue sweet onion bit of
ranch a bit of mint Mayo this is the
best sub out of all of them I actually
think it's the combination of sauces
that makes the sub what it is it's
leaking flavor Peri Peri chicken ever
since McDonald's released Peri Peri
fries here in India there has been a
Peri-Peri Revolution over here a peri
per evolution
as I like to call it a lot of chicken
lot of meat um not a lot of veggies what
happened here some olives would have
been nice and finally this rejected
Subway over here is tandoori tofu which
I refuse to eat on principle because we
also have paneer over here it looks
pretty much the same and I'm sure it
tastes great you know what I realized
Subways opened up like this don't really
look all that great on camera do they oh
my God this looks like somebody's organs
U.S exclusive sandwiches you know they
say greatness is in the agency of others
well I'm here to say greatness is an
agency of other sandwiches I've tried
almost none of these starting over down
here we have something called the Maza
Meats let's take a look at this Yoli oh
I don't think I've ever seen this before
look they even got like the little like
uh
like the fresh mozzarella as well looks
to be all the Italian Meats oh by the
way unless otherwise important to the
sandwich I got everything with lettuce
tomato and onion and like no sauce
unless it includes the sauce so some
mercy on the people who had to wake up
two hours earlier to make these
sandwiches it's just like yeah just put
the same junk on all of them moving on
Supreme Meats oh yeah this is up my
alley salami the other salami ham no
turkey though huh this is capable what
is this provolone cheese this is
something that I would probably get at
Subway the Baja turkey avocado let me
open enough for you here turkey oh yeah
hey they were generous with the avocado
I think right going right in the middle
no big deal
moving on
honey mustard rotisserie style chicken
oh yeah
I like the flavor of that better than
like the regular chicken the
All-American Club ham turkey bacon
the Baja chicken and bacon
it's like weak
even the bacon doesn't have a lot of
flavor
let's get into the steak Baja stick and
jack cheese Black Forest ham
buffalo chicken
oh yeah look at that well they were
generous with the buffalo sauce chicken
bacon ranch
what does it say like the strongest
flavor and this is the tomatoes you guys
don't have the cold cut combo that looks
like baloney
then we have this next one
the meatball right India
I assure you this tastes way better than
it looks roast beef is you guessed it
roast oh god let's turn the red pink is
that normal oh spicy Italian a favorite
of mine to salami is both spicy you know
just like in Italy
the turkey calorie fresh I I think when
something's a Cali sandwich the Cali
means bacon and avocado the steak Cali
fresh
which has London gas bacon and uh
avocado no ah there's the bacon
[Music]
so unless I got covered in the past five
minutes the food at Subway has seemingly
become incredibly Bland steak and cheese
these steak sandwiches are like bricks
and look at this oh Yuli yes now there
are some sandwiches which appear on both
menus but have little differences when
it comes to ingredients for instance our
Subway Club comes with turkey ham and
bacon and our Italian BMT has ham
in India our Subway club actually has
turkey lamb and chicken slices and our
BMT does not contain bacon this is
because most fast food Outlets here
don't serve ham or beef because it will
hurt the religious Sentiments of Hindus
and Muslims in addition to our sandwich
fillings we also have some differences
in our bread options we have honey oat
multi-grain we have roasted garlic and
Parmesan oregano Italian white bread but
this looks oddly similar to the American
Italian cheese and herbs is it the same
thing Joe let me know no
here's exclusive U.S bread options at
Subway cheddar jalapeno bread
gluten-free bread tomato basil wrap and
Herobrine in both the US and India you
can get any sandwich as a wrap or in a
salad bowl other U.S exclusive option is
the Melt I wasn't going to get every
single melt the list goes as follows
Baja chicken and bacon melt chicken and
bacon ranch melt Baja Steak and Jack
melt buffalo chicken melt ham and cheese
melt Italian BMT melt meatball marinara
melt oven roasted turkey melts spiced
Italian melt steak and cheese melt and
tuna melt I went ahead and got two steak
melts and
oh brother the tuna melts
oh God it looks like cat food
[Music]
I definitely don't have coven because I
tasted that I need a steak and cheese
melt a palette cleanser after that
now we're talking here are our breakfast
sandwich options we have egg and cheese
chicken slice egg and cheese and Western
egg and cheese I am very curious to know
what makes this Western
mmm
I can see how this would be a western
option nice Bland easy on the palette
let me tell you something about India
all right if you flavor something that
we're buying at a restaurant with just
salt and pepper we call that a rip-off
at least at least 10 spices for some in
conceivable reason you can get the
breakfast sandwiches for long flatbreads
oh God this and they're so greasy uh egg
and cheese oh look how terrible this
looks
where's the cheese and what oh come on
man
foreign
[Music]
is a bummer
oh my God did you hear that like I mean
these eggs are you kidding me with this
what
I couldn't imagine eating a whole one of
these for breakfast without going
directly back to bed
the black Force ham egg and cheese
[Music]
oh God and now let's never speak of
those breakfasts ever again we have some
exclusive Subway toppings here in the
U.S you cannot get in India such as
spinach banana peppers and Monterey
cheddar cheese according to the Subway's
website in certain parts of the country
you can also get avocado carrot
guacamole sweet peppers feta cheese
pepper jack cheese provolone cheese
swiss cheese here in India unfortunately
all the toppings we have are also
available in the U.S damn it Subway are
we not special enough guys let's have we
know in the comments what special
toppings we should have here in India
however we do have our own exclusive
sauces sauce
starting with mint Mayo which is
absolutely a banger and the entire world
needs to taste this Tandoori Mayo which
we end up using because we overuse the
mint Mayo this balances it out and
finally red chili sauce I've also never
heard of mint mayonnaise and that sounds
incredible actually so in the US we have
a few of our own exclusive sauces such
as Ranch oil Subway vinaigrette and
plain mustard you guys have honey
mustard like us but not plain mustard
and in certain locations around the
country you can also get Buffalo sauce
creamy Italian sauce golden Italian
sauce Savory Caesar sriracha and uh-oh
Tzatziki cucumber Tzatziki or this is
the tea salad
cucumber in my defense I am incredibly
nauseous what if we took all of the Us
exclusive items and put them in one
sandwich well this time we're not going
to and thank you we actually made an
effort to make an edible U.S only
sandwich what we have is a steak sub
cheddar jalapeno bread with spinach
banana peppers mine right jack cheese
ranch and mustard
hmm this all works well together except
the mustard stands out which is kind of
a could do without it and the spinach is
fine don't taste the spinach so I guess
I wouldn't kill me to get some green in
here now what about an india-only sub
here is one with roast garlic bread
tandoori chicken tikka mint Mayo
Tandoori mayo and red chili sauce
I'm really feeling the lack of exclusive
toppings here Subway this is just meat
dripping in sauce make India exclusive
toppings happen right now Subway this is
the Eat Pray Love version of a sub in
the sense that it makes sense to
everybody else in the world except
Indians moving away from Subs our snack
section will tell you that we have a
pepperoni toasty and a veggie toasty
unfortunately at the time that we
ordered it was not available I have
tasted them before though and the
pepperoni one is pretty yummy Subway has
potato chips of course and these are
some U.S exclusives starting on this and
Sun Chips cheddar Harvest Sun Chips and
Subway I've always had a really good
alliance good for them
my favorite Miss Vicky's the jalapeno
chips these things are so good you can
also get the Miss Vicky's lime and
cracked pepper chips the one I went to
didn't have them this I can't believe
you guys don't have the nacho cheese
Doritos I mean this is like
like the most popular chip right and
last lays baked and also kids can get a
pouch of applesauce I'm assuming adults
can get it too but they're technically
for kids in India Subway's chip options
are a lot more limited and they vary
from store to store the one we visited
had a variety of flavors in coronitos
which are basically nacho chips and lays
and they had my personal favorite lace
flavor West Indies hot and chili but the
crew has informed me that they will not
roll further if I don't give a shout out
to India's magic masala
our Subway cookies have one exclusive
flavor and that is this the raspberry
cheesecake
this is so good I don't know how they do
it we saw to have an exclusive here in
India in the US you can get a chocolate
chip cookie but here you can get
dark chocolate chunk cookie or if you
really want to join the Dark Side a
double dark chocolate cookie
here at the subway in the U.S Coca-Cola
rules everything around me we got a lot
of Coke products here I put these in
order of which one I would probably want
to have with a sandwich coke diet coke
not a big diet guy but it's like with
the calories next is Sprite I mean who
doesn't love Sprite it's a little strong
I don't know if it goes well with a
sandwich but why not then we move on to
the simply drinks you got yourself
simply lemonade it doesn't like lemonade
right Simply Orange Juice I feel like
this is more for the breakfast
sandwiches right I mean OJ after 11AM
seems kind of strange to me and then
this apple juice if you want to have an
energy drink with your
sandwich Vitamin Water triple x
and Gator Gatorade yeah I mean I like
Gatorade but I mean it doesn't pair with
food at all last and not least all
natural energy green tea hydrated
coconut water antioxidants electrolytes
with ribose let's find out
whoa that's terrible this one smells
like BL
ah here in India Subway is actually
partnered with PepsiCo so instead of
Coca-Cola products you can get things
like Pepsi Mountain Dew Pepsi black
mirinda Tropicana orange juice and
aquavis water from the makers of
Aquafina that's so complicated why it's
like a movie title at this point
which country is getting a better deal
on its Subs let's compare a foot long
turkey sub in both in the U.S this will
cost you
8.99 in India ordering a foot long
turkey club sandwich on zomato one of
our food delivery apps will cost you
476.19 rupees that's around 6.27 right
now and while that's 30 cheaper than the
US sub it's still pretty expensive for
the average Indian for context in under
seven dollars you can feed an entire
family of four and you're going to get a
very delicious hearty meal in most
restaurants over here now to play
Devil's Advocate the Subway near my
college back in the day had a crazy deal
going on where they gave us a six inch
sub a cookie and a drink of our choice
in under two dollars and we used to eat
lunch at nearly every single day so I
guess from store to store there are
different offers and Subway is and can
be kind of affordable Subway prices have
been a contentious issue in America for
a long time a franchisee named Stuart
Frankel invented the five dollar footlog
back in 2003 which hit the mainstream in
2008. cheaper labor and food costs
combined with an increase in foot
traffic meant the promotion was actually
a huge earner for Subway sadly it didn't
last and a deal was phased out around
2012. when Subway tried to bring it back
in 2017 it was met with uproar from many
franchisees who said it was impossible
to make a profit from the promotion the
same thing happened again in 2020 when
Subway tried to push a 10 for two foot
launch deal which was killed after two
weeks
which country Subway is the most
unhealthy let's start with a foot long
turkey sub at whole grain bread with
lettuce tomato onion peppers and
cucumbers in the US this sandwich
contains 520 calories six grams of total
fat 2 grams of saturated fat 78 grams of
carbs of which 12 are sugars and 1580
milligrams of sodium in India the
nutritional information for this same
sandwich is 586 calories 6 grams of
total fat 4 grams of saturated fat 94
grams of carbs of which 8 grams of
sugars and 1 362 milligrams of sodium
when you break food down like this it
sounds pretty scary
so the U.S sandwich has more sugar and
more sodium than the Indian version they
have the same total fat content I don't
know what to take from that but the
Indian version has more calories
saturated fats and carbohydrates than
the US version my theory is because we
have that extra inch what's the most
calorific thing in the U.S menu
currently it's a foot long Cali fresh
steak sub with smashed avocado on whole
Italian bread one of these is a hefty
1220 calories there's also 68 grams of
fat in there 87 of your daily allowance
as well as 2 380 milligrams of sodium
over 100 of your daily allowance the
most calorific thing on the Indian
Subway menu is this paneer Tikka sub
footlong whole wheat bread with standard
salad it's a whopping 820 calories now
this is less calorific than the American
Cali steak sub and contains
significantly less fat at just 41 of
your recommended daily intake the main
thing to watch out for however is a
saturated fat there's 16 grams of it in
here which is 80 of your recommended
daily intake oh saturated fats you slide
dog
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in India and the US
this is food Wars
[Music]
in Burger King India our drinks come in
one standard size which looks to be your
small or medium but you can also opt for
a can of 330 ml Burger King in the US
our drinks come in four sizes value
small medium and large
let's measure this cup to see how much
is actually in here let's make anybody
else want to pee or is it just me 34
ounces well it says 38 at the bottom of
the cup it ain't 38. our Burger King
fries come in two sizes medium and King
our fries come in four sizes value small
medium large
I remember the large being bigger than
this I'm just glad that the fuss we Rose
for the first UK US Food Wars Burger
King has resulted fry transparency next
up chicken fries I didn't know this was
a thing so I'm very excited to eat them
it should have five pieces three four
five six thank you Burger King
oh never mind one of the fries had
broken they gave me five ours also is
one size nine chicken fries
pack of chicken cigarettes
seven eight nine a nice Brown and Brown
yeah we thought ahead for this one the
next one we shoot them when I'm wearing
all around on a brown jumpsuit we're
gonna paint this brown the most
unwatchable series
here's everything you'll find on the
menu at Burger King India that you won't
find in the US and here's everything you
can get at a US Burger King you can't
get in India let's begin with the
Whoppers this is a good time to mention
that here in India most fast food
restaurants do not serve beef or pork to
keep the religious Sentiments of both
Hindus and Muslims conservative Hindus
will not enter a restaurant that serves
beef conservative Muslims might not
enter a restaurant that serves pork all
right keeping all of that in mind let us
begin with the chicken Whopper
boy okay Burger King definitely has
larger Burgers than most of the
restaurants here in India look at this
it's the size of my face I am the Burger
King
that's so good you might notice if you
are a regular Burger King consumer of
the foreign lands that if you were to
eat this one it's a little spicier and I
think they've done that because most
Indians love their spice there's a lot
of bite to it next up double chicken
patty whoa whoa whoa whoa this one's got
some heft to it huh the mutton Hopper
mutton if you are unaware is goat meat
and Burger King is one of the few fast
food chains here that actually serves
red meat of some kind Indians love their
mutton I love my mutton
it's definitely more meaty has a lot
more bite to it than the chicken you are
burping what are you doing the quality
is out of control every beef burger at
Burger King is a U.S exclusive got all
the Whoppers let's start down here the
little guy the Whopper a junior not
enough meat you say get yourself a
Double Whopper same Burger two patties
can they go bigger they can the terrible
Whopper look at this thing
close your mouth when you're taking a
picture the Texans of the audience might
have to help us out in the comments here
the Texas Double Whopper Texas Prides
itself from what I can tell I know he's
going bigger so why wouldn't it be the
Texas triple Whopper a rare moment where
Texas was reserved
Texans of the internet I think you guys
need to step in here I don't think that
sandwich is doing you guys proud on to
the veg options this is a veg Whopper I
expect great things from this bad boy
I would say this is pretty lackluster
next up veggie double burger
if you want double the disappointment
another thing that we have that
technically isn't beef is The Impossible
Whopper which is made with impossible
beef I'm actually very curious how does
the impossible burger patty taste Joe
regular beef
beef
I have the engine it tastes exactly the
same I want to give the environment a
break I'm gonna get one of these every
once in a while next up we have an
exclusive King collection of burgers
these better be uh quite Royal and
aristocratic number one hot and cheesy
veg a lot of jalapenos
the Patty actually has like cheese melt
in it hot and cheesy Kings collection on
a scale of common villager to the king
himself I would rate this Village Bard
once in a while you want him there just
to appease a few people but otherwise
pretty lackluster paneer Royal just by
the name itself this one should be
incredible so paneer if you don't know
is cottage cheese and here in India it
is almost a staple we eat it in
everything we eat it in curries we
sometimes just sear it and eat it plain
and obviously it had to make its way to
Burgers
the paneer is really good chewy and
delicious I would rate the paneer Royal
a local Baron helps the King around a
little bit now on to the two non-veg
options we have fiery chicken food plain
and simple they just want this meat to
blow my mind
it's just spicy that's all it is it
doesn't have the depth of flavor that
the chicken Whoppers did chicken
Tandoori if you guys don't know what a
Tandoor is it's basically this
cylindrical oven that we heat up using
wood fire and charcoal traditionally and
we use it to create everything from
kebabs to breads I doubt all Burger King
Outlets have an actual Tandoor in the
restaurants but let's see if they were
able to replicate that Smoky flavor
on a scale of absolute Street urchins to
maharajas I would rate these two court
traitors that tried to backstab the king
and now they're on trial they have a lot
of bark but not enough bite they're
going to be executed soon non-wafa
Burgers AKA Burgers get yourself
something called the Big King that's
what it looks like don't have it what we
do have is the single quarter pound King
bacon King I would say generous amount
of bacon
great then these little much more
reasonable sized Burgers bacon
cheeseburger bacon double cheeseburger a
bacon-free double cheeseburger right one
of the most hilarious things on the
Burger King menu is of course the Rodeo
Burger a burger with barbecue sauce and
onion rings because why not yeah
cheeseburger regular dry ass hamburger
who cares enough kingly sandwiches it's
now time for the regular vegetarian
options that they have we have crispy
wedge crispy wedge double crispy wedge
with cheese BK classic BK classic with
cheese light Whopper Junior and light
Whopper Junior with cheese why is it
called light Whopper Junior how many
more things do you need to add to the
name to make it seem small mini light
small Whopper Junior kindergartner
burglar how about that next time Burger
King okay I don't want to try any more
veg Burgers but this one the BK classic
which seems different like the bun looks
to be the same but they've definitely
used more perky buns here
don't use that audio clip out of context
okay finally if you're a vegetarian I
would recommend the BK classic with
cheese boom although it is currently for
a limited time thought I would share
with you guys here in the US we have the
South West options at Burger King
starting with the Southwest bacon Junior
Southwest Whopper the Southwest
impossible Whopper what makes it
Southwest oh I'm seeing like crispy
little chippy guys spice oh it's got
some heat to it yeah there's guacamole
on your hand
I kind of bug with it I wouldn't eat it
if I didn't work at Food Wars you know
for the chicken sandwiches these look so
tiny compared to the Whoppers we have
crispy chicken crispy chicken double
crispy chicken with cheese BK classic
chicken spicy grilled chicken big Smoky
grilled chicken light Hopper chicken
Junior light Whopper double chicken
Junior and light copper chicken Junior
with cheese
so I could walk at Burger King right now
we're going to try just two of these
Burgers just to see if they're any
different first one the spicy grilled
chicken
oh my God I can imagine myself going to
a drive-through taking one of these
driving a box sitting in silk road
traffic getting annoyed with all the
other people honking realizing I should
have gotten a bigger burger and next day
ordering two nice next up the big Smoky
grilled chicken
I don't see how this is Smoky at all in
fact it's kind of sweet and to the naan
beef options I personally think these
new chicken sandwiches are fantastic the
chicken that's CH apostrophe King
because it's Burger King spicy chicken
sandwich same thing got some spicy sauce
on it this is very good if you like
these but want a little more veggies
because you're some old fogy here you go
vegetables they also make the chicken
Deluxe Deluxe equals lettuce and tomato
this car crash of a sandwich is the
spicy actually the spicy with veggies is
actually kind of nice the coolness of
the the lettuce and the Tomato actually
counterbalances the spice The Original
Chicken Sandwich shaped like the new
iPhone for some strange reason this
guy's been around forever it's their
answer to the McChicken it tastes
exactly like a McChicken chicken Junior
there's a little guy
the spicy chicken Junior and last the
only non-chicken thing in the chicken
section is the big fish and now for a
set of snacks that comes under the
stunner menu
we have King Egg Burger King Egg wrap
crispy veg wrap veg crunchy volcano
that's right this is not even a wrap
this is a little geological formation
Tiki twist Burger veg makhani burger and
chicken makhani burger and finally
Crispy Chicken Wrap and crunch chicken
volcano all right the first Burger we're
trying is the chicken makhani burger so
makhan means butter and it also means a
lot to us Indians you just walk in the
room and you say makhan it will ReSound
through the room like people's eyes will
perk up the hairs on their arms will
rise
oh my God yeah
okay so they've gone for like a butter
chicken makhani flavor but it just
tastes like tomato puree over a stale
chicken patty next thing that I really
want to try is the The Volcano itself
and I think this is their answer to Taco
Bell's Crunchwrap
oh that's pretty good he was this close
to offending two communities and Mother
Earth herself but pretty good next thing
I'm gonna try is an Aloo Tiki twist uh
Tiki twist sounds like a cocktail but
Aloo Tikki is actually it's like mashed
potato fried with bread crumbs and it's
used in charts it's used in a lot of
other dishes and they put these crispy
shards of what seems to be the same
material in the volcano
Illuminati confirmed
[Music]
on to breakfast
we got breakfast at the BK in the U.S
you can get an assortment of Chris
sandwiches biscuits melts I didn't get
all of them starting down here a
sandwich of course for those United
America is they took a croissants and
stuff eggs and cheese and your choice of
breakfast meat bacon egg and cheese
croissant sausage egg and cheese
croissant ham egg and cheese croissants
bacon egg and cheese biscuit sausage egg
and cheese biscuit ham egg and cheese
biscuit cheesy ham breakfast melts
sausage and cheese breakfast melt cheesy
bacon breakfast melt and for both the
sandwiches and the biscuits you can also
get pretty much every combination of
meat egg and cheese onset biscuit or
croissant eggnormous burrito uh no no no
no no I am not starting off my morning
with this no thank you this looks like a
dirty diaper like what is any of this I
feel like if I bit this in the like one
bite of this in the morning and I'm on
the toilet get yourself two platters
sausage and pancake splatter and this
one thing like the platter Deluxe you
guys have pancakes good stuff bacon get
yourself eggs and of course syrup next
up chicken wings Burger King here sells
boneless chicken wings they feel like
chicken tenders only
the super meat is like proper chicken
it's not like that processed nuggety
chicken juice thing that happens in the
U.S our Burger King has nuggets and they
come in four pieces and eight pieces I
asked the Burger King employees about
the 16 piece and they said they don't
have a 16 piece they just give you two
eight pieces now it's time for Burger
King India's sides and sauces number one
we have the classic Peri-Peri fries they
give it to you with a little sachet of
the Peri Peri powder and a little shake
bag pour it in there
thank you
voila your simple plain fries are now
peri-perried
hmm
go with McDonald's Peri Peri fries I'm
sorry Burger King two powdery almost
chalky and the flavor is not quite there
okay
it's very pretty Places come back to the
Vengeance fair enough there is a bit of
spice to it next up cheesy fries Italian
cheesy fries and I don't know what makes
these Italian but
think it's a whole lot of oregano and
finally veggie strips well the BK here
in the US and get yourself onion rings
jalapeno cheddar bites see what this
looks like mozzarella stick nuts
applesauce
can't have nuggets without sauces you
know what that means
sauce talk as for the dips we have easy
cheesy Twisted mustard fiery hell they
literally named one of their dips fiery
hell first up buffalo sauce honey
mustard Ranch sweet and sour zesty sauce
do we know what this is
that is just mayonnaise and like brown
mustard marinara sauce salsa Del Sol it
is milkshake name Burger King has three
flavors right now they have mango berry
blast and chocolate guys at the time of
filming this it is currently mango
season here in India none of you have
tasted a real mango until you've tasted
the king of all mangoes Alfonso
available here everywhere you go right
now you're gonna get a delicious mango
milkshake we also make something called
amras which is like a delicious mango
juice the meat with booties and stuff
let's see if this compares to fresh
mango juice
oh it's pretty good it's not too sweet
it just kind of tastes like mango ice
cream sort of mixed but I like it I
really like it next up berry blast paper
straws Burger King thank you the
Dolphins appreciate it just as much as I
do
whoa I did not expect that flavor here
we have something called blackcurrant
ice cream that's rampant in uh very
demented families that order the the
black currant ice cream I'm sorry to
single out these Indian families like
this but this tastes like that I'm
sensing a pattern here so it won't be a
surprise to me if the chocolate
milkshake also just tastes like watered
down chocolate ice cream the mango one I
suppose if it wasn't mango season you
could go and get a mango milkshake but
otherwise go to any other fruit or
milkshake store in India get a nice
thick mango shake with actual mangoes
way better answer the cold drinks let's
start with the shakes over here we have
a frozen Coke you can also get a frozen
Fanta Wild Cherry sounds amazing our
Burger King did not have it first one is
this the Oreo shake
why is that so good it's like a shake
made out of the stuff in the middle
brilliant idea and you can also get
chocolate Oreo shake
no it's not this one's better this one's
very good desserts I'm a sucker for
desserts but why would you order dessert
from a fast food place unless I'm going
to be proven wrong first up they have
chocolate mousse cup okay it's got a
little bit of cake at the bottom
chocolate chocolate chocolate it's a top
chocolate chips on the top
too decadent very sweet next up they
have a Choco lava cup keeping in theme
with their random volcano based food
items and I'm sure this wood oozer
chocolate but you have to heat it first
that is so sweet when would I eat this
I'm trying to think of when I would eat
something this sweet
never we have three dessert exclusives
the first one is just the Hershey's
Sunday pie chocolate chip cookies a soft
serve cup or cone where is a gel well
it's roughly 100 degrees here in
Southern California and that thing would
have melted into a soup before we even
got it to the studio imagine either a
soft serve ice cream cone or a melted
soft serve ice cream cone would be more
accurate as for cold drinks we have
Pepsi Mountain Dew mirinda which is an
orange soda and iced tea all of these
are Under the PepsiCo range of products
and of course in India the Pepsi slogan
is
swag which means every sip has a lot of
swag
no I have to live with the screens for
the rest of my life now here in the U.S
we have obviously a variety of exclusive
drinks can't get in India
Coke Dr Pepper diet coke there it is
barks baby Fanta orange I should say
that at least the bks that I go to here
in sunny Southern California has those
Coke freestyle machines so you can also
get yourself an orange juice it's really
funny looking at orange juice next to
orange drink like look at the difference
with it orange juice orange drink Capri
Sun apple juice Burger King iced coffee
the BK Cafe which is of course coffee
milk
let's stock price a single Indian
chicken Whopper will cost you 199 rupees
or 1.56 US dollars at current conversion
rates in the US a Whopper costs 8.79 or
668 Indian rupee that's around a 236
percent increase in price making a meal
with medium fries and a large drink and
it'll cost you 383 rupees or 5.03 US
Dollars add a medium fry and a medium
drink to the order and that brings the
price to
16.37 or
1246 Indian rupee again about a 225
increase now upgrade to the large size
and it's 407 rupees or 5.35 US Dollars
make it a large
16.77 or
1276 Indian rupee it's a 214 increase
200 rupees for a single burger is
actually very expensive and while fast
food in the U.S and other foreign
countries might seem like something that
the average person can easily afford
here in India this is expensive and only
the upper middle class and the rich can
actually go out and have a burger like
this in fact in Mumbai where we're
filming this right now our most popular
street food is vadapa which is like a
potato burger and it cost is 15 rupees
which is 20 cents it can fill you up
downgrade the cost upgrade the taste get
a Vada pav to better illustrate the
price difference let's compare the US
large Whopper combo to our combination
of two Whoppers two crispy chicken
sandwiches five piece chicken strips
King fries and four drinks all of this
still costs less at just 1102 rupees or
14.45 US Dollars we would have to add
crispy veg with cheese and crispy
chicken with cheese to get around the
same price but again I have to remind
you that in 14 an average family here in
India could eat at home for a week
calories time my favorite part of these
videos because I realize how much I
should not be eating this food let's
start off with a crispy chicken sandwich
from Burger King
it has 430 calories and in the U.S our
crispy chicken sandwich is 670 calories
next up is one of Burger King India's
most popular Burgers the wedge Hopper at
728 calories imagine that high calories
low taste we don't have that but in the
U.S our Burger King does have the
impossible Whopper which contains 630
calories next let's compare the fries
and average box of king-sized fries will
cost you 535 calories if I had to choose
between these fries in an hour of
cycling this video I'd probably skip the
cycling but this is still bad it's it's
a lot of calories and in the U.S a large
fry has 430 calories and now for some
reason if you're really looking to pack
on those calories introducing Burger
King India's most calorific sandwich the
Masala wedge Hopper at a total of
734 calories
the website of Burger King India also
says they sell a 15 piece grilled
chicken wings with a total of
1256 calories but we caught a bunch of
stores it was unavailable and I think
they discontinued it because they did
not want to kill half the country oh yo
yeah
a block of calories and a usbk our most
calorific sandwich is this the bacon
King just one of these Bad Boys 1
359 calories oof
from calorie count to potion sizes we
want to find out all the differences
between Pizza Hut in the US and in India
this is food Wars
the smallest Pizza in the US is the
personal pan pizza and it is six inches
across in India our pizza start at
personal size it's 7 inches wide and has
four slices
the US also has a small pizza but only
with the gluten-free crust and it is
difficult 10 inches wide so depressing
looking
then we're on to the mediums a medium
pizza here in India is 10 inches and has
six slices a U.S medium Pizza comes in
at 12 inches wide this medium Pizza is
equal to the small pizza in the U.S
people in the US sometimes it's just
really hard not to stereotype you guys
next up in India we have
nothing because medium is our largest
size that's right we have only two sizes
personal or medium no large for us
because Pizza Hut is watching our weight
I guess
stereotype away my man because in the
U.S you know we got this large and it is
14 inches in diameter so America's
largest pizza is four inches wider than
India's largest that doesn't sound so
bad however if you calculate the surface
area of the two pizzas those few inches
make a big difference the India medium
has a surface area of 78.5 square inches
while the US large clocks in at
153.9 square inches to save you from
doing the math that's a 96 increase that
means the U.S large pizza is nearly
double our Indian medium what the heck
Pizza Hut the type of crust you get
doesn't affect the width of the pizza
but how does it affect the value we're
going to weigh a medium hand tossed
Slice versus a medium pan crust slice to
see which one gives you more pizza for
your money all right I'm gonna do the
same with our pan and San Francisco
style pizzas uh they're medium size all
right so medium hand tossed weighs 94
grams
Pan the thick boy
Whoa 104 grams that's a difference of
what was the first one
uh that's a difference of this many
grams this one is pan style and it
weighs 78 grams this slice
weighs 66 grams fairly lighter and I
think this is because when they make
this pizza they press it down into the
pan and that's the San Francisco style
this weighs more and therefore is more
because it's more bread you got the
cheese and the sauce you want the fun
stuff right I don't know
oh boy this is gonna be trouble
[Music]
here is everything you'll find on the
menu at Pizza Hut India that you will
not find in the US and here are all the
Pizza Hut menu items from the US you
won't find in India let's start off with
the foundation of any pizza the crust
starting with the San Francisco
signature style to my understanding it's
basically a pan pizza but they press the
dough in with their hands so it's kind
of hand tossed next up we have something
very special it's a Schezwan pan pizza
oh my God yeah I really like this it's
spicy really um just to give you some
comparison the way chicken tikka masala
was invented in the UK but clearly
inspired by Indian Cuisine Schezwan
sauce was actually invented here in
Kolkata by the Chinese community that
settled down here but it's obviously
inspired by Chinese cuisine and now it's
become part of Indian Cuisine we have
accepted it Holi and we eat it all
across India very exciting to see it
integrated into the Pizza Hut menu and
it actually tastes very good on this
pizza next up they have a stuffed cheese
crust Max with two x's for emphasis you
can already see that this thing is
loaded with cheese next to the cheese
alongside it there's like a sort of
creamy sauce which Pizza Hut is calling
Peruvian creamy sauce
wool oh my God yeah this is decadent
food next up we have a stuffed crust
with veg Kebab that's right if you don't
know what Kebab is it's basically meat
that's cooked in like a Tandoor if you
don't know what a Tandoor is please go
watch older episodes of food was I've
explained it eight times a lot of people
like to leave the crust behind but I
feel like pizza is making sure all of
the pizza has eaten because even this
looks like a dish in itself at this
point
my God that's really young and the final
option the stuffed crust with a
non-vegetarian kebab
as you can see this is what looks to be
chicken chic
oh that's the best of a lot that was
amazing oh my God smashed it Pizza Hut
that might be the best pizza I've had on
poorva so far and I didn't even eat the
pizza apart we also have a variety of
crust options in the U.S starting down
here you saw it already here it is again
the hand tossed this to me is like
Classic this is the default you guys
don't have hand tossed moving on thin
and crispy I mean how much look at this
they can't charge the same amount for
this right I don't think they should
moving on over here the original stuffed
crust they put cheese in the crust can
you believe that
it is it is solidified doesn't stop me
from biting into it
yeah yeah yeah last
and let's be honest least gluten-free
crust look I don't know what's going on
gluten allergies and my apologies if you
have one but I'm look at this I'm just
like I'm sorry guys I mean is this that
much better I don't know how you can
enjoy this and for a limited time Pizza
in the USS Detroit style pizza let's go
let us go look at this are you kidding
me with this Detroit style pizza what's
Detroit style well they cook it in a
square pan that has like sides to it
it's like when you cook brownies in
every brownie is like a corner or end
piece it's like that for pizza so every
slice is gonna have the crispy crust on
the outside is thicker one of my
favorite pizza Styles I'm glad Pizza is
doing it generous with the pepperoni
guys I appreciate it
not the best Detroit selfies I've ever
had but it's pretty good I think they go
bread cheese topping sauce these are the
toppings we found under the categories
classic favorites and Delight very
arbitrarily named but yeah let's jump
into it the first option is chicken
sausage smells really good a lot of
onions I love onions
hmm
it's pretty classic the next Pizza is
spiced paneer paneer if you don't know
is cottage cheese we make it all over
the place here in India and it's one of
our favorite ingredients we use it on
everything even pizzas
not very spicy but definitely it's got
like a Tangy twist to it next up we have
the veggie Feast it's got some herbed
onion capsicum and sweet corn
this is like such a wholesome chill
Pizza it's definitely a classic it's
something your mom would make at home
next up we have the veggie Tandoori
which I have already taken a bite of we
got this one with the Schezwan crust so
it's definitely spicier than the typical
pan pizza you'll get and I already
tasted it and I told you I loved it I
love the spice next up we have spiced
chicken
meatballs it's a very straightforward
pizza but we got it with the cheese
burst filling next up we have the
chicken and corn Delight it already has
the word delight in the name so I'm
assuming it should be a delight but I'll
be the judge of that capsicum chicken
just strewn across and corn
it's got too much going on I would say
personally I would not order a pizza
like this next up to round it all off
this is the double chicken sausage pizza
am I wrong in saying that this just
looks like a boring version of the
normal chicken sausage pizza which has
onions and this feels a lot better we
have a pepperoni pizza that is made of
pork and that chicken and a pepperoni
lovers Pizza which one has more
pepperoni I can't tell the Supreme Pizza
it has pepperoni mushrooms green peppers
onions and that's it but if that's not
Supreme enough for you we have the super
supreme which now they've introduced
black olives meat lovers baby meat
lovers you got pepperoni you got bacon
you got sausage I bet there's something
else on there that I don't know another
meat that's just it's beautiful this
next Pizza is the veggie lovers and I
absolutely hate it now you want veggies
go get a salad then put on pizza like
you're not fooling anyone right Backyard
barbecue chicken Yulie do you have
enough b-roll
I think it's barbecue chicken but I
think they use barbecue sauce instead of
pizza sauce genius genius
this is so good oh yeah a buffalo
chicken it looks like surprisingly good
Pizza does not have a straight Hawaiian
pizza on the menu the only thing they
have is Hawaiian chicken I see obviously
chicken I see a pineapple
I think I say ham yep I think Hawaiian
should just be pineapple and bacon if
you want to throw some chicken on that's
fine but if you have a strong opinion
either four against pineapple on Pizza
you're wrong it's a perfectly fine
topping I don't know why everyone gets
so worked up about it more pizzas and
these are all part of the Signature
Collection
um there are 11 pizzas in front of me
two four six okay first off the country
Feast um it looks super Saucy it's all
loaded with vegetables there's mushrooms
capsicum onion sweet corn roasted
Peppers everything that you want on a
country themed Pizza all right next up
we have Tandoori paneer if you remember
in the previous categories we had spiced
paneer so all I'm looking for is why is
this different
oh my God
that's really yum next up is the veggie
lover it's basically got tomato onion
capsicum mushrooms and some red paprika
and hopefully a whole lot of flavor
[Music]
it's underwhelming I'm gonna be honest
next up we have chicken tikka everybody
knows chicken tikka
it's a bit too strong too Tangy and I
think they could have gone with a
thinner layer of sauce next up we have
the Malai chicken tikka Malai is
basically cream so um Malai kebabs they
basically Grill the chicken and they
pour Malai on top we have the chicken
pepperoni double paneer Supreme you like
paneer you like Supreme clothes well
this has double of it minus the clothes
veggie Supreme everybody in India has
heard of this pizza this is a painting I
can genuinely see this on the wall of an
art gallery this capsicum there's olives
there's corn there's onions there's corn
again veg Kebab surprise I'm curious to
know what's going to be surprising about
this
surprise surprise it tastes Bland and
now on to our penultimate signature
Pizza this is the chicken tikka Supreme
woohoo
basically what they've done is they've
taken four different kinds of chicken
and they put it on a pizza and finally
in the line of signature pizzas we have
Triple Chicken Feast it has all of the
above ingredients and we've also gone
the extra mile and taken it with a
chicken stuffing in the crust overall
Pizza Hut has actually killed it I think
all the ingredients have tasted Super
Fresh all the meat has also tasted
really soft and Juicy and Delicious and
the sauce has been consistently yum
throughout damn Pizza Hut
good job as mentioned before currently
have a Detroit style pizza at the U.S
Pizza Hut this is what it looks like two
slices are missing I skipped lunch and
breakfast to be honest for those of you
outside of the United States Detroit is
a city in Michigan they have their own
style of pizza I really enjoy it you can
also get it as a supreme Detroit style
and a meaty Deluxe Detroit style and I
didn't get them because it all looks
exactly like this one fun option on the
Pizza Hut India menu is their new range
of momo Mia pizzas which are pan pizzas
with Momos baked into the crust now if
you don't know what Momos are they're
basically dumplings from Nepal and Tibet
they served all across India and they've
become huge favorites for everybody over
here they've also given a Schezwan sauce
to the side which is what you typically
eat with Momos
hmm
that ain't right I don't see how this is
working I can't think of a single
Italian who would put a pocket of
ravioli on top of a pizza and then bake
them together
and this is effectively what that is we
also have a range of flavor fun personal
pan pizzas that you can get with a host
of new flavors starting off with classic
corn next up we have the classic onion
and capsicum Tandoori mushroom and corn
so it looks similar to this but they use
Tandoori sauce and they've added
mushrooms next up we have the classic
paneer onion and capsicum then we have
the classic chicken sausage but personal
pan sized next we have the Italian
pepperoni and onion and just a reminder
that the pepperoni that they've used is
chicken pepperoni tandoori chicken tikka
and onion and the classic Loaded Chicken
Delight personally
I wouldn't order these pans I would get
the larger pizzas because they tasted
way better on top of set menu items we
can also customize our pizzas in unique
ways for example if you don't want
tomato sauce as your base you can sub it
out for creamy garlic parmesan barbecue
sauce remember from before buffalo sauce
or a no sauce option if you are a maniac
and if you want you can specify light
regular or extra sauce unfortunately we
can't change the sauces on our pizza
bases but we have a bunch of custom
toppings that you will not find in the
US like baby corn sweet corn herb
veggies spice paneer and veg kebab and
we also have exclusive toppings you
cannot get in India for instance we have
pepperoni which is pork Italian sausage
has pork bacon uh I believe it's pork
meatballs beef and pork ham pork and
then beef
and pork then the vegetables we got
white onion we got pineapple which is a
fruit and we have banana peppers which I
don't know if it's a fruit or a
vegetable or a pepper our peppers fruit
whenever we have the option of
customizations on food Wars we like to
combine all of our exclusive ingredients
to make an india-only pizza so this
pizza has a Schezwan base with baby corn
wedge Kebab spiced paneer and herbed
veggies it looks pretty gnarly I'm not
gonna lie but let's see how it tastes
[Music]
hmm I can see why Pizza Hut didn't put
this officially on their menu because
maybe the ingredients go don't go that
well together but hey this is an India
only Pizza Hut pizza and that means
something and of course we had to create
our own us only pizza so the thin crispy
base creamy garlic Parmesan sauce beef
bacon white onion and everyone's
favorite vegetable banana peppers
ah
this looks like a cartoon Pizza wow
okay is that bad it's not great I
wouldn't get it yeah it tastes like
onion and bacon don't get this oh
Pizza Hut has a bunch of sides so let's
start off with the breads first off we
have cheese garlic bread then we have a
spicy Supreme cheese garlic bread it's
basically cheese melted on top of a
garlic bread baguette it's got some
green chili and some chopped onions it's
very delicious when it's hot Mexican
garlic bread sticks oregano sprinkled on
top some jalapenos some chopped olives
and onions it looks really delicious
creamy garlic bread sticks and finally
we have garlic bread sticks in a little
packet that says garlic breadsticks
the U.S Pizza Hut only offers regular
breadsticks and cheese sticks so in fact
the only actual exclusive side that we
have in the U.S is fries we have a bunch
of other sites including baked cheesy
Momo's wedge and baked cheesy Momos
non-ridge
that's a potent smell you know what
it's not half bad next up we have potato
poppers which are pretty much tater tots
we have the indie rock and roll veg and
the indie rock and roll non-veg this is
basically a roll but I like how the wrap
is kind of thin
no again it's quite good next up we have
the zesty paneer pocket and the zesty
chicken pocket these are pretty much
like pizza pockets there's some mint
Mayo some normal Mayo some cream cheese
chicken and jalapenos we have jalapeno
poppers I imagine they're just filled
with cheese and some jalapeno bits oh I
did not expect that consistency and that
brings us to an old classic chicken
wings spicy baked chicken wings so I
suppose they're a healthier alternative
Wing Street Wings yes both traditional
and boneless you can get them in the
following flavors lemon pepper oh let's
go lemon pepper
I usually don't like lemon pepper but
these are pretty good ooh honey barbecue
he's getting these things out like
condensation uh oh the medium Buffalo oh
Cajun style
[Music]
just okay spicy garlic but naked
that's wings with nothing on it why
would you do that I don't know Buffalo
burning hot three Flames
um
this should be a medium oh wait
yeah okay
sweet chili am I sweating I feel like
I'm sweating
they're all just you know I mean I like
wings maybe my wing standards are too
high garlic parmesan oh
my God I mean the sauce like pasta sauce
it's really thick and it's got a lot of
flavor to it but it's just like sitting
in the sauce so either you get a
mouthful of sauce or none and these come
in portions of 6 12 18 or 36. and next
up on the menu you can also find a range
of pastas starting with the creamy
mushroom
you know what if I have to listen to
this so will you all
you know
just get get some of the boom mic
[Music]
decent pasta for a fast food restaurant
they have a Cheesy Comfort veg pasta and
a Cheesy Comfort chicken pasta It's too
gooey we have the spiced tomato twist
veg pasta and the spice tomato twist
non-veg pasta if you come to Pizza Hut
to order pasta
I hope we never cross paths you have no
idea we absolutely love our carbs in
this country and as you can see we have
bowls and bowls of carbs that we call
Pasta you can get four exclusive oven
baked pastas add pot pasta Hut at Pizza
Hut
I'm not eating any of these they all
taste terrible all right the end you can
get a oven-baked chicken alfredo don't
get this or if you don't like chicken
you can just get
cheesy Alfredo and then of course we
have the Italian Meats pasta which is
pepperoni and Italian sausage I mean oh
oh Italy oh Italy
I'm so sorry and lastly the oven baked
veggie pasta I mean this this is this is
a doorstop
I I can't stand the Pizza Hut pasta I
cannot stand it you see the sauces you
know what time it is
exhaust talk starting down here get
yourself blue cheese sauce then get
Ranch oh a garlic sauce we can have a
honey barbecue sauce a medium buffalo
sauce and a side of marinara just for a
dip in your breadsticks and also the
icing the Cinnabon icing for the
Cinnabons and there's a note that says I
really want to see Joe dipping some
pizza in the frosting and eat it
ah
give me this
oh
excellent at first I was like yuck but
this is kind of good and now on to dips
your dips
first off we have tomato ketchup
then we have a mayonnaise fun fact it's
veg mayonnaise doesn't have any egg
because a huge population of this
country is pure vegetarians which means
that they don't eat anything from an
animal
even egg then we have a cheese dip and
finally it's a Schezwan sauce and if so
they serve it with the Momos they serve
it with a bunch of other things
yeah we got the search you're not gonna
find in India that includes down here
the cinnamon sticks they're like
breadsticks only cinnamony
get your mind out of the gutter and
moving on we have here are the Cinnabon
mini cinnamon rolls this is the triple
chocolate brownie if I had to guess
two pounds what do you got here the
ultimate chocolate chip cookie
right
this is like a frisbee
and for all you Sweetie Pies out there
with sweet tooths here are India's
exclusive desserts starting with a Choco
lava cake baby
[Music]
molten the chocolate cake in Domino's
much better next up you get a whole
range of ice cream some quality walls
one of India's biggest ice cream
manufacturers you can get a tiny tub of
chocolate Supreme sundae then you can
get a Cornetto a cone super delicious
and I really love the end of this
because it's just a block of chocolate
and I used to fight over this with my
friends then you get a magnum everybody
loves a magnum and finally you can even
get a family pack of ice cream
soda last exclusive are of course the
drinks both countries have Pepsi but the
pizza in the US you can also get Wild
Cherry Pepsi Orange Crush
Mountain Dew baby Sierra Mist which they
didn't have and Aquafina here in Pizza
Hut India are exclusive drink options
are Pepsi 7Up mirinda and Pepsi black
they also serve an iced tea at the
restaurant but they don't deliver it
unfortunately I would have gone for the
iced tea
[Music]
all right now let's take a look at Pizza
Hut's pricing particularly some clever
marketing tricks they're using to make
you believe you're getting more value
for money than you actually are in the
US a medium cheese pizza and the pan
crust will cost you
13.49 in India a medium Margarita Pizza
will cost you 319 rupees which is
currently 3.93 US dollars that means
over here you are paying 11.9 cents per
square inch of pizza while over here in
India you're just paying 4.4 cents per
square inch of pizza that makes the U.S
pizza 170 more expensive generally with
pizza the more you buy the cheaper cats
a US large has a surface area of
153.9 square engines and costs
15.49 that brings the cost per square
inch down to 10 cents making it 15
cheaper than the medium ladies and
gentlemen it's time for pizza pop quiz
which has the higher surface area why 1
medium pizza or two personal pizzas if
you said two personal pizzas
congratulations you're an idiot because
when it comes to calculating the surface
area of a circle small changes in
diameter can create huge differences in
surface area on the Pizza Hut India
website you can get a combo offer of two
personal pan pizzas for rupees 279
however a medium Pizza costs pretty much
the same but I guess if you want two
different flavors of pizza it makes
sense to go with the combo
and this medium cheese pan crust pizza
it is 1940 calories 79 grams of total
fat 33 grams of saturated fat 224 grams
of carbs and the sodium oh boy
3480 milligrams a medium Margarita Pizza
in India will cost you 1 377 calories
total fat 40.29 grams of which saturates
are 14.7 grams carbohydrates 192 grams
and
2717 milligrams of sodium yikes now the
American stats look a lot worse but I do
want to point out that our medium is
much larger than India's so if you break
it down per square inch you'll see that
the US version does have more fat and
more saturated fat but India's Pizza
actually contains more calories carbs
and sodium but what about the most
calorific item on the Indian menu if you
really want to mess up your day you have
to order the medium wedge surprise Kebab
pizza with wedge Kebab stuffed crust a
whole one of these pizzas will contain
2673 calories that's
133.65 of your daily caloric intake
allowance oh my God okay the calories
are high but the sodium is even higher
that is
6344 milligrams of sodium in here which
is 275 percent of your daily recommended
allowance what about the most calorific
Pizza in the US well that would be a
large pan crusted meat lovers which this
isn't so imagine it bigger and thicker
okay an entire one of these contains a
whopping
3570 calories it's 178 your daily
allowance and the sodium is even worse
than that of India's There's 7 150
milligrams of sodium in here that is
298 your daily recommended amount from
Calico to portion sizes we wanted to
find out all the differences between
Dunkin Donuts in India and in the US
this is food Wars
[Music]
here in the US you can get your Donuts
in one six or a half dozen or twelve AKA
a dozen don't put that in there
here in India you can get your Donuts in
packs of one
three or six one U.S sticky glazed
donuts Indian glazed donut it weighs
49 grams 59 grams in the U.S we have
four sizes of hot coffee the small
the medium the large which Unfortunately
they forgot Duncan
and the extra large here in India our
filter coffee comes in one size this one
if you're wondering what filter coffee
is it's one of the most popular drinks
here in India it's made by taking a
decoction of coffee mixing it with
sweetened milk and typically when
they're preparing it they pour it from a
huge height to create this froth it's
super delicious and it's very strong
it'll wake you right up in the morning
as for our other drinks they come in two
sizes either medium or large this is an
Americano let's wait to see how much we
got
I might have to go to the bathroom after
this
10.14 fluid ounces
if that's not enough for you Duncan's in
the US also has a box of joe which
contains a hundred ounces of hot coffee
and
oh yeah
this should be the extra large in the US
we only have three iced coffee sizes the
small the medium and the large no extra
large but they did remember the large
iced coffee so thanks Duncans so the
Duncan India website says that they
serve an iced Americano but we asked
three Outlets here in Bengaluru and they
said no ice America no we even asked
them hey can you put some ice in our
Americano they said no so if you really
must have an Americano that's iced from
Dunkin you have to take your own ice and
go there
so what what what's the large spot it's
supposed to be 32 I mean I think it's
yeah the cup says 32 supposed to be 32.
Yulie zoom in on that and shame this
business
[Music]
this is everything that you'll find on
the menu at Dunkin Donuts India that you
will not find in the US here is
everything you can get in a U.S Dunkin
Donuts you can't get in India let's
start off with this one it is called
charcoal Villa and I think it's called
that because it's a little triangle of
chocolate which looks like those houses
we used to draw as kids
oh my God yum it's filled with my
favorite donut filling ever which is
Bavarian cream choco almond
hmm
it's okay it's filled with the Bavarian
cream again
with the cream
unreal on to the next one this is called
a chocoholic it's got a piece of KitKat
sticking through it I want to see if
it's one kicker bar if they've taken two
and they've sandwiched them together
let's pull from this end yeah I was
right
if you're a chocoholic this is the one
for you the inside is also got
chocolatey filling in there
chocolate is starting to hit me real
hard right now
this stuff is so sweet this is called
rainbow crunch
oh there's strawberry frosting on top so
this has a strawberry taste it's okay
it's a donut next up we have cookie
Delight it's called cookie Delight
because they've taken cookie pot and
smacked it on top this one's called
crispy crunch for people who have
Trypophobia this one is probably not for
you
oh my God they're saying it the crispy
stuff on top is just not working again
however they do have the Bavarian cream
inside
I feel like there's a hurricane inside
my body right now next up we have a
donut called
the Jenny my fellow Indians will
recognize that there are gems on top
this is one of the most nostalgic
chocolates here in India and I've eaten
them since I was a kid
super yum
you'd think a kid would like them but I
can't even imagine a kid version of
myself liking something that's so
overdosed with sweetness and chocolates
is it Jimmy yes two Gemmy also yes I'd
avoid so I thought this was all the
exclusive signatures but I've been told
that there are two more and let's start
off with this one it's called choco pop
it's got chocolate on top chocolate
sprinkles chocolate wavy lime things and
it's full of chocolate it's very sweet
[Music]
whoa
all right and on to our last donut this
one is called the choco Berry bomb
that's actually quite nice it has
definitely cut the sweetness that I've
experienced there's like some Berry Jam
inside which is kind of tart and nice
the top is milk chocolate with shavings
of white chocolate whoa yeah
it's a good donut I wouldn't order it
it's too much all of this I would not
order any of these they're too much it
exclusive Donuts you get in the U.S you
can't get in India now we're filming
this the first week of October of course
the number one flavor you get this month
is pumpkin
yeah this tastes just like pumpkin pie
also you can get yourself a glazed
blueberry donut see look at that glaze
on top Blueberry dough on the inside
also delicious love it glazed chocolate
figured this was everywhere right
so good ooh Boston cream the Ben Affleck
of donuts looks like a regular donut
doesn't it everyone in India but
the prize is cream on the inside
I know everyone likes Donuts I haven't
done it in a while but crap this is
really good one of my favorites I have
to put these double chocolate maybe my
favorite because it just did what they
had to do take a chocolate donut and put
that chocolate frosting I like right on
top of it
a double thread oh he's just so good
I am in heaven
hi strawberry
frosting with sprinkles you don't got
this this is like the Homer Simpson
donut right this is the the one that you
always see me eating oh the vanilla
cream
gotta say don't think we had this one
before
coming it's like Scarface over here I'm
just covered a little much
oh my God here's some powder right here
powdered donut India you don't know what
this is come on it's a donut number one
right
also in the U.S you can get a vanilla
frosted with sprinkles and a bear claw
which unfortunately did not have at the
time shooting this hang on
munchkins guys ain't got munchkins what
we have a variety of Munchkin flavors
but this one specifically is the pumpkin
munchkin and
mmm
tastes just like pumpkin pie fantastic
hey guys we're now on to a different
category of donuts called the all-time
favorites uh I took a quick hospital
visit and I'm completely fine now I'm
sorry about the madness from the
previous set of donuts um I'm fine now I
don't know what came over me okay so
we'll start off with uh this specimen
over here it's called the cookie
cartwheel adorable name and yes it does
look like a wheel I like how they put
the White Stripes
[Music]
yeah it's sweet next up on our list is a
donut that's not intimidating at all
it's only called death by chocolate
will this kill me probably not but will
this kill me from diabetes if I eat too
much absolutely and for that reason it's
a win in my book if you thought death by
chocolate was scary
this is alive by chocolate in terms of
visual differences I can already tell
this one has more of a cookie crumble on
top they're very similar as expected I
will say this one is feels more like it
lifts your spirits and you feel more
alive and this one will probably put you
to sleep in a coma so death and Alive it
makes sense
[Music]
whoa on to the next one we have
something called very very
strawberry vanilla frosting on top it's
got some pink streaks and it looks to be
stuffed with strawberry jam which sounds
amazing especially after all this
chocolate overdose
it's sweet
oh my God it's nice though all right
it's time for our final donut and this
one is a bit of a boss battle so this is
a donut eclair it's called The Breakup
party eclair I guess because if you go
through a breakup this is what you end
up eating
so the first few bites were quite nice
they weren't as sweet and they didn't
feel as rich
but I realized most of the chocolate is
kind of centered towards the center of
the eclair and so it's a lot more
decadent the closer you get great for
breakups great as a metaphor for what
you feel when you're going through a
breakup and as a donut itself
pretty average both hot and cold
espresso and coffee drinks in the US
have options for flavors you can add as
flavor shots which are unsweetened or
flavor swirls which are sweet and creamy
now flavors unique to the US include
shots of vanilla toasted almond
blueberry raspberry and coconut and
flavor swirls you can get French vanilla
and pumpkin so I went ahead and had each
one of those Swirls and shots added to
one coffee right here in front of me
we'll call it the food Wars drinkaroo I
don't know what it is all the flavors in
one drink the lady when I ordered it was
like really and I was like really
foreign
[Music]
oh man
it's like there's like an electric
charge to at the end I don't quite
understand
[Music]
this is poison don't get it all right
it's time for drinks let's start off
with the cold options that we have here
at Dunkin India the first one is a
classic lemonade let's go ahead and try
it it looks very clear
that's nice it's refreshing they've not
made it too sweet and I kind of like it
next up we have a virgin mojito
I don't see why somebody would go to
Dunkin Donuts get a donut and then a
virgin mojito on the side quick point to
make you can get them in a small bottle
or you can even get them in larger
options next up we have two flavors of
iced tea we have lemon and Peach I'm
gonna try the peach
if I had to pick one of these this is
the one I'd go for
exclusive hot drinks here in the US we
have these three uh the first one is
like a specific coffee blend at Duncan
called Duncan midnights
oh wow that has oh that is power that's
strong wow
it's like it's like really strong I kind
of love it moving on you give yourself a
chai latte Angel doesn't have chai
lattes what's going on guys
that's really good and of course a
matcha latte no not matcha I hate Masha
that's the green one right beverages
that taste like lawn clippings
yeah I hate it alright it's now time for
our milk based cold beverages here in
India we have a range of frappes some
ice shaken coffees let's start with the
frappes coffee
caramel and Hazelnut and they have a
seasonal flavor which is Alfonso mango
if you've not heard of the Alfonso
variety of mangoes it grows all over
here in India and it is the king of
mangoes you have to try it if you get a
chance I'm gonna start off with this one
because I love mango flavored anything
it's not bad next up we have some shaken
iced coffees in three flavors caramel
classic and hazelnut also the classic
flavored shaken iced coffee it's not as
sweet and I want to put this one on a
pedestal thank you
okay next up they also sell a ice mocha
and an iced latte it's time for the
chocolate milkshake and can I just say
looks decadent
it's quite thick
um it's kind of grainy you can taste the
graininess of the chocolate which I like
but I don't know if some some people
might not like that some people might
like really smooth chocolate milkshakes
okay so if you're traveling to India and
you must eat a Dunkin I would recommend
you have the Alphonse so mango frappe if
it's in season but I would also say
don't go to Dunkin go to any Juice Shop
you find them all across India and they
take fresh mangoes and they make you a
mango milkshake that will blow your mind
they'll put actual pieces of Alfonso
pulp in there and you'll chew on it
while you drink your milkshake God sense
so then they made these two hours ago
I'm sorry assume they don't look like
this anyway we have these cold drinks in
the US to call Refreshers they're
actually pretty good surprisingly I'm
starting down here we have the
strawberry dragon fruit I am such a
child it's spelled
[Music]
s-t-r-a-w-d-r-g-n-f-r-t and all I could
think of was Dragon farts
well that's actually pretty good Peach
Passion Fruit
frt I keep thinking part of such a child
whoa
what the hell I think all the syrup like
went to the bottom it's like way
stronger than it should be
yeah because up top is really weak
somewhere in between there's a good sip
but I didn't find it anyway all right
Peach Passion Fruit coconut
oh but this is is that cool does that
work
okay
uh no
[Music]
oh gross yeah the coconut ones are bad
keeping it up on the cool drinks you get
yourself a frozen coffee a frozen matcha
latte a frozen chocolate and of course
the culados wait frozen hot chocolate
it's not just chocolate milk
oh man that is strong that is a
milkshake yo
it's not terrible it's this the flavor
is very strong this is apparently a blue
raspberry I think they have other
flavors but
once upon a time I worked at a movie
theater yes really when we figured out a
way to get into the syrup box because
found drinks with syrup and soda water
at the same time it mixes right when you
pour it in it was like a really dark
color and we dared each other drink it I
remember it was
so powerful I thought I was going to
throw up
and I'd never experienced anything like
that powerful flavored until today
Supply surprise Dunkin Donuts also
serves chai so you have two flavors this
is ginger chai and we have eliji chai
elaichi is
cardamom ginger in Hindi is adrak and
it's just such a beautiful word to say
oh my God
woof they've gone heavy on the ginger
for sure
as advertised these do taste like
elaichi which is cardamom and ginger
yeah they don't quite have the the soul
of a chai that you get on the roadside
but I really love how Duncan has tried
to do this makes you feel a little bit
more at home so thank you Duncan
sandwiches and wraps and bagels and
breakfast stuff oh my get a good look
India we have a huge selection of
non-donary breakfast uh sandwiches
variety stuff you can get oh man I hit a
wall and I apologize
and I'm back you can get yourself maple
sugar bacon breakfast sandwich we have
these wake up wraps and wake up wraps
are I don't know really phoned in
breakfast tacos I don't know how to
describe it it's a tortilla they put the
stuff they already had for the
sandwiches in there they folded over
I'll just grab one you can get yourself
one and oh man this thing is like
hey everyone I'm watching this video in
the comments let me know I show you this
and then when I open it are you more
likely to eat this or less likely let me
know in the comments Duncan nobody wants
these you can get yourself a tomato
pesto grilled cheese Pesto's fine and
all but when something has pesto on it
you don't realize it doesn't look like
look at this green does that look like
who's you go oh it's pesto or would you
be like oh I think that's moldy you also
got the grilled cheese oh
then you get yourself the sourdough
breakfast sandwich yo these things so
solidified probably edible a few hours
ago I'll I'll take a bite of this
sausage egg and cheese
no
not bad bacon egg and Juice somewhere
encased in this melted cheese is bacon I
assure you there's also a turkey sausage
egg and cheese somewhere oh you can also
get bagels at your Dunkin Donuts why I
don't know but you can get bagels plain
cinnamon raisin multigrain sesame seed
and this one everything and get yourself
some cream cheeses including Garden
veggie strawberry and plain also you can
get an avocado spread which they did not
include
Duncan India you're not gonna believe
this our Dunkin Donuts you can get a
side of
you can get a side of something called
snack and bacon what snack and bacon you
ask it is
a bag of bacon Bagel minis you can get
plain and everything Bagels here's one
right now I think these have cream
cheese inside of them
yeah
I don't think I've ever had one of these
before
that's not a bad idea not bad guys also
in the U.S you can order hash browns now
at Dunkin Donuts apparently you get
these what do we calling these omelette
bites uh you get bacon egg and cheese or
egg white and veggie come on this is
straight taken from from Starbucks right
we went to the Dunkin India website and
over there on the menu they claimed to
sell burgers and a few sides like nachos
however we went to the outlets and the
manager said that they're phasing out
all Savory food and Duncan nationally
but he was kind enough to make us one
single non-ridge burger just so that we
get to taste what it would have been
like it has a whole chicken piece in
there which is already kind of nice some
onions looks like Tandoori mayo and the
bun looks pretty tasty
oh my God
that's actually really good I've done
many episodes of food Wars tasted many
burgers from restaurants that are
literally burger joints and this
literally Rivals those burgers this is
pretty good what's happening Duncan okay
so the fact is that Duncan has actually
scaled down massively here in India in
Bangalore where we're filming there used
to be 20 Dunkin Donut outlets now there
are only three so rumor has it that
Duncan might be phasing out of India in
general and the decision is going to be
made in the coming weeks so maybe this
video is the last remaining Legacy of
Duncan in India and this is probably the
last burger that has ever eaten oh
uterus might be the guys this might be
the last Burger ever consumed from
Dunkin Donuts here in India
okay let's talk price this large
Americano is rupees 139 which is
currently 1.71 US dollars but keep in
mind at the time that we're filming this
the Indian Rupees at an all-time low so
hopefully things will get better and
this won't cost so much that same drink
in the US is 3.69 or
293.44 rupees that's a 63.9 percent
increase in price okay so the biggest
menu item that we have here in India is
our box of six now you can get two
categories you can get Classic Donuts
which are a lot simpler and it'll cost
you rupees 399 or you can get the
favorites Donuts which we have here
which are a lot more extravagant and
will cost you rupees 499 which amounts
to USD 6.12 right now if you want 12
donuts you need to get two boxes of six
which will cost you rupees 998. for food
our biggest menu item is a dozen donuts
18.73 cents or
1492.85 rupees
thank you our biggest drink is the box
of joe Avella it's the most expensive
single menu item 27.48 or
2190.25 rupees now in India we have
something called a Vada which is pretty
much a donut but it's Savory and it's
fried and I want to say that those costs
around 20 rupees while this original
glazed that I've bitten into a few times
costs 85 rupees so it's important to
note this price difference and people
here will definitely think about that
before buying something like this
[Music]
nikhail stop eating the props
okay so Dunkin Donuts India has not
released any of the nutritional info out
for the public and they've not gotten
back to us when we asked them for
information as of now however I can
confirm that one donut is probably less
nutritious than one salad
let's talk about dunking U.S nutrition
starting with the glazed donut in the
U.S it has 360 calories 22 grams of fat
10 grams of saturated fat 420 milligrams
of sodium or 20 39 grams of carbs and 18
grams of sugar and let's compare that
donut on to this one the Boston cream in
the USA a Boston cream is 270 calories
11 grams of fat 320 milligrams of sodium
39 grams of carbs and 18 grams of sugar
a Dunkin Donuts large ice Dunkin dark
roast coffee with cream and sugar in the
U.S is 260 calories 12 grams of fat and
37 grams of carbs now assuming that the
iced coffee is the same in the U.S and
India getting a large iced coffee with
cream and sugar and both the glazed and
a Boston cream donut has 890 calories
that's 35.6 percent of your daily
calorie intake yo
again Dunkin Donuts has not released any
of their ingredients to the public
however there is one huge difference
between the U.S and Indian donuts and
that is that the Indian Donuts are all
eggless this is because a huge
percentage of Indians are vegetarian
especially Hindus and so they even
consider eating egg as non-veg food and
so yeah most fast food restaurants have
decided to not use egg in any of their
foods to make it more accessible to a
larger part of India but the US does
have it out of sight so I will share
with you the ingredients right now first
up the coffee regardless if you're
getting it hot or cold if you get a
plaque it's going to be 100 arabica
coffee nice now if you want to add cream
and sugar to it then you are adding milk
cream to sodium phosphate stabilizer
sodium citrate as a stabilizer and sugar
if you're going to be adding flavor to
your coffee drink one flavor you can get
in both India and the US is caramel and
in the US our caramel flavor is made up
of all this
in the US our standard glazed donut is
made up of all of these things
you think that's a lot here's everything
in our Boston cream donuts
yikes that's a lot of words from Candy
Corn to potion size we want to find out
all the differences between lace chips
in the US and in India this is food Wars
here are all the latest trips you will
find in India that you won't find in the
US and here are all the latest ships in
the US you can't find in India oh my
good God yeah to begin things I'm gonna
go with the one I hate the most Spanish
tomato Tango yeah I just never really
like this flavor it's just too heavy on
the Tomato side
is horrible I have nothing nice to say
about this flavor also just to note our
standard lace chips come in the ridge
style we do also sell the flat style but
that's more of a special variety of
place next it's West Indies hot and
sweet chili formally Caribbean hot and
sweet chili
so I'm talking about
get out of here and now
for the Maharaja of Indian leaves magic
Masala if you haven't heard of this you
must be living under a rock because this
is the little emperor of chips commonly
known as blue leaves
look at this chip dude
oh my God
it's already so spicy the reason this
chip has become so popular in India is
because they have actually managed to
capture the Masala of India so well and
Masala if you're wondering is like
ground up spices that are added to every
single dish we eat here this is truly
magic I want to know what they're like
Joe got himself some
oh man and the chip bags in India are
like much harder to open oh man you guys
gotta walked up tight
is it gonna rip okay yeah
oh yeah
damn isn't good
not too spicy great flavor we have so
many flavors I couldn't get them all for
the shoot I mean I'll just start right
here
barbecue this is like the classic chip I
think this is more popular than the
classic to be honest the US has I would
say at least 10 different variations of
barbecue possibly more so I have just
like standard barbecuers pretty bold
move by lays salt and vinegar
[Music]
so much
top chip top chip right here close all
mirror cheddar and sour cream
lemon another favorite oh man
it seems like
lime flavored chips would be weird or
citrusy chips but
so good and these are like really limey
all the super fans watching know I do
not like pickles
no I might kick it up a notch blaming
hot dill pickle and the flaming hot that
font that implies that's like flaming
hot Cheetos right
um better
still not that good ah last in this
group is a chili lemon
yeah
these are coming home with me other
flavors in this category that I couldn't
get the time of filming cheddar jalapeno
and Sweet Southern heat barbecue I was
totally able to buy them online I get a
thing in the mail two days ago saying
the post office is holding them Ransom
and wants five more dollars or postage
for me to pick it up not happening I
will not be intimidated by the United
States Post Office and keep the chips
all right also what I couldn't get at
the time of filming was honey barbecue
Chesapeake Bay crab spice Adobes which
is a different spicy chip which is
actually very good I was bummed that
couldn't get those and the Doritos Cool
Ranch lays unfortunately
let's now talk about two exclusive
flavors that are in both countries but
slightly different we have uh the
sizzling heart lays and the American
style cream and onion it was previously
known as American sour cream and onion
it's great no fudge one of my favorite
flavors it's been there for like over
two decades I feel in India and there's
a reason for that ours is just regular
sour cream and onion I also got America
style sour cream and onion from India
and then one after the other
the flavor on these are much stronger
and even says now with more food this is
more flavoring I gotta say I like these
India ones better up next we have
sizzling hot this is the flavor I've
actually never had I'm very excited to
see how it Stacks compared to Magic
Masala which is already pretty spicy
whoa
yo look at this chip it's literally red
oh
nice it's not as much a direct heat as
the magic Masala it's a nice flavor in
the US we have flaming hot Flavor now
let me explain this is flaming hot
kettle chips couldn't get the regular
flaming hot we'll get in the kettle
chips later it's like regular spice as a
heat Tube without being too specific I
think they use these red chilies right
here it packs a nice punch without being
too overwhelming with the flavor like
the perfect amount of heat without
getting too overwhelming okay so we
don't only have ridge style chips we
also have some flat ones in fact they're
called wafer style which I think is
pretty much your classic style of lace
the first flavor is salt with pepper not
salt and pepper don't you dare say that
it's very nice I should buy this more
often I've never tried this before very
good job okay on to the next wafer style
chip we have sun-dried chili
I love sun-dried anything beam that
Sunray on to any vegetable I will eat it
oh bam
this is really good they smashed through
this one
got a prop okay well oh
it's really yum and one of the most
beautiful sights you'll see in India is
people Sun drying their own chilies on
their roofs porches wherever biryanis
curries they all use sun-dried chili and
this chips packet really has nailed this
flavor
maybe my favorite kettle cooked we
already saw the Flamin Hot kettle cooked
these are thicker chip they transport a
lot better obviously than Esme broken
a potato taste to it potato snaps like
I love cattle chips sea salt Cracked
Pepper
yeah like
sea salt and vinegar this ain't your
pond Salt this ain't your Lake salt this
certainly is not your Fjord salt
why is salt and vinegar so good
attention everyone my favorite Kettle
chip is about to be eaten by me the
jalapeno kettle chips I'm not going to
talk about Miss Vicky's because this
isn't a Miss Vicky's video and I hate to
say it
these might be better
we've got the jalapeno flavor in there
it's not too spicy so you can really
Chow Down on these moving on
unfortunately to something that I kind
of can't stand are
baked you get them in original and you
get them a barbecue
like eating cardboard lays has something
called the better for you Series so we
have these and then lightly sell the
barbecue lightly salted wavy I mean I
want the salt but like how much
this is what paper tastes like we got
simply sea salt thick cut
and you can also get the simply barbecue
thick cut something called layers which
are these guys bite-sized layers crispy
layers tasty layers you get them in
three cheese sour cream and onion I've
never seen this before my entire life oh
the bass stinks
oh these are these are really bad these
are terrible well these are real
chemically tasting oh my God these
tastes like they were poisoned I know
for our next range of exclusive chips we
have lays Max
that's maxed with two x's why the two
x's that's like saying it's more better
I have not seen or tasted these before
starting with Macho chili flavor it is
kinda rich but I would say it's more
very
I wouldn't say super spicy I kind of
like that this one doesn't leave that
burning sensation in your throat it's
really nice
yeah I don't know about The Branding but
I really like this flavor next flavor
peppery cheddar
whoa all sorts of stuff happening here
there's like some mint to it oh you know
this tastes like this tastes like Malai
Tikka like chicken Malai Tikka dipped in
pudina Chutney this is very unique our
next flavor is
sizzling barbecue oh the reason this is
called lace Max it's because it has Max
crunch Max flavor and Max taste and I
can wholeheartedly say both of these
have delivered
it even smells strongly of barbecue so
these work they're great
more fun chip Styles I think we can call
these the India style but we also call
them the wavy style they are wavy hence
the name and you get them an original
reduced fat honey barbecue Ranch you
also get them in salt and pepper lightly
salted fat low fat if I didn't say that
already like the waves are like wider
you guys have like really like condensed
waves Blaze apparently went into answer
the age-old question how can we copy
something popular and make it much much
worse and stacks were invented you guys
know what Pringles are right of course
you do well
hear that we'll put them in a tube they
won't break as easily right
holy
look at us
so what was the point of putting in this
tube I hate this so much but to really
prove my point yo dog look what I got by
the way paper two excellent idea
Dave Pringle whatever your name is
stacks and now to our final set of
exclusives The Gourmet collection I have
had a lot of gourmet food in my life and
I've very rarely been actually impressed
with the food paprika
vintage cheese and paprika
oh
if I taste this chip without any of the
fancy packaging I don't think Gourmet is
the first word that would come to my
head Thai Sweet Chili Gourmet
this literally tastes like the West
Indies hot in Chile but on a flat chip
so Gourmet is just packaging that's what
we've learned from this experiment with
these two chips
skippable in addition to that we also
have lays poppables poppables come in
sea salt and vinegar see oh Julius
Pringle that was his name not Dave they
also have poppable sea salt and vinegar
poppable sea salt poppable white cheddar
and poppable honey barbecue okay I don't
want to eat all these what's the what's
the cereal that looks like this is it
Chex
if you got these on accident eat them
but I wouldn't I wouldn't reach for
these over regular potato chips
here in India our lace chips packets
come in five sizes there's 30 grams 50
grams 73 grams 104 grams and 174 grams
the big boy the party pack I feel like I
could eat this whole thing on my own to
be honest in the U.S our lace chips come
in six variety of sizes all the way down
here got the 28 gram bag which comes in
the multi-pack next up 74.4 Gram bag in
the middle here there's also an elusive
78 gram bag look I saw it on target.com
and walmart.com it exists it just wasn't
available anywhere in Southern
California I looked okay one step up we
have what I think is the classic
Grocery Store bag
226 gram aka the eight ounce bag you've
seen it a million times this is the one
right next to that one is the family
size bag which I also couldn't get a
hold of
297.6 gram bag I couldn't find it
because the American family is dead but
what is Alive and Well is of course our
biggest size the party size
368 grams for all you familyless
Partiers lays has you covered that means
the biggest bag in the US is this much
larger than the biggest bag in India but
wait there's more or less depending on
the packet that you get because
according to Amazon the weights of these
different packets might vary so they're
given a weight range the biggest weight
difference is in our largest pack of 174
to 190 grams which is a difference of 16
grams so let's see how much we get in
one package
175 grams one gram extra from what is
advertised which is I'll take it so let
me show you what 16 grams of chips looks
like so you can see what you're
potentially missing out on it doesn't
seem like a lot but I think that's quite
a substantial amount of chips you're
missing out on to be fair they they did
write 174 grams only on the pack in the
US our flavor bags weigh less than the
original flavor bag take this barbecue
flavored lace bag it weighs 7.75 ounces
or 7 and 3 4 ounces Yulie can we get in
there
you see that thank you compared to the
eight ounce you get with the original
bag okay same price less product now
Harry did research on that episode so
take it away Harry
what no do your own research according
to Harry's research from the last latest
episode back in 2014 PepsiCo claimed the
reason that there is a slightly higher
price per ounce for flavor chips is the
added seasoning so then
lays can you explain to me why this
lightly salted bag gives you fewer chips
in the original bag that's more money
but less salt a lays check it out the
lightly salted so less salted than this
also seven and three-fourths while we're
exposing potential lays lies this 28
gram bag in the U.S supposedly contains
15 chips according to Lay's website
let's see how accurate this is and I'm
going to go on all the tips in this 30
gram packet to see how many we have
hahaha
I mean it doesn't contain one whole chip
one
12.
13. I mean if we're doing it by chip
related piles 6 12 8 moving close to 18
chips per bag huh all right I'll concede
cool so that's 24 chips I would say
realistically this is like 20 chips that
have been broken into many other pieces
but let's be real they're gonna fit a
lot more chips into this packet and lace
is notorious for filling it with air
it's actually nitrogen gas which helps
preserve the chips and also acts as a
cushion to stop them from getting
smashed in transit I mean
what would it have been like without the
cushion this whole bag would have been
dust apparently but what is the air to
chip ratio you ask let's find out in a
new segment I like to call the our
chipmedies principle
can I just say this is one of the
weirdest things I've done in my life a
generous 55 mL of chips in this packet
now let's measure how much the packet
itself can hold in volume
oh this smells so bad
900 mL that's
845 mL of chips that we could have had
lays I feel cheated which I think to
make it more accurate let's do four and
then we'll fill this guy up and then
we'll divide by four and that would give
us the average of those that make sense
dust
all right
oh man all right can I please have the
scientific chip crunching nunchucks
throw them
whoa look out chips pow wow how
2.75 fluid ounces per bag now that's
science you can use
so now we're going to fill this with
water cool the whole thing's 20. I'm
expect 2.75
17.25 units or whatever cubic fluid
ounces even more interesting ad
information because of India's very
geography the amount of air that's
backed into these packets is different
for different altitudes for example in
cities of higher altitude like lay in
the Himalayas there is the risk of these
packets exploding
due to the low atmospheric pressure and
so when they're sent there they're sent
with no air at all inside of them and so
they run the risk of being crushed in
transport so they have to be taken as
delicately as a crate of eggs
[Music]
but what about price
this is our largest chips packet the 174
grams and on swiggy and Amazon this
sells for about 78 rupees which is about
a dollar right now and that equals
thank you
rupees 0.44 per gram about
0.005 dollars and yes I did all of that
math and conversion in my head here in
the us if we break it down starting with
this big bag the 226.8 gram AKA eight
ounce bag it's 3.99 at Target or
316.58 rupees yes it's a bigger bag I
know so breaking it down per gram we
found that in the US the cost is at 260
percent increase compared to India when
we do enjoy at least chips we also have
a giant chip culture here in uh India in
fact these are called hot chips and they
sold all across India at stalls called
Hot Chip stalls where basically they
have a giant frying pan and they cut the
potato in front of you to these thin
slices and fry it and give it to you
nice hot hot fresh fresh and so for 174
grams which is the same as this you're
paying rupees 45 for a lot fresher chips
so as you can see Lays competing against
a giant chip Market here in India and
doing pretty well I would say
[Music]
now for the burning question are there
any questionable ingredients that are in
your lace chips that you need to watch
out for fret not because Joe and I have
found them out for you as far as the
basic salted version goes you're totally
fine both in India and the US they're
made of potatoes vegetable oil salt
warning warning alert here in India some
of our flavors have an ingredient called
potassium chloride in regular doses this
is completely safe and it's a low sodium
alternative to Salt however it's also
one of the three ingredients used in the
three drug cocktail per Lethal
Injections too much potassium chloride
will cause irregular heartbeats and boom
your heart will stop so if you've been
thinking of doing a lace mukbang be
careful we don't have any of that in the
US lace but we do have food coloring
caramel color in our barbecue
and honey barbecue chips certain types
of caramel color can contain a byproduct
called four dash me uppercase i studies
found that it caused cancer in rats and
mice leading campaigns in support of
banning it from foods give me that
dancing rat
all right the FDA was like nah it's fine
humans don't come close to the level of
exposure that caused that rat tumors but
that didn't stop the state of California
adding it to its Proposition 65 list of
chemicals quote known to the states of
California to cause cancer or
reproductive toxicity end quote another
ingredient found in several varieties of
relationships here in India is disodium
glutamate AKA flavor enhancer 69 no not
69.
flavor enhances 627 but basically it's
used alongside MSG to enhance the flavor
of the chips both the Food and Drug
Administration or the FDA in the United
States and the European Food Safety
Authority or the efsa consider disodium
glutamate safe but it's not recommended
for babies children pregnant women and
lactating mothers and also should be
avoided by asthmatics or people
suffering from gout MSC if you're
wondering is the commonly misunderstood
ingredient known as monosodium glutamate
which is added to a lot of Asian Cuisine
and gives it that Umami flavor in 2019
lays sued a bunch of Indian Farmers for
growing a certain variety of potato
fc5 variety saying it has a patent on
that variety this type of potato is
ideal for snack chips as it has a lower
moisture content but strike one of the
little guy Farmer's rights activists
petition the protection of the plant
varieties and Farmers rights Authority
and it agreed PepsiCo Lays cannot claim
a patent over a seed variety it was
revoked immediately and the Indian
potato farmers are now flush with low
moisture potato money let's go
foreign
[Music]
let's compare the classics first a 28
gram bag of classic lays in the U.S
contains 160 calories uh 10 grams of
total fat 1.5 grams of saturated fat 15
grams of carbs and 170 milligrams of
sodium okay so our least nutrition is
per 100 grams so I did a little bit of
math to compare it to the US 28 grams
actually Jordan the mat so if the math
is wrong blame you okay so we have 154.8
calories total fat 9.8 grams of which
saturates are 3.7 grams carbs are 14.7
grams and sodium
142.8 milligrams wow that was pretty
close actually we're under the US in
every metric except for saturated fats
where we are over 164 and I think that's
because we use parmoline oil to fry our
chips and it's very high in saturated
fats unlike the U.S vegetable oil what
about the least healthiest chip in each
country over here there are a lot of
them that are tied to 160 calories per
28 gram bag show list but we did find
that the 160 calorie chips with the
highest fat content are these no the
cheddar and sour cream I love these guys
making them the least healthy if I did
have a bag that small it would contain
all of this
and here in India our highest calorific
chip is
classic salted how lame how is this the
most calorific chip we sell here lays if
I had to run an extra mile it wouldn't
be for classic salted so you know what
the next most calorific chip is
magic Masala baby blue lace we had to
end with this one super calorific I
don't know why I'm proud of that but uh
good great to know that this is and
forever will be the Maharaja of lays
from calorie count to portion says we
want to find out all the differences
between Taco Bell in India and the US
this is food Wars
here India our typical tacos come in
orders of one two in a two taco meal
with fries and a drink three Taco Trio
combo which comes with nachos and a
drink or on weekends they have a special
offer where you can get eight tacos in
their weekend taco party breakfast
taco
eat taco weekend party pack I have a
party with your friends only there are
eight of them and they all are okay with
having this one taco in the U.S our
standard Taco Bell tacos come in orders
of one three with a drink and the 12
Taco Box 12 tacos one box here in India
our classic burrito is six and a half
centimeters or six and a half inches our
U.S burrito is five inches across in
terms of good it's the first time I've
measured the growth of anything promise
seven inches also about five inches and
that's what matters most okay now to
measure the weight of our classic
burrito damn this is a big boy 291 grams
185 grams our classic quesadilla is just
shy of 11 inches 10 inches and as for
weight
and it weighs 174 grams 202 grams add an
Indian Taco Bell the largest item we
have on our menu is the aforementioned
weekend a taco party picnic popping
water is this thing eight Taco weekend
party pack and it's always a party
so the vegetarian version is 499 rupees
and the non-resident version is 599
rupees in the US our biggest menu item
is a supreme variety taco party pack it
is 12. supreme tacos and it runs 21.99
or
1751.65 Indian rupee
here's everything you'll find at a Taco
Bell in India that you will not find in
the US and here is everything at a U.S
Taco Bell you can't find in India let's
Taco about it here in India all of the
tacos have a vegetarian option this is
because even though India is a primarily
non-vegetarian country we have a huge
population of vegetarians or people who
have different preferences of what kind
of meat they like to eat and so it's
great for most of these fast food chains
to have a lot of veg options all of them
have the option of either pinto beans
fajita veggies or Mexican paneer and
they're also in increasing order of
spice the cheesy double decker Taco
honestly I actually really like this
Taco I know it's sacrific for some
people to eat a softer and hard shell
taco together but when you parcel this
stuff and get it delivered to you both
the tacos become soft shim
William all right the next taco I'm
gonna eat is a crunchy taco plain and
simple it's got pinto beans in it it's
unafraid of like this on a crunchy taco
after you've ordered it from a
restaurant that's far away because look
at this it's become soggy already so I'm
going to be gentle on my criticism of
this but you use soft shell tacos are
getting it huh
let's do some decent crunch to it here
in India pinto beans are what we call
rajma and they're a staple in lava rajma
so it's a perfect match to put them in a
taco next up another crunchy taco this
one is the Mexican paneer now paneer if
you're unaware is cottage cheese we make
it all over here in India we basically
take curdle milk add some sort of fruit
or vegetable acid to it like lemon juice
and you get cottage cheese which is
paneer I'm curious to know what makes
this Mexican
paneer is one of the most popular things
you'll find in India at any restaurant
this paneer tastes chalky like most
processed paneer that you'd store in a
freezer wood if you prefer your paneer
chunky you might enjoy this not so much
now on to the soft shell tacos uh this
one is Mexican paneer the same thing I
just had
this Mexican paneer is a little bit more
spicy my favorite thing about tacos is
that not every bite is uniform so you
get a lot of different textures and
flavors in each bite you take and I
guess that's proving its point over here
okay so the next one we're going to try
is a soft taco with fajita veggies
inside
I'm opting out of the fajita veggies as
a filling in general and finally we have
our last veggie option which is a veggie
Fiesta which has tater tots
win not to win if I was going to Taco
Bell I had to order a veggie Taco for
some reason my option would be a crunchy
pinto bean taco and now for our
non-esitating tacos please note that all
of the meat in our tacos is chicken and
not beef this is because we have a huge
percentage of Hindus here in India and
they do not eat beef this makes all of
our non-veg tacos exclusives because yes
in the U.S you can substitute your beef
for chicken but it's not on the official
menu all right it's a modification which
means these are more exclusives to India
okay so you have two options of filling
either Mexican chicken or grilled
chicken we're starting off with a
grilled chicken crunchy taco which has
severely disintegrated not bad this is
also kind of the test of Taco Bell's uh
structural Integrity pretty good
[Music]
that's a win for me what else do you
want Taco Bell this Taco though has seen
better times
it kind of reminds me of like a rajma
chawl when you're chewing on the Raj
myself that's how soft the chicken is
there are a lot of comparisons you can
make with Mexican and Indian food we
have something exactly like this in
India it's called chapati and it's made
out of wheat the tortillas in Mexico are
typically made with corn the one in Taco
Bell is made out of maida which is
all-purpose flour I can't speak for
Mexican Cuisine but there's definitely a
lot of Indian flavors in this
this is actually a soft grilled chicken
taco and I can wholeheartedly say worst
of the bunch don't get this one a cheese
double decker Taco with grilled chicken
again come on man I wanted the Mexican
one but the hard shell taco is
disintegrating into a soft shell tacos
there's nothing special Chicken Fiesta
taco oh my God I didn't expect that at
all
if I've been chewing for so long I'm so
tired oh damn the aftertaste of this is
really good it's not a nice spice to it
now we have a very special Taco as you
can see this one is still wrapped
because I've never seen this in my life
it's called a naked chicken taco pause
for a moment what do you think that
means oh my God ladies and gentlemen
the naked chicken taco
[Music]
genuinely feels like I just undressed
food so there's no chicken filling
inside it because the chicken is the
Taco that's right that's how far we've
come as the human race we have taken
this bird and turn it into a freaking
pancake and folded it over cheese your
scientists were too busy trying to
figure out whether they could do it they
didn't stop to think whether they should
do it
ah nice I think that might be one of the
worst things I've had on this show oh
God oh God
I'm gonna be honest it actually looks
pretty good to me that reminds me of the
KFC double down which I did actually
enjoy I try it starting off soft taco
and soft taco supreme which is beef
flimsiest thing in the world
this stuff is oh this stuff is sweating
already
so I don't know how many vegetarians are
watching now but look at what you're
missing I think I just created a few
vegetarians I mean I like how they taste
but I mean Taco Bell's got so much fun
stuff on the menu what are you doing
eating regular tacos like get out of
here it's crunchy taco which we saw
earlier
fantastic maybe a little more stuff in
it
the cream Taco it really loaded up with
the veggies India India India look at me
this is my favorite thing in the Taco
Bell menu I sing its phrases at every
Taco Bell food Wars it is the nacho
cheese Doritos Locos Tacos some genius
somewhere connected Taco Bell and
Doritos to make a hard shell taco that
is in fact a Doritos shell
mmm comes in standard and of course
Supreme
because I've been looking forward to
this all day it's burrito time baby I've
gotten a Mexican paneer version here as
well as a pinto beans version I think
I'll go with the pinto beans one by the
way this tray is all of the vegetarian
burritos and this is the non vegetarian
tray happy baby India has a lot of roll
culture we have Kati rules we have
kolkataros we also have shawarmas which
we are a huge fan of
most Indians this basically will feel
like you took rajma rice and you shoved
it inside a maida roti I think I'd go
with the taco over this next up we have
tikka masala but I found this a recently
it was actually invented by the British
so clearly inspired by India but
invented by them another thing that the
British took from us that we haven't
been paid back for
we have a flavor here it's called achary
and it's basically like a pickle this is
more archery than chicken tikka masala
also I would be lying if I didn't admit
that Taco Bell it's all it's already
doing its thing to my digestive system
Taco Bell is notorious for making you go
to the bathroom zoom in to my stomach
right now and just listen to this the
noises and let's get a translation
my God and now for Sriracha wedge
burrito is now running the risk of
offending three different cultures I
don't normally eat a burrito by ripping
it in half actually that sounds awesome
we should do that more often like a
double-handed don't clip that you can
skip it we have the seven layer burrito
this one tastes like all of these put
together and we have one last veg wrap
ah guys I can't do this it's the same
thing this is tater tots that same
feeling I bow down and defeat Taco Bell
you have vanquished me moving on to the
non vegetarian burritos and we're hoping
some of these are a little more distinct
from the others all right we have a
classic Mexican chicken burrito
oh so bad this is damn bad let's just
say I'm glad you didn't call yourself
burrito bowl next up tikka masala but
now in non-veg
[Music]
this is actually quite good this one
doesn't taste as dry as the other ones
I've had and of course we have the seven
layer non vegetarian burrito instead of
paneer we have grilled chicken let's
just do the slab test again
you could really hurt somebody with this
seven layer one okay we have one last
burrito which is why what is this this
is not why have you done this this
burrito looks like the the love child of
all other burritos over here these
burritos are definitely related and this
is the product of incest
wow it's actually not that bad honestly
out of all of these I'd prefer to finish
this one because it's just smaller the
pain will end faster burritos might not
be visually the most exciting part of
the video but please don't leave maybe
just open some clips of Family Guy next
to it so you can watch that and this
like you're on Tick Tock the double
steak grilled cheese burrito and the
spicy double steak grilled cheese
burrito and right it's grilled cheese
because they like Grill it shut with
cheese genius idea yeah look at that it
has jalapenos on it oh that's fantastic
that's a really great idea
oh yeah just rules a beefy quesarito
when these things cool off though this
is a lot of cheese in there oh and it
has a rice in it little burritos have
rice I don't know I'm so surprised by
that rice on a burrito same thing but
with black beans I mean it's already
kind of kind of like dripping out there
already grilled number one beans and
cheese in there you see that and the red
is uh those like chips if it was crispy
chips in there five layer burrito it
used to be seven layer took out two
layers and added a beefy one for some
weird reason I assure you there's five
layers in beef inside I'm not doing that
I'm not some weird fetish that on the
internet that I'm not aware of slapping
faces with burritos burrito supreme look
it's so much different from the last
thing we were just looking at but like
that one's just like
CK chipotle chicken
yeah Chipotle Nails legit an extra one
if anyone wants it go ahead and comment
below and I'll mail it to you beefy
melts beef and melted cheese I can't
believe it together at last
I mean it tastes like all the other ones
I feel like we could pair this menu down
a little bit last but not least cheesy
bean and rice now for India's
Specialties I am excited for the
diversity that's all I'll say very
representative of our country let's
start off with the chalupa The Humble
chalupa
it's nice if you guys are at home
wondering what the difference between a
normal taco and a chalupa is you should
Google it what is this I mean education
show I'm sure to eat man for my Indian
present it's kind of the difference
between a chapati and like a batura they
actually fry it a little bit
um
but that was a very horrible place to
bite because I only got chicken I have
soft spot for the chalupa and it gets my
approval we have the wet star wrap voila
so inventive let's take a burrito but
make it flat oh wow don't make me eat
this Insider please
oh I'm coming from a country where we're
used to eating something like this a
chapati with a sabzi on the side which
is like a curry which has vegetables and
fresh paneer and maybe some chicken so
to eat something like this just feels
not even supper it just feels wrong I'm
actually curious to know if any Mexicans
watching this video okay let me know in
the comments whether you feel like Taco
Bell has done Justice to representing
your cuisine in any way next up we have
a Kickstart count of Applause I'm just
gonna keep this UFO of man's worst
accomplishment over here quesadilla
fajita veg very thin curious to know how
they fit a lot of fajita veggies into it
they haven't how do people do this my
God I just realized Joe is insane how
have you eaten so much Taco Bell Joe
yeah I'm insane I lost my mind somewhere
during the Japan season oh well and it's
strange because I'm still an intern
we're doing rice bowls now yeah it looks
really good
um if it was abstract art in a museum
about 20 meters away from your eyeballs
but when you come close and then you're
faced with the proposition of eating it
ah
I can feel my body rejecting this
otherwise it's fine I mean it's it's
just very average this is a normal rice
bowl
we have the same thing another Rice Bowl
but this time it's got some grilled
chicken in there
that was really good this feels like the
safest bet ah I don't know when anything
is still so let's go through together
the first thing this is uh either a
black bean chalupa or a dirty diaper I
can't tell because it's thick and
wrinkly and just dripping with black goo
don't want that oh it's this uh yeah I
mean every time these Doritos shells
show up I'm just happy Dorito Cheesy
Gordita Crunch nacho cheese they put
every word in that
oh it's that thing but not nachos I mean
once you have the Dorito shell version
like to go back is like no way no way
I've touched the sky I can stay on the
ground no longer and then we have two
Crunchwrap Supreme options black bean
Crunchwrap Supreme and then the regular
Crunchwrap Supreme is of course filled
with beef okay it's time now for India's
sides menu starting off with Mexican
corn salad
you don't need to add so much sauce to
it I feel like this could have been a
lot simpler and people would appreciate
it more next up we have loaded fries and
loaded uh nachos so typically Taco Bell
does not serve loaded nachos and loaded
fries here in India but we found a
restaurant that was kind enough to send
it to us anyways I will say this is
probably my favorite thing about Taco
Bell in India the loaded nachos are
banging when you get them at the
restaurant
[Music]
like wet cardboard and now we have two
bath bags just kidding chicken nachos
they had chicken tacos and now there are
chicken nachos and our second doggy bag
has whoa that was alarming because what
I saw was this I did not expect this to
come out of that bag crispy chicken
slips sides baby we got them cheesy
Fiesta potatoes
there's better things to be had on the
menu if I do like those black beans
black beans and rice and you can get a
guacamole side now here are some items
that are available both in India and the
us but are still very different for
example this is India's quesadilla
grilled cheese quesadilla but as you can
see it's filled with a lot of fajita
veggies it's got like this special
creamy sauce and it's topped with a lot
of jalapenos whereas in the U.S it comes
with just cheese how boring is that
correct and this is what it looks like
incredibly boring another big difference
is here in India are nachos are all
seasons so they already have like a
masala or some sort of spice to them our
nacho chips in the US are just regular
tortilla chips with nacho cheese
in our veg options we use pinto beans or
rajma whereas in the U.S our Bean of
choice is the black bean exclusive U.S
sauces hey you know what that means
Source talk it's now time for India's
exclusive sauces we have quite the wide
range we have pool Ranch because there's
a lot of spice in a lot of these
burritos and tacos I imagine if you're
somebody who can't tolerate spice
definitely get a side of this then there
is spicy salsa I tasted it it's really
nice it's got a lot more spiced it but
also the flavor of imli which is
tamarind we use it in a lot of our
dishes especially South Indian dishes
then there's a chocolate sauce which I
imagine is for churros or some sort of
dippable dessert but if you want to dip
your quesadilla into this I'm not gonna
judge next up we have lava sauce which
doesn't really look as much like lava
but it definitely has a kick to it
chicken tikka masala sauce which looks
more like lava down on the end here we
got reduced fat sour cream who doesn't
like chips and sour cream right
could use some fat then moving on we
have a chipotle sauce Ole sauce is very
good
avocado ranch
I love it more of that please they have
a spicy ranch how spicy could it be not
very and finally the red sauce okay it
is finally dessert time I have eaten a
lot of savory food and I'm excited for
the desserts good old churros I am a big
fan of churros they send you one
chocolatey dip
I feel like you can't really go wrong
with Churros if you want to call
yourself a restaurant and next is
something I have never seen before
cinnamon twisties
I could see myself you know 3am in the
night sad vulnerable eating a whole
packet of these so that means a good
dessert Taco Bell used to sell
quesadillas filled with chocolate and
they were called choco Diaz but I guess
they've stopped that now Taco Bell is
against puns the only U.S exclusive
dessert we have are these the Cinnabon
Delights Cinnabons I'm pretty sure this
filled with some sort of like cream
cheese right
I share this cream cheese in this or
whatever they're frosting someone's got
to eat that definitely can't go to waste
eat it now
right they're fantastic all right it's
time for India's exclusive drinks what
could we do without them nothing out of
choke to death on all that burrito maida
wrap first up uh the soft drinks that we
have we sell 7Up and Miranda over here
but actually in Bangalore I've seen a
lot more variety of drinks so I think it
varies from store to store next up Taco
Bell sells juices this one was a mixed
fruit juice but I drank it all and I can
tell you it was pretty good they also
sell a cranberry and apple juice but the
stores that we asked in Mumbai did not
have those available and finally they
sell milkshakes this is mango this is
chocolate cookie crumble the true test
of a milkshake is to test the fruit one
and see if it's still fresh
hey that's pretty good mango milkshake
U.S exclusive drinks there's literally a
million yes really of soft drinks you
can get a Taco Bell you can't get in
India so I just went and got a Diet
Pepsi and of course
Baja Blast after like doing this what
three four times at this point I'm
actually starting to like a blast you
think I should get a whole bunch of soft
drinks at the US Taco Bell all of these
I wasn't getting 20 drinks you know so
get yourself a bottle OJ Tropicana also
something you can get are things called
freezes which at one point were frozen
slushy or slurpy like drinks you can get
of course a Mountain Dew Baja Blast and
also get yourself Wild Cherry fruits
that's cough syrup
also you can get coffee both iced and
hot
iced coffee
oh no wait that's soda what is this
ignore that over there
gave us two of these iced coffee that's
flavored like the Cinnabon Delights are
you kidding me I can just feel my life
expectancy just getting closer and
closer just like except
he ain't seen his 80s
but it's worth that's delicious you can
also get those coffees Hot Taco Bell
breakfast baby
I think this is just about everything
once again I can't tell what anything is
it's all just a sea of beige let's find
out together this one just says bacon
thank you for that burrito with bacon
I'm like the Riddler over here it's just
like Yay figured out question mark
question mark I mean it's a bit
unnatural how yellow that is it's really
bright it's a bit concerning this one's
gonna be the one with steak I assume
who's hungry
stick's a little weird maybe I don't get
the steak one specifically I'll just see
this just a condensation how bad this
food is sweating Breakfast Crunchwrap
Supreme oh there's sausage inside of
this what comes inside like the magic
ticket now I get to work at Taco Bell or
something their sausage is good though
get yourself a hash brown They also have
breakfast salsa with the Taco Bell I
went to did not have any
favorite topic that's why you come to
food was because you love fast food but
mainly you love nutrition in India a
typical soft shell Mexican chicken taco
will be 185 calories in the US our
standard chicken soft taco is 160
calories so we have fewer calories fat
carbs and sodium but more protein next
up is a chicken quesadilla ours has
268.5 calories and ours is 510 calories
now please note the sodium level on our
quesadilla it's over half the daily
recommended amount that's a salty
quesadilla in India a vegetar app is
239.9 calories closest way after that is
our black bean Crunchwrap Supreme again
double the calorie count get a load of
that sodium
looking for the most
will cost you 480.9 calories here in the
US if you're having a hard time finding
calories at a Taco Bell check out this
the double beef grilled cheese burrito
so Taco Bell in India does not disclose
any other ingredients but I thought it
would be interesting to talk about two
of the ingredients that we have here
that are unique to India number one is
paneer so the problem with the Mexican
paneer that was served to me in this
batch of Taco Bell is that it tasted
like the processed paneer you get at
stores it tasted like something had been
stored in the fridge also because paneer
is so popular here in India every single
fast food restaurant has paneer options
you know when you know how well it can
be done I didn't like the paneer that
much in the burritos and tacos I had
today the next ingredient I want to talk
about is Tikka Masala I thought it was
okay it had a lot of flavor it was quite
spicy but the thing that makes tikka
masala so exciting is that it's always
made from fresh tomatoes and so you can
sort of tell there's a difference when
it's in the sauce form however I will
say it's always a valiant effort to see
these fast food companies and people who
come here from abroad in general adapt
to the Indian palette and try to make
Cuisine that matches ours in the US we
do disclose our ingredients and here's a
few you should be wary of first is
brominated vegetable oil AKA BVO BVO is
an emulsifier found in Citrus flavored
sodas that specifically use citrus oils
and is considered a health risk when
ingested in large amounts in one case a
man who drank two to four liters of BVO
soda per day developed bromism and
experienced symptoms such as memory loss
and extreme muscle fatigue it can be
found in the ingredients of three of the
Cantina menu freezes the beach Berry
freeze the ginger mule freeze and the
party punch freeze the last one the
party punch freeze also contains yellow
number five AKA tired
which is subject to restriction outside
the U.S in places like the EU and India
as it quote may have a diverse effect on
activity and attention in children and
you can find it in several Taco Bell
menu items specifically to Doritos Locos
Taco nacho cheese shells oh no I had
like three of those today and Baja Blast
I just want to
says we're going to find out all the
differences between Cadbury chocolates
in the UK and in India this is food Wars
Cadbury dairy milk in India comes in
ranges of four sizes number one is
Cadbury dairy milk minis it comes in
this large packet with 18 smaller pieces
of 7 grams each a smallest of these bite
size 11 gram bars then we have these 18
gram little bars a simple 24 grams tiny
one next up we have our multi-pack bars
which weigh 33.5 grams the standard
individual Dairy Milk Bar weighs 45
grams your Duo bar which comes in two
halves and weighs 54.4 grams then a 55
grams Maha pack next up we have this 110
gram bar family pack 126 grams then we
move to a 180 gram bar we have this 360
gram bar
the biggest size you'll find in the UK
is an 850 gram giant bar
so in India Canada is really well known
for its gift boxes in fact they've done
so much marketing over so many years
that it's become synonymous with
festivals like Diwali dasera and even
Christmas and New Year's on their
website right now you can get anything
from an anniversary 10 box to a Ramadan
tin box and they come in several
different sizes for starters there's a
standard personalized gift box which
contains six Cadbury dairy milk bars
three of which are silk and three of
which are standard and that's the one we
have right here in fact they've put my
face on it I mean that's a whole lot of
packaging for normal bars of chocolate
you can just buy I guess it even says
food was oh it says US versus India
sorry Harry apart from this you can also
get a larger personalized birthday gift
box which will contain 450 grams silk
bars three birthday whistles a large
Banner a birthday hat so the next time
you don't know what to do for your
birthday just order this to your house
and you can have a party by yourself now
we have some gift box items of our own
but they usually come more in the form
of selection boxes these are most
commonly seen around Christmas time at
which point cadburys will release Heroes
and Roses which are selection boxes
containing 600 grams of individually
wrapped chocolates it's a real tradition
in British households to have a few of
these lying around the other options
include quality Street and celebrations
people tend to have their own favorites
when it comes to the selection boxes and
also the chocolates inside them I think
generally Heroes would be my preferred
option over roses I prefer the kind of
more mainstream chocolate bars that
you'll find including little whisper
bites which I think might be my favorite
if you want a gift option for all year
round up for a milk tray these have been
around for decades I think my mum used
to be giving these to people when she
was growing up and for the run-up to
Christmas you've got to get yourself an
advent calendar I don't think I'd
normally go for one of these these are a
little bit flimsy quite narrow but still
you get a lot of Joy from opening a tiny
bite of chocolate every morning and then
run up to Christmas
Cadbury products that you'll find in
India that you will not find in the UK
here are all the Cadbury products from
the UK that you won't find in India this
is so much chocolate in terms of our
classic dairy milk flavors we have two
exclusives number one roast almond and
number two crackle this used to be my
favorite as a child but right now I
really like this delicious chunks of
roast almond we have some exclusive
dairy milk flavors of our own firstly
for the health conscious among us we
have this 30 less sugar dairy milk I
guess this could be helpful as well if
you find regular milk chocolate too
sweet which some people do but then I
guess just opt for some dark chocolate
instead next up we have Cadbury caramel
it's a bar of dairy milk but inside each
square there's a little bit of caramel
this is one of my favorite ones it does
get a little bit sickly if you eat too
much of it because of the amount of
sugar but very tasty we have some big
taste bars which are chunky versions of
dairy milk starting with peanut caramel
crisp and we also have a triple chopped
sensation big Taste Bar which combines
dark milk and white chocolate in one
delicious bar these ones look really
cool they've definitely put a bit more
thought into the design of the bars
tastes really good so
next up we've got dairy milk with
crunchy bits now this is crunchy with an
ie not crunchy with a Y crunchy with an
ie is actually a bar of chalk that you
can get here in the UK it's milk
chocolate with a honeycomb Center then
we have a Dairy Milk dime bar
time is another chocolate bar which
dairy milk has kind of collabed with I
think it's like a very thin brittle
almond caramel bar with a little bit of
chocolate on the outside my granddad
released the light dime then we have
this marvelous Creations jelly popping
candy bar as the name suggests it's a
bar of chocolate which contains some
popping candy as well as I think jelly
beans I've not tried this in a long time
I want to see what the ratios are like
and also if I can really feel the
popping candy you can see like a couple
of bits of I assume jelly beans peeking
out the top the pattern is kind of odd
usually obviously you have squares makes
it nice and easy to break apart and
share I'm just going to bite into it
like a madman
you really do get the popping candy my
mouth is popping
but it's actually not too bad you get
little chewy Sweet bits in with your
chocolate there's a lot going on but I
don't hate it for vegans in the UK
Cadbury's also has a plant-based bar
I've never tried this so I want to see
if I can taste the difference between
this and dairy milk
really looks like chocolate
definitely does Taste of almond which is
okay because I quite like kind of nut
and chocolate as a combination if I went
vegan I don't know if I'd be rushing to
the store to buy this it's okay the
texture is pretty good but the flavor
just really isn't there our last two
exclusive dairy milk bars are actually a
mystery two bars which contain fillings
of a mystery flavor you try and guess
what the flavor is and then you can
submit your answer online myself and the
rest of the crew have now got to try
these and give our best guesses mystery
bar one oh gosh last time I threw stuff
at you it didn't go very well
got it oh okay it's fruity currently
we're thinking maybe Rose I'm personally
thinking apricot struggling to agree
here we can't taste more
fruit while we figure that one out we'll
try Mystery by number two now this one
smells aggressively fruity catch Leon
I'm getting quite a lot of like very
artificial raspberry flavor I'd be
fairly confident in a certain amount of
raspberry it might be blueberry plot
twist they've already revealed the
flavors we didn't know first one was
rhubarb and custard classic British
dessert didn't really get very close to
that one second was blue raspberry which
we actually did kind of get I personally
don't think I would buy either of those
again though maybe the first one you
don't mind it and now for our silk range
or as Cadbury's trying to rebranded the
S range what is this some sort of new
iPhone but whether you call it silk or S
I love these chocolates first off we
have the typical silk it basically it's
just dairy milk but a lot of silkier
then we have dairy milk silk bubbly it's
dairy milk silk but bubbly yes nice
light Airy next you have a Dairy Milk
silk fruit and nut then we have dairy
milk silk hazelnut wow there are some
proper large chunks of hazelnut the
hazelnut itself the flavor of it really
lends to the chocolate and it doesn't
taste as sweet next up we have dairy
milk silk roast installment we have
dairy milk silk moose they've tried to
recreate the flavor of mousse and you
can see that it's a lot more fudgy the
chocolate inside it's all right
oh man there's one that I'm scared to
try dairy milk silk bubbly bubble gum oh
no I saw the color of it oh my God why
have they done this growing up we had a
bubble gum called Boomer which is now
what we have all become that one bite
was really not that bad it definitely
tastes like bubble gum and gave me that
Boomer Vibe that's as much as I can have
of that now to cleanse the palette silk
Oreo um
that is a nice flavor dude I think is my
favorite out of the lot we also have
another variation of Oreo it's a red
velvet Oreo if you've watched previous
episodes of food wash you remember that
one of the ingredients that is taken
India by storm in the past few decades
is red velvet and I have tasted this
before and I actually think it's really
good but it is overkill it's literally
dairy milk silk the Oreo white cream and
chunks of Oreo that have been turned
into red velvet
do you have a treadmill finally we have
dairy milk silk heart blush I imagine
you give this to your loved one it says
pull over here and I'm pretty excited
for this
Never Gonna Give You Up Never Gonna Let
You Down I can't believe I've been
rickrolled in my own video at the back
there is a very elaborate looking tear
tab so I'm just gonna ah
not very easy to wait what
I'd probably break up with whoever gave
me this at this point this is
frustrating it's more practicing all
right
more packaging this is honestly a very
wasteful way to tell somebody you like
them there you go it's some pink
chocolate oh my God I swear to God if
it's the same as the bubble gum I'm
gonna cry
it's not bubblegum so
this is actually quite a fun experience
I'm not gonna like
yeah we don't have silk bars but we do
have something called Dark milk
Cadbury's has kind of invented this
hybrid milk and dark chocolate for
someone whose tastes like somewhere
between those two there is the dark milk
dark milk also comes in variations
including a salted caramel flavor and a
hazelnut flavor I feel like they've
tried to Market these a little bit more
at adults maybe as opposed to kids the
packaging kind of gives a slightly more
sophisticated vibe sexy if you will at
the other end of the scale we have some
even sweeter options than classic milk
chocolate firstly we have Cara milk
which is golden caramel chocolate this
one I have not tried I'm kind of
intrigued I'm gonna have a bite I worry
it's going to be far too sweet
well that's very sweet you do get notes
of caramel but I really don't think I
could eat more than a couple of bites of
that and of course we also just have
white chocolate as I've said I'm not
really a big fan of white chocolate and
I don't think I'm alone in that because
this basically wasn't available in any
of the big supermarkets that I looked in
the shop we were able to track it down
in was poundland which is a shop in the
UK where everything costs a pound I know
it sounds ridiculous to an American
audience but that is what it's called
you can find Cadbury boneville dark
chocolate in both the UK and in India
slight difference in the UK the
packaging is bright red and over here we
have different flavors 50 dark chocolate
and 70 dark chocolate I have uh over the
years grown to like dark chocolate I was
never a fan of it growing up but 70 dark
chocolate I don't know oh
you know it's not as bitter as I
expected very creamy also the cocoa is
100 sustainably sourced next up we have
a fruit and nut it's got a peanut in
there
it doesn't taste as heavy as the other
chocolates I've had so far and I really
appreciate this am I growing old is that
what's happening and the final flavor is
cranberry which have been the most
excited about I don't think I've had any
chocolate bars that have had cranberry
in them but obviously cranberry and dark
chocolate sounds like an amazing
combination that is so good the tartness
of the cranberry and like the slight
sugeriness really complements the dark
chocolate it's a crunch of roasted
almond it's a winner real nice I like
this range of bone Wheels feels like a
healthier guilty pleasure we also have
some boneville products you'll find in
the UK that you won't find in India
firstly we have Bonville old Jamaica the
old Jamaica refers to rum and raisin
flavors added to the dark chocolate and
we also have an orange bournville I
personally don't love dark chocolate and
I especially do not love dark chocolate
combined with fruit so I'm respectfully
not going to try any of these if you're
wondering where the name bourneville
comes from it's actually a village that
was created by the Cadbury family for
workers who worked in the factory near
Birmingham Bond will still exist today
so you can go and visit it it's home to
Cadbury World which is a kind of Cadbury
Museum interactive experience thing and
apparently it's a really nice place to
live and now it's time for all of the
remaining Indian Cadbury products
starting with Cadbury
fuse
their tagline for this is a delicious
chocolatey Feast like some sort of
chocolatey mousse in the middle
surrounded by caramel and then the outer
layer of chocolate has peanuts in it so
I can imagine this being a proper Feast
kind of nice I think I could eat this
much of one chocolate but the fact that
I'm eating so many varieties of
chocolate one after the other is really
doing something to my brain like why are
we doing this no like what is this why
are we tasting all of this what is the
point of this show next in line we have
the Cadbury
crispello I want to be on the team that
gets to name all of these chocolates
seems like you can just get away with
anything it's clearly filled with some
rice krispies and things that are
Crispies hey this one is actually really
um next up
Cadbury 5 Star 3D if you don't know what
5 star is it's basically the chocolate
that made caramel cool in India it's
been around for decades and actually fun
fact it's my mom's favorite chocolate
now they've upgraded to Five Star 3D
what's the difference between this and
any other five star it has nuts I will
say having eaten the past three
chocolates in a row I'm starting to
realize they're kind of the same thing
it's decent I prefer the original five
star that one Sparks Nostalgia this one
just feels too modern next up we have a
perk so perk is another chocolate that's
been around in India for ages now and
it's gone through a lot of Evolutions
like every other chocolate has now they
sell pork in a double pack it says you
can rip it share it
oh
next up some gemstones that's right the
UK didn't give us our gemstones back but
they definitely gave us gems
yeah I mean fair enough sorry guys so
they're M M's without the m m branding
on top what I used to as a kid you'd get
a small packet of gems and I would suck
on each gym until the color would come
off and it would be a white gem then I'd
put all the white ones in my mouth and
bite them like one big chocolate that
was weird and I had no friends Cadbury
Temptations rum and raise rum and uh
Cadbury Cadbury
Cadbury Temptations almond treat it
smells like rum
whoa I did not expect that flavor to be
so strong can they sell this to Children
it kind of tastes like a Christmas rum
cake yeah I don't mind it I think this
could be a great Christmas
sort of chocolate to have around next up
is my favorite childhood chocolate
nutties I freaking love nutties and my
favorite part about nutties is that The
Branding has not really changed for like
decades now what this chocolate is is
basically Cadbury chocolate coated over
a cashew nut that's covered in nubit
oh my God that is so good then we have a
load more Cadbury exclusives in the UK
and we'll start with the bars we'll
start with what is technically a Cadbury
product but initially was not this is
the fries chocolate cream bar it's a
dark chocolate bar with a creamy smooth
fondant Center a fun fact is that the
fries were a Quaker family who were the
first ones to actually commercially
produce chocolate bars in the UK before
the fries came along drinking chocolate
was kind of the only way to consume it
fries also makes a peppermint cream bar
as well as Turkish delight I will say
this is not the best Turkish to lay out
there if you want Turkish delight go to
a grocery store that sells Turkish food
get some classic stuff whereas this is a
kind of slightly cheapy Turkish delight
encased in chocolate next up we have
Boost bars these are chocolate bars
filled with caramel and biscuit pieces
when boost was first launched I think
they were kind of marketed as almost
like an energy bar they had loads of
sugar and glucose in them although I
think they have now recently dropped
that down and it's just in line more
with a standard chocolate bar then we're
on two Chomps I personally love a Chomp
these were also a little bit hard to
find I think we have to go to poundland
for these ones as well but they used to
cost like 10p from your local news
agents it's just like a chocolate bar
with toffee caramel inside simple but
effective then we have crunchy bars
which are chocolate bars with a large
honeycomb Center personally don't love
crunchy bars I don't love the texture of
the honeycomb and they're very very
sweet what I do love however is a curly
whirly these are brilliantly named they
come in these little individual bars
like this they look a bit weird it's
kind of a web of chocolate and caramel
I used to have braces as a kid and I
really missed toffee and caramel while I
had them on moving on we have a double
decker bar a nod to the British double
decker buses this is a two layered
chocolate bar with a nougal layer as
well as a kind of crunchy pieces and
caramel layer I like these next up we
have fudge bars we've got these little
bite-sized ones today I like these the
guys seem to disagree with me but I
think these are good I will opt for
these in a Heroes box it's just about a
fudge covered with chocolate then we
move on to the picnic bar it's a
chocolate bar that contains I think
caramel some rice crispy kind of pieces
as well as some raisins and peanuts now
while India has a Five Star Bar in the
UK we just have a Star Bar I don't think
I've ever had one of these before
apparently it's milk chocolate with
caramel and peanut let's give it a try
that might get added to my rotation you
know that's pretty good next up we have
the twirl these are like ribboned
chocolate bars which are then kind of
cased within more chocolate it leads to
quite an interesting texture and quite a
nice taste the only issue with Twirls is
that they do crumble and kind of go
everywhere you can also get 12s in
orange flavor then we're on to whisper
bars I don't really know how they make
these because it's milk chocolate but
it's like aerated there's kind of little
holes all the way through it we put a
man on the moon and we aerated a
chocolate bar the result is a really
nice texture actually it sort of melts
in your mouth when you eat it I have
some American colleagues in the US last
time I visited this was the one thing
they asked me to bring over you can also
get whisper gold bars these are the same
as regular Whispers but they have a
layer of caramel running along the top
and the last but by no means this bar is
the Fredo it's basically just a tiny
piece of solid milk chocolate in the
shape of Fredo the Frog but for people
of a certain generation namely mine
they're also a surprising representation
of economic inflation to put on my angry
old man hat for a second when I was a
youngin these were 10p and then around
2005 prices started to gradually creep
up before we knew it prices were as high
as 30p for alfredo these outrageous
prices actually led to public outcry so
much so that they back down and I think
nowadays they're around 25 people the
bank of England says that it should have
been around 17 or 18p by now whereas we
are getting charged 25 so cadburys give
us some cheap photos again economic run
is now over you can also get photos in a
caramel flavor the last thing to add to
the chocolate bars is that you can get
pretty much all of them in the form of
these share bags they basically just
condense them into bite-sized pieces and
put them in a bag that you can open and
reseal next up we have dairy milk bites
there are two flavors that we have right
now Hazelnut and almond they look pretty
similar to the silk of these flavors so
I imagine these are just smaller
bite-sized versions next up lickables
why have they done this thoughts on this
this is clearly for small children
somebody want to help me I have no idea
how to open this this feels like one of
those uh puzzles
oh
the lower half of it was the chocolate
and the rest of it had this toy now to
the chocolate this is a QR code because
most children have phones that they can
scan this with oh looks like goopy
Cadbury chocolate with chunks of Oreo
and you just gotta
lick it
this is this weird Cadbury okay next up
we have Cadbury chocolate bakes chalk
filled cookies in case you didn't think
this contained chocolate they reminded
you eight times in The Branding the
packaging and the design feels a lot
more premium feel like there's a good
value for money here because it was
filled to the literal brim now we're
gonna go to this side we have Oreo
dipped in Cadbury damn I'm really
enjoying this whole Oreo Cadbury
marriage over here now we have an Oreo
biscuit coated in Cadbury chocolate the
Oreo biscuits are kind of overpowering
so it's all right next up we have this
tin can of Rich dry fruits again in the
Cadbury celebrations line in India
common gifting cultures to give a box of
dry fruits and nuts and so Cadbury is
adapted really well to that okay so the
next thing is something very different
this is actually born Vita or Cadbury
bournvita and this is a drinking
chocolate we drink a lot of milk here in
India and as kids everybody who's
addicted to one of many different
drinking chocolates horlicks comp plan
I'm a Milo guy myself there was boost
and then obviously born Vita I think
most people were not born Vita people
this is Cadbury's range of
choco melts and it's a small dish of
chocolate that's used for baking and
finally the last three packets are
toffees that Cadbury sells in bulk this
one is five star bites it's similar to
the dairy milk minis from Indian fans of
five star out there comment and let me
know whether you're more of a rummies
guy or a Suresh guy these are packs of
toffees eclairs to be specific this one
is chocolate flavored and this one is
coffee flavor another quirky thing about
India is sometimes when you go to the
local stores and you pay in cash and
they have to give you change but they
don't have any they'll just give you one
of these chocolates and you can't really
argue it you just grab it and go I think
it's very cute actually it's a very
endearing thing about India but remember
if you're gonna take a chocolate from a
store screw all this take Melody Melody
is the best chocolate all right in the
UK capris offers a lot of seasonal
products now we're recording this
episode in late October so unfortunately
we can't get some of the most famous
ones what I'm of course referring to
here are Cadbury Creme eggs and Cadbury
Mini Eggs in the UK these are only
available in the run-up to the east
holidays but while they are available
they're wildly popular although I will
say I don't like cream eggs I take stick
for this I think they're gross the
fondant in the middle is grim you have
to kind of like tongue it out it's just
really bizarre many eggs however are
delicious I don't know what they're
putting in the shells of those things
but God they're amazing well we can't
get the Easter exclusives right now what
we do have are Halloween and Christmas
options for Halloween I was able to find
these goo heads I think these are kind
of a Halloween version of cream eggs so
I'm going to crack One open and see that
does look exactly the same as a Cream
Egg even down to the patterning that's
kind of printed on the egg I mean yeah
that's pretty much just a Cream Egg
I just don't like them then for
Christmas exclusives I found these
Cadbury puds these are dairy milk
chocolate balls where the Truffle Center
hazelnut pieces and rice crisps they
sound pretty good we also found Cadbury
Mini snowballs which are milk chocolate
and a crisp sugar shell they might hurt
a little bit more than a normal snowball
fight if you have one of these thrown at
your head and of course you can get a
Dairy Milk Advent calendar for Christmas
it looks like some kind of mud monster
moving away from seasonal items we have
Cadbury eclairs Cadbury eclairs are
quite tough pieces of toffee with some
chocolate in the center they're a pretty
good jaw workout but I do quite like
these and another iconic Cadbury item is
buttons these are bags of discs of dairy
milk chocolate real classic these have
been around for years from there we're
moving on to Cadbury's biscuit options
possibly the most iconic of which are
fingers these are thin sticks of sweet
biscuit covered in dairy milk chocolate
they're very tasty they're pretty
Moorish and they come in these kind of
iconic sleeve tray things
I know with Joe we have a caffeine meter
but if I had a sugar meter
we're blasting off right now we also
have some other flavor options including
mint orange bornville dark and finally
white roundies are circular layered
wafer biscuits covered in dairy milk
chocolate if you're a fan of Wafers you
can also get time out wafer bars again
it's Chocolate Wafers layered and
surrounded by chocolate but this time in
more of a bar form than a circular
Biscuit the next Cadbury biscuits option
is animals Fredo has hopped into the
jungle to join his friends he's a little
animal shaped biscuits which on one side
are covered with chocolate I don't think
I've eaten one of these as an adult but
they were an excellent lunchbox Edition
when I was a little kid I'd also be
remiss not to talk about mini rolls
these are an iconic British snack what
it is is like a chocolate sponge with
this kind of cream swirl in the middle
surrounded by milk chocolate I'm not
sure why the mini roll is currently
saying I'm rich and famous but good for
the mini roll these are great finally
Cadbury's offers some baked options
which you might find in the bakery
section of your local supermarket these
can include things like donuts and
muffins but the ones I was able to find
today were Flapjack bites in the UK when
we say Flapjacks we don't mean pancakes
which I think Americans can say
sometimes Flapjacks over here are kind
of like oats held together with honey
golden syrup and some other stuff and
these mini cookies
here's everything in the bar dairy milk
chocolate in the UK here's everything
you'll find in a bar of dairy milk
chocolate here in India so the list of
ingredients is pretty much the same in
the UK and in India but the UK uses palm
and sheer fats which is not specifically
listed here in India India goes into a
little bit more detail on the flavorings
used in the chocolate listing natural
vanillin as well as artificial ethyl
vanilla as the name suggests this is the
main component of vanilla bean extract
some kind of vanilla is likely present
in the UK chocolate it's just contained
within the flavorings on the list but
how much chocolate are you actually
getting in your chocolate the food
safety and standards authority of India
has some minimum requirements for what
milk chocolate should contain the rules
are 25 total fat two percent milk fat
2.5 cocoa solids and 10.5 percent milk
solids we have equivalent rules here in
the UK the cocoa and chocolate products
regulations of 2003 set the minimums for
milk chocolate at 25 total fat 5 milk
fat 20 dry cocoa solids 2.5 dry non-fat
cocoa solids and 20 dry milk solids
Cadbury in the UK says its chocolate
contains 23 milk solids and meets the EU
minimum of 20 for Cocoa salads India's
Cadbury packaging says it contains over
22 milk solids so thank you Cadbury for
not being chindi it is interesting that
Indian rules do not have a minimum for
dry fat free cocoa solids in milk
chocolate the dark chocolates however
have a minimum and it's 14 dry cocoa
solids tends to refer to cocoa powder
which is one of the purest forms of
cocoa having more cocoa solids therefore
gives the end product a stronger
chocolate taste
100 grams of dairy milk in the UK
contains the following 100 grams of
dairy milk in India contains the
calories are actually identical the
least healthy bar in the UK is the big
taste toffee whole nut bar one of these
contains 560 calories per 100 grams a
slight increase on Dairy Milk but what
is the least healthy chocolate bar here
in India
it's the dairy milk silk hazelnut 100
grams of this contains 571 calories
which is more than any bar in the UK I
guess it's a win I'm counting it as a
win from calorie counter portion sizes
we wanted to find out all the
differences between Nando's in the UK
and India this is food Wars
if you're ordering chicken for one
person it comes in three sizes of the UK
Nando's
as a quarter chicken
as a half chicken or
as a whole chicken
for one person here in Nando's India
comes in the form of a quarter chicken
which is one piece or a half chicken
which is two pieces you can also get a
whole chicken but it only comes in the
form of a sharing platter the largest of
which is a jumbo platter two whole
chickens and five large sides I'm
excited to eat this but all I need now
is friends so
hit me up
the largest item in the UK is the family
platter it comes with two whole chickens
as well as five large sides a family of
one I can eat this what about some other
things from the Nando's menu well in the
UK you can get a grilled chicken burger
in two sizes as a single or as a double
Nando's India also sells chicken burgers
and offers customers the option to
double their chicken so you can get a
single chicken burger or double it to a
double chicken burger Nando's India
serves chicken wings but only in one
size a pack of four wings from a UK
Nando's come in four portion sizes as a
three piece there's a five piece there's
a ten piece and a 15 piece it's really
weird being the country with the biggest
sizes for a change Joe I miss you now
the classic side for any order of
Nando's in the UK is a side of Peri-Peri
chips I'm allowed to call them chips not
fries because Joey's not in this video
in the UK these come in two sizes
regular and large here in Nando's India
they're advertised not as chips but as
fries because that's what they are Harry
you're weirdo I'm gonna weigh them you
get them in two sizes either regular or
large let me wear the regular
it's a hundred grams on the dot nice
next
418 grams no 408 grams 175 grams in the
large I don't know how to read
here is everything on the menu at a UK
now knows that you won't find in India
this is everything you'll find on the
menu at Nando's India that you will not
find in the UK we'll start with the
chicken now when you order chicken at
Nando's they'll ask you to pick a spice
level we have quite a few of these most
of which are shared with India except
for two firstly we have pimento spice I
think this is limited edition and it
sits somewhere between medium and hot on
the spice scale and our other exclusive
spice is Perry Tamer as the name
suggests this is quite a mild tame spice
it's somewhere between mild and
basically plain chicken I think it's a
slightly sweeter glaze than you might
find on the regular Peri-Peri spice here
in India we just get our chicken in the
classic scale of plain lemon and Herb
mild
hot and extra hot I'm willing to bet
that our extra hot blows the UK extra
hot out of the water you see this tongue
this tongue can take spice oh my God is
this some kind of joke it's like
tickling me it's teasing me with spice
this is Child's Play I will say I love
how the UK Nando's has two extra flavors
I wish India Nando's experimented more
where in India dude there are so many
spices but what we lack in spices we
make up for in Mains number one creamy
cashew chicken with spicy rice
damn good okay now on to the next meal
this is chicken cataplana cataplana is a
type of Portuguese clam shaped stove
cooking pot and they've also served it
with a yogurt dip so using a cataplan is
apparently healthier because you end up
using less fats to cook your meat and
your veggies next up we're having
chicken espetada or as I like to call it
I've been fired from the show 16 times
this season I imagine they take the
piece of chicken put them in skewers put
the marinade so Nando's is a Portuguese
inspired South African restaurant so
most of the recipes are things that were
developed by Portuguese explorers when
they were in South Africa we also have a
lot of Cuisine that's inspired by our
former Colonial overlords back in
Portugal in fact Goa which is a small
estate here in India was where the
Portuguese first settled and so a lot of
the cuisine is derived and inspired by
Portuguese Cuisine we have a couple of
chicken Mains of our own starting with
boneless thighs these come in orders of
four and you can get them in any of the
standard Nando's spice levels and our
other chicken exclusive is this Wing
roulette so Wing roulette is an order of
10 wings and it's a variety of the
Nando's spices the idea is that you'll
get some of these share them with your
friends some of you might get hit with
an extra hot wing whereas others might
get off easy with a mile when I go to
Nando's I'm generally going for medium
or hot I'm not trying to be a hero I'm
going for extra hot I'm just not
actually going to taste the food it's
just going to kind of hurt I may also
add a little bit of the kind of garlic
and herb sauce which adds a little bit
of spice to it or also I've used ketchup
in the past which my friends have
lambasted me for so don't do that
good chicken though we also have some
meal deals these are more affordable
options and you will not find them in
the UK let's start off with the first
one which is pulled chicken sliders oh
my God this is like Gourmet dining I
think I would need to eat three of these
to feel considerably full Unfortunately
they only give you two next up is a
pulled chicken burger
oh my motherload of chicken that is a
lot of pulled chicken it needs a sauce
did I just eat a part that doesn't have
sauce next up we have chicken tegela
which is basically grilled chicken some
corn some roasted veggies and tomato and
this is served with some spicy rice
they've also given like a bunch of
veggies and I was really trying to get
our vitamins in but take a look at the
tegela itself it's got a better rice
underneath but on top there's some
pulled chicken a lot of grilled onions
and a lot of finely chopped capsicum
next up you have the option of a pulled
chicken wrap I mean it looks like a wrap
or you can also get a pulled chicken
pita
damn this looks like a donor Kebab I
guess the true test of whether Nando's
is putting a lot of effort into their
food is whether they're wraps and their
Pita tastes good let's go
miles better than any other fast food
restaurant alongside those you can get a
tub of veggies so next up is chicken
skewers for a kebab eating Nation
good job mandus you get these along with
some pita bread and a couple of Salsas
you get a yogurt sauce and some salsa
next up we have Portuguese chicken and
gravy and if you can't tell from my face
I'm having a great time
oh boy
look at that it looks like there's
Tarkan top dude oh my God what is the
tadka you ask basically it's the best
way to finish up a curry here in India
we take oil heat it add some spices in
there temper them and then pour them
over our Curry and our final meal deal
dish is Saucy chicken strips in spicy
rice I'm not gonna lie this one looks
like the most boring option out of
everything here let's look at some of
the burgers and wraps from Nando's in
the UK we have a couple of exclusive
options firstly we have the sunset
burger if I had to Hazard a guess as to
why this is called the sunset Burger it
might be because you kind of get a
sunset yellow orange red effect going
with the cheese the chicken and the
Chutney which looks very pretty
I haven't had this before I wouldn't
normally order it at Nando's but it's
actually very very good the bun is
slightly different to the regular burger
buns that we get it's a little bit more
kind of spongy and pillowy and that
Chutney stuff is delicious very sweet a
little bit Smoky then we also have the
Fino Peta I really love the packaging of
this it's great for delivery you just
tear straight through the middle not
like that
and then
pop that off
you have a nicely preserved upright
bitter now in a filo Pizza you get
chicken thighs you get some salad you
get Pyrenees you get halloumi and I
think there's also some caramelized
onions in there as well I'll be honest
I'm going to Nando's this is what I'm
getting it's kind of got all my favorite
Nando's things in one little package
they took it off the menu for the
pandemic they've recently brought it
back which I am thrilled about because I
missed it dearly
The Cheeky Nando's levels
off the charts right now we have a
couple of exclusive burgers and wrap
flavors of our own starting with the
chicken Caesar salad wrap
like their packaging
let's see how this tastes
that is a messed up way to eat a wrap
eat it from the top not from the side
please nikhil
wow next up is the berry cheeseburger
which also comes as a wrap or in Pita
form look at the juice is dripping off
this thing man
that's what I'm talking about this
flavor has just achen India by storm in
the past few decades it's part of the
trifecta of ingredients that are red
velvet matcha and Peri Peri the people
just love to put into every menu over
here Peri-Peri if you don't know is a
spice mix that was discovered by
Portuguese explorers when they were
settling slash pillaging South African
countries like South Africa and
Mozambique on the subject of foreigners
coming to a place and taking things from
it I would like to formally apologize to
India from the UK feel free to come and
take your stuff back from the British
museum whatever's convenient I feel like
most Indians identify Peri Peri as the
little packets of Peri Peri you get at
McDonald's and you pour them into your
fries and shake them to get Peri-Peri
fries I feel like when they come to
Nando's they might find it not spicy
enough if you don't eat meat now this is
actually pretty good for vegetarian and
vegan options in the UK first up we have
the great imitator wrap it doesn't look
very appealing right now however the
great imitator is Nando's version of
fake chicken I think it's made with pea
protein and by all accounts I've heard
it's pretty good then we have the beanie
Burger
as the name would suggest it's a bean
Patty also comes with I believe an
egg-free Mayo some salad as well then we
have a spiced chickpea Burger it's kind
of similar to the beanie Burger however
once again as the name would suggests
the Patty is predominantly made of
chickpeas this one actually mirrors the
sunset Burger a little more because it's
got the same bun and also has some of
that red pepper Chutney and then finally
we have a portobello mushroom and
halloumi Pitta it's a pita bread with a
big portobello mushroom inside as well
as some salad some halloumi and more of
that red pepper Chutney pretty much
every fast food restaurant here in India
serves vegetarian food because a huge
percentage of the country is vegetarian
having said that Nando's actually had
quite a few non-vegetarian options which
is very cool to see in a restaurant like
this so let's go off the list of
vegetarian food now starting with creamy
cashew paneer and spicy rice so this is
the same thing as the creamy cashew
chicken except they've replaced it with
chunks of cottage cheese and it just
looks delicious let's see if Nando's has
done paneer right
it's really nice and it's not as chewy
it's soft soft paneer at a fast food
chain unheard of the next vegetarian
dish is called something exotic it's a
mystery even they don't know what it
could be and it is
what the heck I okay I did not expect to
see this it's watermelon and paneer
you know Nando's watermelon and paneer
you really are walking the line between
creativity and Abomination
no those are kind of weird together but
I think overall this is a fun dish and
they serve it along with a three bean
salad the three beans are
chickpea rajma and some other one let's
taste
then this is flavorful what's going on
okay now we're moving on to a vegetarian
version of the cataplana they have
tossed the same vegetables but this time
along with paneer and some chickpea I
don't taste the chickpea
very nice this is easily the best food
I've had in food Wars
hands
okay next up we have a vegetarian
version of the espetada as well
look at this
it's probably the best wedge skewer I've
seen in my life it's just too beautiful
I can't eat it I must frame this
in my home also they serve garlic bread
because this isn't enough apparently the
first one is a veg burger they serve it
with coleslaw
it's a runnable frozen patty it's all
right this is probably the most
underwhelming thing on the menu so far
and finally they have a mushroom and
paneer Burger both of these options you
can get along with a wrap or pita
they have put a huge chunk of paneer in
there have you seen a paneer this big I
didn't even know they made this
Super Burger when there's good food in
the show I'm so happy and that's not all
there are more vegetarian options from
the meal deal section let's go from the
top first off we have wedge sliders
these ones have patties instead of
pulled chicken next up you can get a veg
together this one has paneer so same
thing it's a bed of rice some chopped
veggies on top with paneer as the
protein it's served along with potato
wedges next up we have paneer skewers
that you can get along with either spice
rice or with some pita bread very
similar to the skewers we had with
chicken and they seem to have the same
sauce as well they served along with
either pita bread or spice rice you can
choose which option of side and you also
get a salsa as well as a yogurt dip I
always feel like it's hard to do skewers
with paneer because it's such a delicate
ingredient that if you fry too much it
gets too rubbery oh is that a piece of
pineapple then oh it's a lot of thought
put into these dishes Nando's is a class
apart it's just a class apart and
finally we have a very simple option at
the end it's a roasted veg and some
grilled paneer I'd probably skip this
one next up the UK exclusive starters
first up we've got some sweet potato
wedges and garlic Pyrenees
for some reason they've also mixed in a
bunch of regular chips as well I don't
know if that's normal because I'm
traditionally not going to order sweet
potato fries if you've watched free Wars
for a long time you'll know my thoughts
on sweet potato namely that they are bad
it's just like someone took a chip
and went how can we make this floppier
I know
the garlic Pyrenees however very tasty
would recommend getting a side of this
next time you're in Nando's also
exclusive to the UK are Peri Peri nuts
you can start your meal off with a
combination of I think cashews almonds
and maybe macadamia nuts all coated in
their signature Peri-Peri spice I'm
usually pretty good at this let's find
out
in the UK you can also get fried
halloumi sticks and a dip of your choice
however unfortunately the restaurant
forgot ours here's what they're supposed
to look like
neither of these are exclusive but in
both countries you can also start with
hummus and olives India has a variety of
options starting with the cheesy Fiesta
phrase seems pretty straightforward but
let's see if it is a fiesta oh my God
bro that presentation is off the charts
look at this
every Marvel at the presentation
okay I will say these have been in the
cold for a while so they may not taste
as good as when they're fresh
I am right next up they have cheesy
Fiesta Chicken
boom let's pull chicken grilled onions
same cheese and I imagine there's fries
underneath next up they have something
called the sweet potato and corn snack
whoa why is their food so beautiful it's
gone there's uh bits of red paprika some
chopped parsley but also it's pieces of
thinly sliced lemon
that's new
oh
are you supposed to eat that it's
interesting I don't know if I'd serve
lemon pieces in my salad next up we have
uh four piece wings but these ones are
spicy Tangy Wings they look quite
delicious
sprinkle some lemon on there
I'm disproportionately jealous of that
little lemon wedge with the wings why
don't we have that very little touch
lovely bit of freshness to your wing
forget about it I have to be honest
pretty blind not tasting any spice not
getting any Tang these are the most
underwhelming things on the menu so far
and now for something I did not expect
to see on the Nando's menu at all we
have a creamy cashew paneer and chicken
naan more like Nando's am I right guys
bro
why is all their food looking like art
that I can hang up on my wall okay so
this naan has the chicken so this is the
non-veg naan
let's go ahead and take a bite see how
it tastes
it was damn good the gravy on top is
very similar to a butter chicken it's
got a lot of sweetness and richness you
can tell there's cashew in it but
they've also sprinkled on a lot of green
chili some coriander and chopped onions
so there is a nice thicker spice and
they just drizzled a lot of Malai on top
so it's creamy this is what it would be
like if India had to have a pizza
banging also they serve it with
something called perines dip are you
sure this is for this
let's just avoid
it's just like a huge tub of mayonnaise
for those looking for a healthier option
Nando's also offers salads there are two
main options in the UK firstly we have
this quinoa and Peri tomato salad this
actually looks pretty good I have to say
it looks like kind of sun-dried tomatoes
some lettuce some dressing some of these
little crunchy Crouton cracker things
and of course quinoa and our other salad
option is the delightfully named Rainbow
Bowl
now the very colorful rainbow bowl comes
with some hummus some coleslaw some
tennis and broccoli there's some grains
down in the corner and I think some
shredded carrot as well I love
tenderstem broccoli and we'll fight for
the deaf tennis and broccoli
by default the salads come plain but you
can also add chicken breast chicken
thighs fake chicken or beanie patties to
any of them here at Nando's India we
have salad options of our all starting
with the Mediterranean salad
is that something Mediterranean next up
we have an Algarve salad looks pretty
much the same minus the olives plus some
cashew nuts and a lot of sun-dried chili
or tomatoes then we have a quinoa salad
for those of you who are monsters and
can't eat rice like a normal person and
finally we have a Caesar salad and the
Caesar salad comes with a dressing now
all of those salads we ordered are
vegetarian but you can optionally get
some chicken strips if you need more
protein in there then we're on to the
sides in the UK you can get quite a few
exclusive sites to go along with your
Peri-Peri chips first up we have rainbow
slaw which is coleslaw filled with
Skittles no it's not it's just Coastal
but kind of colorful we also have a
mixed leaf salad
a little box of leaves oh there's some
tomato and cucumber in there as well
this one is spiced grains with butternut
squash
which actually sounds pretty good some
grains in there I think that's feta
cheese
some green beans and butternut squash
next up we have creamy mashed potato
it's mashed potato you can also get a
side of just some long stem broccoli
this one looks a little more sad than
the one that was on the salad but still
great
here's some garlic in there as well nice
touch and then finally we can get Macho
peas
peas for Macho men just like me
I wasn't really sure where to put these
but there are a couple of extra things
which you can add on to pretty much any
order so I guess they kind of count as
sides first up you can just buy a couple
of pieces of grilled halloumi from
anandos in the UK for those of you who
don't know halloumi is a cheese which I
think is made with sometimes a mixture
of sheep and goat's milk predominantly
produced in Cyprus it's an interesting
cheese when you bite into it it doesn't
really give it's got a kind of like
rubbery texture I personally find it
very satisfying to eat as do a lot of
British people I think we're responsible
for something like 80 of the Cypress
halloumi consumption in the world which
is kind of wild but yeah it's pretty
good
it like squeaks on your teeth when you
eat it the other sorts of side options
include just one whole portobello
mushroom
this might have looked okay when it was
hot you can also just get a single plain
tortilla from Nando's
I guess the idea is that you could kind
of buy maybe the halloumi the mushroom
and a couple of other bits and sauces
and create your own wrap or own burrito
situation
personally
don't think it's worth doing that just
buy a pre-assembled one options for
sides here at an Indian Nando's you can
get potato wedgies I already showed
veggies no no they're not veggies
they're potato wedges run in the middle
potato veggies you can also get some
Char grilled veg in fact they give you a
lot you can also get a three bean salad
which looks really colorful and has like
a soupy liquid that I want to try
lentil soup you say nay I want three
bean salad water
next up we have a Portuguese salad it
looks pretty straightforward I have no
idea what makes this Portuguese is it
the olives probably and finally you can
just get a tub of feta cheese they've
given me six cubes of feta cheese
yeah
cool Nando's actually has quite a few
dessert options in the UK if you're in
store many of the shops will have an
option for bottomless frozen yogurt so
you can have that in the flavors of
vanilla strawberry chocolate or mango
install and also on delivery you can get
a few more options including a Nauti
nata this is Nando's take on a
Portuguese egg custard tart AKA Pasto de
nada
probably butcher the pronunciation of
that if I take myself out to Nando's and
I'm feeling uh bougie I'll probably end
my meal with one of these because I love
these things we can also get a salted
caramel brownie
it's very pretty it's got little gold
sprinkles on it
I'm describing More Foods as pretty it's
been the theme of today but they are
kind of pretty
next we have a chocolate cake
which is a slice of what looks like a
pretty good gooey kind of indulgent
chocolate cake
it's pretty moist and then we also have
this gooey caramel cheesecake
this is actually really good I'm a
cheesecake fan but this is a great
example of a cheesecake I had it for the
first time I think when we filmed the UK
versus US Nando's go watch it now highly
recommend we don't shed any desserts
with the UK but we have our own desserts
starting with an ice cream and hot
chocolate where they don't deliver it so
here's an image of it I guess looks
pretty good looks nice then we have a
series of cakes starting with a
chocolate cake it's parcel in a burger
case which is kind of weird but dude
look at this it's a thick moist
fat cake I must taste for science
appropriately humid next up a red velvet
cake what did I say the trifecta of
ingredients I am surprised there's no
matcha milkshake at the end of this they
have to fit in red velvet in every
restaurant Peri-Peri red velvet and
matcha
and finally we have an out and out
cheesecake honestly all these desserts
are okay I probably skip the dessert
here last but by no means least let's
talk about the drinks if you go into a
restaurant at Fernando's in the UK you
can get bottomless fizzy drinks
including coke diet coke Coke Zero
Sprite and Fanta now some people will
ask for a free glass of tap water and
then use that other fizzy drink
fountains to help themselves to free
fizzy drinks but I personally have
definitely never done that and would not
encourage that kind of flagrantly
illegal Behavior whatsoever
on delivery we do also have a few
exclusive drink options first options
are these bottle green cordials for
those of you who aren't familiar with
cordials it's like a flavor concentrate
so what you'll do is you'll put a few
splashes of this into a glass top it up
with water and then you have a drink
which you can actually consume I kind of
thought these would come pre-mixed so I
was a little bit surprised to see just
bottles of The Cordial itself but I
guess if you can make yourself some
squash at home this is Rooibos
right out
robust teas which are flavored with
things like lemon
Peach and Berry and finally we have
gingerella by Karma drinks this is just
a ginger ale
we can also get bottomless soda refills
here in India but our bottled options
are fresh lime soda and two iced tea
options I don't know if fresh
temperature is a big thing abroad but
over here in India it is the number one
drink for middle class families when you
go out with your family each person of
the family has a different order for
fresh thyme soda Some Like It with just
salt some like a just sweet Some Like It
with sweet and salt and some monsters
like it with no salt or sugar this is
from a company called Brew House a tea
brewing company this is supposed to be a
Mojito lemon iced tea
it's nice and next a peach iced tea
Nando's also offers these drinks called
designer drinks which seem to be
non-alcoholic soft drink cocktails it
seems like they just took seven up and
Blended them to form different flavors
with different colors but I'm curious to
see if they actually taste good color
color which color do you choose let's
try the Virgin mojito ah tastes like a
Mojito without the alcohol
you can see they've gone the extra mile
they're put in fresh lemon a lot of mint
in there
next one is Citra which I assume is a
Mandarin slash orange flavor dream
very delicious super refreshing I
thought this could be something we could
make fun of Nando's for but they've
actually made some delicious refreshing
drinks if dip do the cat's got the flu
the dogs got the chickenpox and so have
you Portuguese lemonade let's go what
makes it Portuguese I don't know maybe
it's olive oil let's see this is really
um so it's not all sweet it has like
some sort of powder at the bottom is it
Peri-Peri powder I don't know but it
tastes like Chaat powder that they put
in a lot of lemon sodas here in India
and it's really yum Peach and
elderflower they've actually put
it's in there these are certified
designer drinks
half a chicken Peri-Peri chips and
garlic bread at a UK Nando's will cost
you 13 pounds and 10 pence that same
meal in India will cost you rupees 869
which at the time of filming this video
is equal to 9.85 pounds that's almost 25
percent cheaper of a meal than the one
in the UK okay now while you Brits might
feel hard done by because of these price
differences I must say that this is
actually super expensive for a single
meal for a single person here in India
in fact most people in this country
would find that almost aspirational you
can get meals here for close to 100
rupees that's less than a pound I would
say that I can't even consider this fast
food it is the most expensive restaurant
we've tried here on food Wars but the
food was Top Class throughout so I guess
it makes sense now Nando's does have
some slightly more affordable options in
the form of meal deals where you can get
a single meal for around 400 rupees
which is equal to 4.5 pounds this
doesn't seem like a significant upgrade
and it isn't in fact the state that
we're filming this video is Karnataka
here in India and the daily wage is
around 500 rupees so you would have to
literally work an entire day to afford a
single meal here in Nando's in fact my
first salary as an intern was 10 000
rupees per month which is 125 pounds per
month and so if I ordered a cheeky
Nando's it would literally be nearly one
tenth of my entire monthly salary I'm
not sure I'd consider Nando is an
affordable option in the UK and I'm not
even really sure I'd consider it fast
food it sit somewhere in that kind of
fast casual bracket combining elements
of fast food restaurants with elements
of the more traditional dining
experience some Brits don't really like
Nando's and might claim that it's kind
of overrated I personally love Nando's
it's fast it's consistent and I have a
kind of cultural attachment to it as I
was kind of a teenager when it really
blew up in popularity here in the UK I
might be able to get more value for
money at somewhere like a KFC but to me
it wouldn't hit the same
unfortunately Nando's in the UK doesn't
disclose a full ingredients list Nando's
in India also doesn't disclose a full
ingredient list so what do we know about
the food well the FAQ pages on our
respective websites do share some clues
for example in the UK Nando says it uses
red tractor assured chicken from British
Farms to be red track to certified
chickens must be raised with certain
benefits such as no cages and natural
light the Indian FAQ page says that all
of Nando's Chicken in India is sourced
from India and it's all cage-free they
also say that all the chickens are a
grade now I don't know what this means
because it's hard to keep up with
up-to-date poultry practices here in
India but one report from 2012 said that
a top grade chicken must be free of
deformities that detract from its
appearance or that affect the normal
distribution of Flesh slight deformities
such as slightly curved or dented breast
bones and slightly curved backs may be
present now this sounds kind of vague
but I do hope that Nando's is following
this practice and only sourcing some a
grade chickens because that's what it
tasted like some a great
one other thing we can gleam from the
FAQ page is that the great imitator wrap
might not be as plant-based as Nando's
seems to think it is this is because
both the tortilla wrap and also the
glaze used on the chicken contains
shellac Sherlock is a substance used in
food as a glazing agent but it's found
in various other things such as nail
polish fireworks and sealants The Twist
is that it's technically an animal
product it's a resin secreted by lack
beetles female lack beetles will secrete
it onto trees in the forests of India
and Thailand where it's then harvested
processed and sold for use the bugs
countless animals for the purpose of
veganism I'm a meat eater so I can't
really talk but in my opinion I don't
think a bug should count I think that's
fine you know what Harry up till now I
didn't get the whole cheeky Nando's meme
but now I kinda get it I feel like
they're having a lot of fun with all the
food that they're serving and I had so
much fun eating all of the food I feel
like India should have its own version
of The Cheeky Nando's we're going to
call it the chalu nandos because chalu
means kind of cheeky in Hindi